Bis zum nächsten Mal.
So, MonkaS.
Oh, Windows hat die Soundsettings nicht verkackt diesmal.
Nice.
Ich hab nicht gut gepennt heute Nacht.
Keine Ahnung, wie lange ich an bin.
Ich muss gerade mal mein Headset entwirren.
WTF?
Wie kann sich ein Headset, was ich nicht absichtlich verknote, von alleine immer so?
Leute, ich wurde gescampt.
Amazon Marketplace.
Ich habe mir ein Billig-Headset bestellt.
Äh, kein Billig-Headset, ein Billig-Kopfhörer.
Die gleichen Billig-Kopfhörer, die ich auch sonst so verwende.
wenn ich jetzt nicht hier gerade mein
mein teures Headset auf hab
mein Bionamix Headset auf hab
weil das Bionamix Headset so gut das ist
ja, es ist ja letztendlich
ein DT770 mit einem halbwegs
gescheiten Mikrofon
das Ding ist
das ist nice
aber das ist halt geschlossen, du hast komplett
komplett die Badewanne
wenn du es so willst, auf den
auf den Ohren, das ist hier so
beim Streamen und so ist das alles ganz nice
Aber wenn man einfach nur vorm Rechner sitzt
Und vielleicht auch mal hören will
Wenn es klingelt an der Tür
Oder irgendwie wenn das Telefon klingelt
Oder wenn das Handy klingelt
Ist das nicht so gut
Deswegen habe ich so einen billigen normalen Kopfhörer
Und der ist kaputt
Der geht nur noch auf einer Seite
Ich sehe auch warum
Das Kabel ist auf der einen Seite kaputt
Und da guckt das Kupfer raus
Das ist wahrscheinlich einfach
8 Jahre oder so mal kaputt
und deswegen
dachte ich mir so, hey, muss man
ein neues kaufen, aber
WTF, okay, müssen wir gleich nochmal
schön bannen, exzellent
exzellent
bannen
so, bevor die Modkis
da sind. Zumindest wurde ich gescampt.
Ich habe mir vor zwei Wochen oder so,
das ist schon eine ganze Weile her,
habe ich mir bei Amazon noch
den gleichen billigen Kopfhörer
nochmal bestellt, den ich die ganze
Zeit verwendet habe.
Und da stand
jetzt ein Tag, nachdem ich bestellt habe,
stand da, wurde versendet.
Und
das Ding ist, angeblich
laut Amazon, wurde es mit der
deutschen Post versendet, hat aber eine
Tracking-Nummer von
äh,
wie heißt das?
US Mail oder so?
Irgendeine
Ami-Mail-Firma.
Und
egal, wo man nach dieser Tracking-Nummer sucht,
das gibt nix und finde nix. Ich glaube, ich wurde
gescampt. Ich warte jetzt
noch ab, weil die
haben gesagt, ey, bis
17. spätestens ist es da.
Was auch immer das für ein
Versanddienstleister sein soll,
der irgendwie drei Wochen oder so braucht.
Das kommt angeblich aus Bulgarien, der Kopfhörer.
Also mal schauen.
So, und ich gehe davon aus, ich wurde gescampt.
Da muss ich irgendwie über Amazon
so einen Case oder so aufmachen,
weil ich habe es ja alles über Amazon abgewickelt.
Also das Geld werde ich wahrscheinlich schon wieder kriegen.
Aber es fuckt mich ab, ey.
Den ganzen Scammer.
Basten, Alter.
Jetzt habe ich mir den gleichen Kopfhörer nochmal bestellt
Woanders
Kostet auch ein bisschen weniger
Hoffe ich mal, dass ich da nicht nochmal gescapt werde
Warum will ich meine VM anmachen?
Das ist Fail
Ich will überhaupt nicht meine VM anmachen
Ich will meine Linux Mini PC anmachen
Dann kann ich euch mal was
ein nices zeigen was ich geproggert habe.
Linux Mini PC.
Jawoll.
Das verdammte Spiel.
Der echte Gangster.
Der war einfach seiner Zeit voraus.
Der hätte heute 5 Millionen Abos auf YouTube.
Genauso wie der Asi-Tony.
Hallo?
Please starten mini pc starten jetzt
Bios date 2024 okay, na gut doch der rechner der mini pc schon ein paar tage alt es kann tatsächlich sein dass es von
2024 ist
Ich habe nicht gut geschlafen wieder probleme
so sagt das immer wenn der stream richtig angelaufen ist wenn ihr am start zeit leute
dann zeige ich euch aber ich weiß es gibt es aktuell nur ziemlich prüft auf prüft auf
konzept aber wenn ihr ich funktioniert schon ganz nice aber vorher müssen wir
mal abdecken nein nein nein das wollen wir nicht machen wir wollen abdecken und danach
der fond ja da sind irgendwelche random unicode zeichen die halt aussehen wie buchstaben
aber du solltest die nachricht eigentlich nicht mehr sehen ich habe alles gelöscht
Alles weg.
Aber je nachdem, was du hast, wenn du FFZ oder so hast,
dann kannst du ja auch gelöschte Nachrichten
wieder anzeigen.
Ja, die wissen schon, warum.
Die sind erfahren im Spammen.
Oh.
Na gut.
Was, die sind groß?
Haben wir die markiert?
Ne, bei mir nicht.
Wenn ich die markiere, sind die ganz normal.
Hattest du damals auch das Problem,
dass die Terminaleingabe so extrem laggt?
Gelaggt haben?
Unter Arch-based System
mit Wayland, unter VMware Workstation.
Ja, du kannst
Wayland nicht gescheit verwenden unter
VMware Workstation. Das ist das Problem.
Deswegen bin ich ja mittlerweile nicht mehr
auf VMware Workstation, sondern das hier ist ein
Das ist ein Mini-PC.
Das ist ein Mini-PC
mit einem 8-Kern-Ryzen
und einer mobilen AMD-Grafikkarte.
Das ist ja auch eines der Gründe,
warum ich das gemacht habe mit dem Mini-PC.
Weil Wayland in VMware einfach
reudisch ist. Einfach nicht
richtig funktioniert.
Guck mal, ich habe Z installiert.
Das wusste ich gar nicht. Z ist übrigens richtig
nice.
Ich habe mir ein Video dazu angeguckt.
Das wollte ich mal im Stream mit euch ausprobieren.
Aber das ist normal. Wayland und
auf einmal Workstation kannst du komplett vergessen.
Das ist einfach
nur Schrott.
Leider. Ja, und vor allem, man macht auch keine
Anstalten, da irgendwie was zu fixen.
Es gibt ja ein paar neue Projekte auf GitHub.
Die wollte ich mit euch auch mal ausprobieren.
Was machen wir da?
Nein, das jetzt, jetzt machen wir das nicht.
Die wollte ich mit, also ein neues Projekt gibt's.
Der kann angeblich,
zahlt euch fest, der kann angeblich
Linux virtualisieren, unter Windows,
mit
GPU.
Der benutzt unter der Haube,
also dieses,
also Hyper-V, beziehungsweise das Framework,
muss man eigentlich sagen, das Framework
unter Hyper-V. Ich hab vergessen,
wie das Haus,
hier, Framework unter Hyper-V
Windows,
wie heißt das labert wieder dass das
ist es gibt es gibt so ein komisches
windows vm framework virtualisierungs
framework management
Okay, keine Ahnung wie das heißt
Es gibt
Die KI kannst du ganz vergessen
Es gibt mittlerweile unter Windows 11
Ein Framework zur Virtualisierung
Von Microsoft
Darauf baut glaube ich auch Hyper-V auf
Aber das kann man auch so verwenden
Und ich habe ein Projekt gefunden
Auf GitHub, kann ich euch mal zeigen
Das probieren wir im Stream auch mal aus
Das kann angeblich
Mit diesem Framework
unter Windows Linux
virtualisieren.
So.
Aber mit
GPU. Und zwar
mit diesem, ich bin mir
nicht ganz sicher, wie das heißt, so GPU
Slicing oder sowas in der Richtung.
Also sprich, du kannst quasi
einen Teil von deiner Host-GPU
partitionieren quasi.
Ich glaube, partitionieren nennt sich das da.
Und an eine VM
durchreichen. Das ist
nicht so einfach, weil die 4M
die passenden Treiber dafür braucht und die
Windows-Seite auch passen muss.
Wahrscheinlich ist das unter der Haube auch ein bisschen
das, was WSL macht. Keine Ahnung.
Zumindest kann man da angeblich, wie gesagt,
muss man mal ausprobieren, kann man
Linux virtualisieren unter Windows
mit voller GPU
Acceleration und
auch Hardware
Video Decoder und sowas. Wenn
das funktioniert, wäre das eigentlich mega
nice und vor allem eine Workstation kann komplett
einpacken leider ist das projekt selber leider ist das buch nicht das nennt sich
nicht para virtualisieren das nennt sich irgendwie anders in dem fall das nennt
sich etwas recht du hast recht heißt so gpu pv ja genau hier damit kann er das
irgendwie kann sie mir die kleine grafikkarte so partitionieren und
weiter weiterreichen zumindest muss man das mal ausprobieren wenn das
funktioniert ist das mega nice und vor allem
bei Workstation braucht kein Mensch mehr unter Windows.
Ich habe ein bisschen das Gefühl,
das Projekt ist noch
nicht so alt.
Und
ich lese hier ganz oft irgendwas
von Agents und Gedöns
auf der Seite. Also vielleicht
ist das auch gar nicht.
Ist damit auch 144 Hertz möglich?
Das ist die...
Nee, hier. Fixed 1080p
60 Hertz
fps display aber es ist ja schon mal einen riesen gewinn wirst es vor mwm wenn du volle
gpu unterstützung hast und hardware video decoder und alles da kann ich zumindest unter linux im
desktop auch mit 60 fps leben vielleicht kann man das ja vielleicht kann man gibt es auch eine
config dass das experiment geht nein da muss nicht hyper wie aktiv sein das ist ja das coole da steht
hier auch, guck,
das funktioniert, und wenn man Windows 11
ohne Hyper-V,
das braucht aber,
das braucht dieses
Windows,
Framework installiert, was es
quasi
Windows
HCN
APIS, was auch immer das
bedeutet, ja, das ist quasi
das worauf Hyper-V letztendlich wieder basiert.
Das ist richtig nice.
Wie gesagt, wir probieren das auch mal im Stream aus.
Ich habe halt das Gefühl,
weil hier oft was von Agent
drin steht, dass er diese
Desktop-Virtualisierung gar nicht als Hauptanwendungszweck
hat für diese
Software. Auf der anderen Seite,
hier steht explizit drin,
Full Windows Ubuntu Desktop
VM, Complete Graphic OS
with GPU Acceleration.
Also
ist wohl auch
im
Projektscope, das man dann mit Desktop
virtualisiert. Ich habe also ein bisschen das Gefühl,
dass das Projekt relativ neu ist noch,
dass da wahrscheinlich noch ein paar
grundlegende Sachen fehlen werden.
Keine Ahnung, ob Sound richtig, wobei Sound
stand hier, glaube ich, da Sound geht. Ja, aber keine Ahnung,
ob Sound gescheit richtig funktioniert.
Keine Ahnung, ob da beispielsweise
KDE richtig drunter funktioniert.
Keine Ahnung, ob Copy-Paste richtig
funktioniert. Keine Ahnung, ob
Key-Pass-Through und
Escapen aus der VM richtig
funktioniert. Keine Ahnung, ob Fullscreen
richtig... Fullscreen funktioniert glaube ich schon nicht
richtig, was ja so Game Changer ist.
Wenn du eine VM nicht im Fullscreen betreiben
kannst, ist das halt irgendwie Mist, ja.
Da gibt es hier einen Feature Request, dass es wohl irgendwie
kein Fullscreen kann.
Ja, das sind halt alles so Dinger,
das braucht noch ein bisschen.
Ich hoffe, ich hoffe, ja.
Ich hoffe, das Ding...
Also, ich hoffe, dass Desktop Virtualisierung
Fokus ist, weil ganz ehrlich,
dann kann mein Linux
mini pc also wenn das mal irgendwann gut funktionieren sollte kann man linux mini pc
tatsächlich wieder einpacken weil so so so nice dass hier ist native linux mini pc naja aber der
sagt er hier explizit das volle volle vm support ja also so nice dass hier ist ja eine native
linux mini pc zu haben und das funktioniert auch gut gegen die power von einem 24 kerne
desktop cpu plus 40 90 gtx rtx 40 90 kann halt der mini pc keinsterweise anstecken deswegen
wie gesagt das probieren wir im stream aus so leute soll ich euch mal zeigen was ich
massive nice es geprogrammert habe was ich finde das zumindest massive nice was auch immer
MaxAd
Jaja, das kann weg
Vielen Dank für den Sub
16 Jahre, excellent Subscription
Dankeschön
So, hier sind wir auf dem Raspberry Pi
SSH, Copy ID
Machen wir mal, schadet auf jeden Fall nichts
Okay
Leute, ich hab was richtig nice, das programmiert
Ich hoffe, dass jetzt nicht der
By the way, nicht der Fiat Champ
Der Fiat Champ, den muss ich mal archivieren so langsam, ey.
Vier Jahre kein Absatz mehr.
Guck mal hier.
Der SSH Champ ist jetzt am Start, Leute.
Der SSH Champ.
Der SSH Champ hat eine exzellente Projektbeschreibung, eine exzellente Readme.
Und ich meine das wortwörtlich.
Das ist nicht dafür gedacht, irgendwie zu benutzen.
Aber ich zeige euch trotzdem mal, was der SSH Champ macht, okay?
Also, ursprünglich habe ich das Ganze entwickelt für mich auf der Arbeit,
weil ich da oftmals das Problem habe,
Ich bin per SSH auf dem Server
Möchte per SSH
Also ne umgedreht
Ich bin per SSH auf dem Server, guckt mir da irgendwelche Logs an
Möchte mir die Logs runterziehen auf meine lokale Kiste
Dazu muss man immer SCP'en
Zumal wir noch über ihren extra Proxy-Hop gehen
Heißt im Endeffekt, das ist eklig
So und jetzt habe ich, ich habe was gebaut
Ich zeige euch das jetzt mal
Server-Admins werden das
Zusetzen wissen
Ich muss mir mal grad mal
Ich hoffe ich kann das hier bilden überhaupt
Gescheit
Und ich hoffe, ich werde jetzt nicht gleich Supply Chain
Attacked
Okay, go
Go build it
Also so, Leute, der SSH
Der SSH Champ ist am Start
Jetzt zeige ich euch das Ganze mal
Was der SSH Champ macht
Ich hoffe, Leute, ich hoffe, es funktioniert
Ja, ich hoffe, es funktioniert
Es kann sein, dass es jetzt Vorführeffekt ist
Und ich gestern Abend, weil ich hab gestern Abend hier noch was
Committed, guck mal
Massive geile Comet Messages
Also ich hab gestern Abend noch Zeug committet
Ich hoffe
Ich hoffe ich hab's nicht kaputt gemacht
Gestern Abend noch
Das kann sein
Also passt mal auf
Der SSH-Champ ist ein SSH-Rapper
Das ist dafür gedacht ein Alias zu sein
Auf
Auf SSH
Im Endeffekt wenn's fertig ist
Mit Autocompletion
Wie SSH komplette Option Pass
zu ssh es ist am ende kein unterschied ob du den ssh champ oder ssh verwendest bis auf ein
paar zusätzliche features das ist quasi ein enhanced ssh aber ich benutze das jetzt mal
so soll wir verbinden uns jetzt hier max at ich glaube 2.55 so guck mal jetzt bin ich bei ssh auf
meinem raspberry pi drauf wie ssh ok also das kann man auch alias ich kann euch das auch mal zeigen
sprich wenn ich hier wenn ich hier sage hier minus minus help dann bekomme ich dann bekomme
ich die hilfe von ssh also das ist wirklich als eins zu eins rapper um ssh gedacht was ssh ein
hans und alles auch an optionen weiter leitet das heißt man muss ich hier gar nichts großartig
überlegen man kann weiter port vorwording machen man kann es auch proxys über ssh machen also
überhaupt kein problem es ist es ist quasi einfach wirklich nur von der minus v oder was ist minus
Version. Was ist denn bei SSH? Keine Ahnung.
Es ist einfach nur ein Rapper um SSH.
Also nur ein Rapper ist gut.
Also wenn ihr euch das Projekt anguckt, das ist schon...
Ähm...
Wie konnte man noch mal
Line of Codes zählen?
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Glock war das da, oder?
Ja. Also aktuell...
Pearl Monka...
W! Gibt's da nicht irgendwas besseres?
Moment.
Count Line...
Count Line of Code.
gibt's da nicht?
Slot count. Kann das nicht
Bad oder so irgendwas machen? Na zumindest,
ihr seht's ja hier, also da ist schon,
da ist schon ein bisschen, by the way, ist die Soundqualität
von mir eigentlich okay?
Ich, ich hab, ich hab am
Freitag notgetrunken ein bisschen
bla bla bla, test, test, ja.
Dankeschön für den Follow.
Ich hab am Freitag ein bisschen beim Audiointerface
gezwungen, da hast du rumgespielt,
weil ich die Headsets
umstöpseln musste, ja.
So, also Massive SSH Champ, weiter geht's
Also ihr seht schon hier, da gibt's ein paar Dateien
Ja, gibt's auch hier ein bisschen, ist alles in Go natürlich, weil es Self-Contained Binary
Ist der SSH Champ mit AI entstanden?
Der SSH Champ ist nicht Vibe-Coded, dass ich quasi einem Agent gesagt hab, ich brauch das und das
Aber es ist ein paar Sachen supported by AI
Ja, ihr wisst ja, ich frage ganz gerne mal, weil ich was programmiert habe, Copy-Paste an AI, hier fällt dir irgendein Fehler auf, habe ich an irgendwas nicht gedacht, kann man das irgendwie schöner machen? Also ein paar Sachen sind korrigiert bei AI.
Ja, zum Beispiel eine Sache kann ich dir zeigen, die ist korrigiert bei AI, weil ich keine Ahnung hatte, wie ich das fehlerfrei auf die Reihe kriegen sollte.
Das Ding kann Desktop-Notifications verschicken.
Ja, und das ist von mir hier alles.
Wobei, nee, das stimmt noch nicht mehr. Das ist auch nicht von mir.
Ja, also das hier ist im Prinzip von mir.
Ja, aber die Sache, wie ich Desktop-Notifications schicke, ganz ehrlich, da habe ich Obrus gefragt, wie das funktioniert.
funktioniert weil bis ich mir das von hand raus gesucht hätte hätte ich zwei
stunden da ist ein bisschen scheiß funktioniert sie ist auch eine dumm
kommentar das ist halt dass das halt copy paste aus opus hier das der rest
aber es ist also es ist wirklich wenig generiert also dass das ist alles wie
gesagt aus ich weiß alles von hand gebastelt die ganzen ui dinger sind von
hand gebastelt hier das zeug ist von hand gewagt gebastelt also es ist also
es ist korrigiert bei AI.
So, genau. Jetzt kann ich euch mal
zeigen, was das Ganze macht. Also wie gesagt,
massive, nice SSH-Wrapper.
So.
Also wir verbinden uns jetzt damit per SSH
auf eine, auf den
Raspberry Pi. Und Leute, ich hoffe,
es funktioniert. Wenn es auf dem Raspberry Pi
nicht funktioniert, dann habe ich irgendwas
verkackt, beziehungsweise an irgendwas nicht gedacht.
Dann zeige ich es euch
auf einer anderen Linux-Kiste per SSH.
Okay, also ihr seid jetzt hier ganz normal per SSH drauf.
Ihr könnt euch Sachen angucken.
So, und jetzt gucken wir mal hier in die Becher C zum Beispiel rein.
Das ist die Standard Becher C hier, ohne irgendwas Spezielles drin.
Und wir können einfach was anlegen hier.
Guck, touch, cute, chat, lul, ajaja.
Okay, beste Dateiname.
Da schreiben wir jetzt rein.
Ich weiß, was wir reinschreiben.
Wir schreiben da gar nichts rein.
Wir copy-pasten einfach die letzten Chat-Messages da rein.
Okay, zack.
So.
Und jetzt bin ich auf dem Server drauf und stelle fest, ah, die Datei hier, die Datei hier, die will ich unbedingt bei mir lokal haben.
Oder, oh, die Datei hätte ich gerne im Clipboard.
Ja, ich meine, bei so einer kurzen Datei ist das kein Problem, die Datei im Clipboard zu haben.
Ja, das klicke ich an, Steuerung C, dann habe ich sie im Clipboard, okay, das ist nicht so geil.
Aber ihr seid jetzt da drauf.
So, normalerweise, wenn man das jetzt kopieren will, dann muss ich hier sagen, SCP, Max, Blablabla, Zeug eingeben.
Ist auch alles kein Problem, solange man SSH-Keys kopiert hat und solange man nicht irgendwelche Zwischenproxys hat, die einem dann in die Suppe spucken.
Aber wisst ihr, was noch viel nicer ist? Jetzt kann ich euch mal was zeigen.
Guck mal hier, QChat, die Datei liegt eindeutig hier auf meinem Raspberry Pi.
Okay, da, das ist nicht meine Kiste. Ihr seht es da, da meine Kiste, da Raspberry Pi.
So, und jetzt sage ich, Champ, Push, ähm, Cute Chat, ajaja.
Und jetzt, und jetzt passt mal auf.
Bam, New File, From PXE Champ, Accept, Yes.
Mhm, und guck mal da, jetzt gehe ich lokal bei mir ins Download-Verzeichnis.
Da gibt es jetzt ein Ordner SSH Champ.
Nach Hausname sortiert.
Und siehe da, da ist die Datei mit Timestamp.
Das heißt, ich kann die sogar mehrfach kopieren.
Lokal bei mir auf dem Rechner.
Ist das nicht nice?
Ist das nicht nice, hä?
Du brauchst kein SCP mehr, um ein zweites Terminal aufzumachen.
Pfeil Ziller war zu viel für dich?
tja, mach mal
FileZilla mit Sudo.
Kennst du Kitten SSH?
Ja, das ist
tatsächlich auch ein bisschen inspiriert
dabei. Also inspiriert ist das
Ganze von iTerm2
und
Kitty tatsächlich.
Ich kann euch zeigen, wie das funktioniert.
Der Grund, warum ich das gebastelt habe, ist
folgendes.
Also erstens ist es prinzipiell einfacher.
Ja, ich glaube, da kann man
sich nicht großartig drüber schreiben. Das ist
einfacher, da Sachen zu kopieren.
Aber bei mir auf der Arbeit
ist es so,
ich habe noch eine SSH-Proxy
dazwischen.
Und diese SSH-Proxy braucht
Windows-Passwort,
ein gültiges
Ticket als Reason
zum Einloggen
und eine
Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung.
Und wenn ich SCP mache im zweiten Terminal,
darf ich das jedes Mal nochmal eintippen.
Man kann das Ganze zwar ein bisschen umgehen, so Trick 17 mäßig kann man das umgehen, mit Control Master Sessions kann man das umgehen,
Aber generell mit SSH-Multiplexing, genau
Aber spätestens da stößt er auch an die Grenze
Wenn du beispielsweise Sudo geworden bist, ja
Wenn du Root geworden bist
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich das gestern Abend noch gepusht habe
Ich hoffe
Nee, ich hab's nicht mehr gepusht, shit
Ich hab das nämlich auch so eingestellt, dass du das Ganze
Als Root dann verwenden kannst
Dass der quasi die Aliasse mitnimmt
Wenn du Sudo machst
Das heißt, du kannst auch Dateien
uploaden von einem anderen User auf deine lokale Kiste.
Was sehr praktisch ist.
Und mit SCP immer super abfuck.
Ja, da musst du dann so komische
Dinger machen, wie Piped durch SSH
und sowas.
Und das ist halt praktisch.
Übrigens, es geht auch noch mehr. Also ich kann auch sagen,
ich hab hier ein Kommando laufen auf dem
Server. Hier. Echo12356
und das will ich jetzt nach
in mein lokales Clipboard kopieren.
Bam. Und guck mal da.
Es ist lokal im Clipboard.
Auch nice, oder? Obwohl es alles auf dem Server ausgeführt wird.
Es ist übrigens ChampClip, nicht ClipChamp.
ClipChamp ist das Microsoft-Ding.
Ja.
Man kann auch beispielsweise sagen,
hier, QChat,
will ich ins Clipboard kopieren.
Und zack, habe ich den gerade mit dem Clipboard.
Wohlgemerkt, das läuft alles auf dem Server.
Ja.
Und schreibt das ins lokale Clipboard.
oder eben auch,
also um es jetzt mal ein bisschen realistischer zu machen, ja,
gehen wir mal hier nach var log,
ich hoffe, ich darf als mein normaler User da irgendwas machen,
hier, var log hier,
image,
image update log,
das da,
stellt euch vor, ihr seid irgendwie auf dem Server,
by the way,
und wo das auch funktioniert,
das habe ich ja ganz vergessen zu erwähnen,
wo das auch funktioniert,
stellt euch mal vor,
ihr seid jetzt über 3, 4 Sessions,
SSH gehoppt.
Ja? Stellt euch mal vor,
ihr macht hier
nochmal SSH.
So, ihr seid jetzt nochmal per SSH gehoppt.
Jetzt ist mit SSH Multiplexing
hier aus. Ja?
Ups. Ich bin Kacknoob.
Das hab ich auch noch nicht...
Okay, vergiss es.
Das hab ich auch noch nicht gepusht. Egal.
Dann würde das auch funktionieren.
Das muss ich mir mal aufschreiben,
dass ich das nachher noch mache.
Ja, dass er das mitnimmt per SSH.
Genau.
Und jetzt realistisch,
ihr seid ja auf dem Server drauf,
über drei Zwischenhops irgendwie
drauf gehoppt.
Und jetzt habt ihr hier
einen Log. Zum Beispiel
ImageUpdateLog.
So. Dann sagt der, ah Mist,
das brauche ich lokal,
weil ich das an eine E-Mail anhängen will.
So, und jetzt gehen wir mal von aus, ja.
Also, das ist ein bisschen längeres Log-File.
Das heißt, du brauchst keinen Client als Empfänger.
Wie ermittelst du dann die Ausgangsmaschine?
Das kann ich dir gleich zeigen.
Das funktioniert über Terminal-Escape-Sequenzen.
Also, das geht überall.
Das geht eigentlich überall.
Du brauchst aber meine Aliasse hier, die gepusht werden,
weil die machen Sachen. Guck mal hier.
Wenn man jetzt hier nach
äh
Chat, wie gibt man das denn jetzt aus, was das ist?
Command?
Nee.
Äh
Keine Ahnung. Wie gebe ich denn jetzt aus, was
dahinter steckt?
Das ist ja tatsächlich eine Shell-Funktion.
Ich will ausgeben, das ist eine Shell-Function
Wie gebe ich dann aus, was hinter dieser Shell-Function
Steckt
Ich habe eigentlich gedacht, es wäre
Es hat sogar eine Hilfe-Text
Ich habe eigentlich gedacht, Witch kann das anzeigen
Aber anscheinend nicht
Bild in oder sowas
8-P? Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ja, okay, keine Ahnung.
Kein Schimmer.
Irgendwie kann man sich garantiert anzeigen lassen.
Ja, das ist...
Okay, keine Ahnung.
So, ich kann es euch aber gleich zeigen.
So, jetzt stellt euch vor, ihr seid jetzt auf dem Server.
Wer ist vielleicht?
Keine Ahnung.
Nö.
Set. Set ist eine gute Idee.
Ähm, hier.
Da ist es doch.
Hier ist es.
Guck.
Das ist ein bisschen, das ist ein bisschen
ein Advancer.
Das hier ist die eigentliche Magic.
Guck mal. Das benutzt
Terminal Escape Sequence 1337.
Das ist was, was iTerm2
für Mac gefunden hat.
Erfunden hat.
So, aber um das, ich kann das gleich zeigen.
So, um das jetzt Beispiel nochmal zu zeigen.
Also ihr habt eine ganz lange Log-Datei, okay?
Ups.
Ihr habt eine ganz lange Log-Datei.
Wenn ein Jump-Host dazwischen ist, klappt das immer noch, ja?
Man muss nur gucken, dass man die Shell-Befehle weiterhin hat.
Aber prinzipiell funktioniert das mit einem Jump-Host dazwischen.
Weil es über Terminal-Escape-Sequenzen geht.
Solange du meinen SSH-Wrapper verwendest, funktioniert es.
Es geht über beliebig viele Zwischenhops.
So.
Also guck, wir haben hier ein ganz langes Log-File.
Ich kann jetzt einmal hier sagen, Champ, Clip.
Ja, weil das jetzt hier zu Copy-Pasten ist ein bisschen doof.
Ja, ich sage jetzt hier Champ, Clip.
Und bam, guck ich mal in Clipboard, da ist es drin.
Guck, ich kann jetzt hier rüber gehen, dass ihr seht, dass es im Clipboard ist.
Der ganze Kram ist im Clipboard.
Oder ich kann...
Du kannst... Naja, du kannst
nicht unbedingt SCP kopieren über
Jump Holes. Da musst du die komplette Kette
mit SCP nachbauen.
Wenn du dich jetzt hier interaktiv auf was
verbunden hast, verbindest dich von hier
nochmal was interaktiv, wo du vielleicht noch zwei
Faktor-Authentifizierung brauchst und sowas.
Dann ist das gar nicht mehr so einfach.
So, oder ich kann hier
sagen, Champ, äh,
Push. So, das geht auch Standard in.
Steht auch, Standard in.
hier new file standard im vom pxe champ accept band copy paste notification ist
gespeichert wir gehen jetzt hier in das verzeichnis rein zack
oder ist es guckt stelle da ist es wie soll das funktionieren du gehst auf den
ersten Host per SSH.
Von dort gehst du
über irgendeinen anderen Gateway
per SSH nochmal weiter.
Da musst du vielleicht zwei Faktor-Authentifizierung eingeben.
Wie willst du dann von deinem
ursprünglichen Host
SCPen auf den
dahin gejumpen?
Du musst ja SCP sagen,
da müsstest du irgendwie so was
bauen wie, also gut,
was du machen kannst ist,
hier, SSH, bla,
irgendwas
SSH
Add irgendwas
und dann da am Ende Cat oder so.
Das würdest du vielleicht machen können.
Proxychains
funktioniert? Ne, mit
Proxychump funktioniert das nicht so einfach.
Also
ja doch, das funktioniert, aber du musst
das ja im Nachhinein immer noch machen.
Du musst das im Nachhinein
immer noch machen.
Du kannst ja keine SSH
config im vorfeld erstellen wenn du nicht genau weißt wo du hin also wo du landest dann wie
willst du das machen das musste dann dynamisch zusammenbauen also bei mir auf der arbeit wäre
das zum beispiel so aber beispiel so ich gehe jetzt auf ingo linux arbeitskiste für mein team
das ist okay das ist der erste jump aus das ist noch okay das lass ich mir lass ich mir
gefallen. So. Dann gehe ich auf
einen
Google, warte mal hier, auf einen
Google
Cloud
Kiste für Brot.
So. Und von dort
gehe ich beispielsweise auf irgendeine
CubeCTL Admin Kiste.
Das ist jetzt einfach random, was ich mir ausgedacht habe.
Okay? So. Und das baue mal per
SCP nach, dass du dann
auf der Kiste von hier was ordentlich
Copy-Pasten kannst. Ja.
Das ist übrigens auch eines der ersten Gründe gewesen, warum ich das gebaut habe.
Und es ist halt mega praktisch.
Also ich sage nicht, dass man das nicht alles irgendwie um fünf Ecken machen kann, aber sicherlich nicht so einfach und so schnell.
Also was beispielsweise auch eine Möglichkeit ist, was ich auch eine Weile auf der Arbeit gemacht habe,
wenn jetzt nicht so viele Jump-Hows oder irgendwelche Sachen dazwischen sind,
Ich hab mir einfach das
Ich hab mir einfach SlashTemp
Gemounted
Per SSHFS
Und Dateien die ich kopieren wollte
Hab ich dann eben auf dem Server nach SlashTemp
Kopiert und hier unten
Aber du brauchst immer ein zweites Terminal und so
Das ist alles super eklig
Da finde ich das hier echt
Deutlich nicer
Einfach sagen wir jetzt
Zack
Champ Push
Zack wir wollen QChat pushen
except jawoll da ist da und sie da ist auch da mit timestamp ganz kurz wie das
ganze funktioniert kann ja auch kurz zeigen das ist es ist in der tat
relativ übersichtlich und ich glaube es ist auch relativ ordentliches go unter
der haube funktioniert das folgendermaßen
Du kannst ihn sehen, hier, es ist auf GitHub.
GitHub, äh, Wubblos, SSH-Champ.
Hat SSH-FS den Maintainer? Keine Ahnung.
Aber, aber, hier, äh, Mugiwara, ich zeig, ich zeig das auch gleich.
Übrigens, dein...
Dein Name klingt sehr nach...
Ich kann euch jetzt auch mal zeigen, wie es funktioniert.
Also, gucken wir mal in die Main.go rein.
Ist...
Weißt du was?
Wisst ihr was? Wir probieren jetzt mal was aus.
Wenn wir schon gerade dabei sind.
Ich hab das doch geklont.
Äh, SSH Champ.
Okay. Z.
Hä? Z?
Warum kann man das nicht?
Z Editor ist es.
Okay.
Hab ich noch nie benutzt. Schauen wir mal.
Monkey Eyes, was passiert hier? Wallet.
Unrecognized Project
Äh
Trust and Enter
Trust and Come
Kann das was?
Z? Hab ich nie ausprobiert
Komm hier, Go
App
Main.go
Okay, ich find's schon mal gut
Der hat Go Syntax Highlighting
So alles out of the box
Lasst uns mal gucken, ob der auch
Go Autocomplete und so
auto hat er nicht schade dass er mega nice gewesen hätte z auto hätte go auto
kommt der macht im hintergrund dinge der installiert stimmkarten go runtime oder
kann es sein dass er einfach nur kurz braucht bisher am start ist
Okay, da macht Magic im Hintergrund
So, jetzt schauen wir mal, ob es jetzt funktioniert
Ah
Guck mal
Z hat standardmäßig
Äh, das kann man so nicht machen
Äh, Z hat standardmäßig
Go
Äh, Unterstützung
Finde ich sehr nice
So, wie macht man denn in Z? Gibt es hier auch Steuerung P oder sowas?
Ähm, font
Size.
Control plus.
Okay. Also ich kann es euch mal...
By the way, wir machen
demnächst mal einen Z-Stream.
Ah, mein Auge!
Wie
stellt man hier...
Leute, ich würde gerne
meinen Theme ändern.
Wie geht denn das?
Theme Selector.
Aha.
Boah!
Okay, das sieht doch eigentlich ganz gut aus.
Das lassen wir mal.
Also, ich zeige...
Oder gibt es denn auch die...
Gibt es denn hier auch
Plugins mit Themes?
Oder Settings oder sowas?
Themes?
Wie installiert man den Z-Themes?
Den Z-Stream.
Ja.
Hmm.
Install Theme.
Theme.
Vielleicht muss ich auch noch Plugins suchen oder so.
Ja, wie funktioniert das denn?
Wie installiert man Plugins?
Okay, gibt es hier irgendwo einen Settings-Button oder irgendwas?
Hier, hä?
Extensions!
Aber hier gibt es keine Themes.
Icon Theme?
Jet Brains Themes?
Okay.
Steam Selector. Jet Brains.
Ah, das sieht ganz okay aus.
Weil das gar nicht so ein großer Unterschied hier ist, oder?
Oh
Da können wir auch dabei bleiben
Na egal, ich sag jetzt mal ganz kurz was zum Source Code
Weil insgesamt ist es tatsächlich relativ übersichtlich
Also guckt, das Ganze ist
Das Ganze ist ein SSH-Wrapper
Also wenn man
Wenn man nicht interaktiv verwendet
Leitet es einfach nur durch und gut ist
Das ist, letztendlich ist es ein SSH-Wrapper
Also der guckt
Am Anfang hier
Also gut
Das Einzige, was du installiert haben musst, ist SSH.
Ein SSH-Rapper ohne SSH funktioniert ja logischerweise nicht.
Der startet SSH, und zwar mit diesem Kommando.
Dieses Kommando ist quasi ein SSH mit ein bisschen Bashmagic.
Okay, ein bisschen Bashmagic ist gut.
Ein SSH-Kommando mit ein bisschen Bashmagic.
Die Bash Magic sorgt unter anderem dafür, dass man diese Champ Push und Champ Clip Befehle hat.
Remote, wo man dann Sachen mitmachen kann.
So.
Und was ist denn ein Meta-Preter?
So, und wie das Ganze dann funktioniert ist,
Wenn man hier diese Champ Push ausführt auf der, auf dem Server, dann macht es hier Magic.
Worauf es ankommt, ist letztendlich das hier.
Guck, der sendet dann eine Escape Sequenz übers Terminal.
Escape, das ist quasi die, ähm.
Das ist quasi die
Escape Sequence für
Terminal Escape Sequenzen
Und dann sagt er, Escape Sequence
Das ist was
Das hat ITEM2 sich ausgedacht
Das ist ein Terminal für Mac
Das ist nicht von mir
Ich hab mir nur angeguckt, wie ITEM2 das macht
Ich hab's aber ein bisschen extended
Für ITEM2
Im Vergleich zu Item 2, weil ich keinen Bock hatte, alles nachzubauen.
So, da kriegst du eine Escape-Sequenz und das Format ist halt, sobald diese Escape-Sequenz geschickt wird, musst du übergeben, was du für einen File schicken willst, wie groß das File ist, von welchem Host das Ganze kommt, wo es hin soll, also File oder Clipboard.
ob es ein Verzeichnis ist, das ist by the way auch noch nicht implementiert
oder ob es ein Bild ist
was man anzeigen lassen will im Terminal
oder aber halt ein File
so, das habe ich, das ist wie gesagt
mehr oder weniger inspiriert von
Item 2 und ein bisschen von Kitty
und was mein SSH-Rapper
im Endeffekt macht ist
ich kann es euch mal zeigen
der scannt
den Standard-Out
vom SSH-Prozess.
Der scannt den Output
vom
SSH-Prozess
und checkt dann beispielsweise
Sachen wie, wurde
eine Escape-Sequenz gefunden?
Nämlich sowas. Wenn eine
Escape-Sequenz gefunden wurde,
ja, dann
müssen wir hier machen
und das Prefix
gefunden wurde.
Das Prefix ist das da.
Wenn das Prefix gefunden wurde,
dann
das Ganze
an den Not gefunden wurde.
Not gefunden wurde. Wenn das Prefix
gefunden wurde, also sprich, wenn der Buffer so lang ist
wie das Prefix, dann
ruft er letztendlich das hier auf.
Ich will es euch gar nicht so sehr im Detail zeigen.
Und das ruft wiederum dann
also hier decodet er
quasi diesen ganzen
Argument String, also Name
und
gedöns.
Und dann übergibt er das Ganze
an den File-Händler.
Und der File-Händler macht dann so Dinge wie
ist Target gesetzt? Wenn das Target Clipboard
ist, also hier so, ne?
Wenn das Target Clipboard ist,
dann das Ganze ins Clipboard
verschieben. Hier muss ich übrigens auch nochmal eine Sicherheitsabfrage
davor machen.
Wenn das Target nicht Clipboard ist,
dann guckt er, wo ist das User-Heimat-Verzeichnis.
Dann
legt er dann Verzeichnis an mit
SSH-Champ, guckt von welchem Host
das Ganze kommt,
escapt
hier ein paar Dinger,
generiert einen Timestamp,
zeigt einen Confirmation-Prompt,
sonst könnte euch ja nämlich jeder Random-Dude
ein File schicken,
wobei das nicht so ganz stimmt, er braucht immer noch
Zugang zu eurem Standard-Out
vom Terminal,
da kommt hier ein
Prompt, so nach dem Motto
hier, neues File, willst du das annehmen?
Und wie gesagt, dieser ganze
Go-Code, der läuft ja lokal
bei mir. Den kann man
per Bash-Skript vom Server nicht beeinflussen.
Zumindest hoffe ich, dass man das nicht kann.
Und wenn
Confirmation okay ist,
dann legt er einen Ordner an, schreibt das
File lokal dahin.
Und im Endeffekt,
was der hier macht,
ist, neben diesen Escape-Sequenzen,
also, man gibt den Namen
vom File an, Größe vom File,
Host, von dem es kommt, wohin das Ganze soll,
ob es ein Verzeichnis ist oder nicht, ob es ein Bild ist oder nicht.
Und hier zum Schluss, das hier ist eigentlich der Trick.
Hier zum Schluss nach dem Doppelpunkt, das habe ich mir abgeguckt, wie gesagt von iTerm2.
Nach dem Doppelpunkt kommt die Datei Base64 encoded.
Und deswegen macht der Scanner auch hier Base64 decode.
Das heißt, was man hier in Data drin stehen hat, ist dann quasi Raw Bytes von der Datei.
Ein Nachteil hat das Ganze, wenn die Datei sehr groß ist
Dann hat er mehrere hundert MB in einer Terminal Escape Sequenz
Das heißt, das wird erstmal komplett in Memory auf dem Server zusammengebaut
Und dann nochmal komplett in Memory auf dem Host empfangen
Also das ist jetzt aktuell nicht dafür geeignet, gigabyteweise große Dateien rumzuschieben
Weil dann geht entweder der Server out of memory oder der Client out of memory.
Aber es gibt auch eine Sache, das habe ich mir schon aufgeschrieben.
Es gibt eine Sache in diesem Protokoll, das Ding kann Chunked Transfers.
Also du kannst, anstatt File anzugeben, kann man irgendwie sinngemäß sowas machen.
File Start und dann File Chunk.
Das muss ich aber noch einbauen.
Das ist natürlich deutlich praktischer.
Ja.
Weil, dann hast du keine
5 Gig
irgendwo im RAM rumliegen.
Aber nachdem man das eh nur für ein paar
Kilobyte große Logdateien macht, ist das auf jeden Fall schon
benutzbar. Aber Chunk Transfer
wäre auf jeden Fall noch was sehr Sinnvolles.
So funktioniert das.
Der SSH Champ.
Ja, und da kann man noch jede Menge anderes Zeug einbauen.
Aber ich werde mich jetzt erst mal auf die Copy-Geschichte konzentrieren.
Ah ja.
Ah ja, du musst halt irgendwie tunneln, ne?
Du musst halt irgendwie tunneln.
Aber wisst ihr was?
Das Gute ist, das macht iTerm auch so.
Und by the way, Westterm, Westterm selber kann das auch.
Also wenn ihr den Terminal verwendet, ja?
Wenn ihr den Terminal verwendet, was diese Escape-Sequenzen unterstützt,
dann geht das auch ohne mein Tool.
Wobei, nicht so schön, muss man dazu sagen.
Aber Westterm kann diese Escape-Sequenzen auch.
Also wenn Westterm diese Escape-Sequenzen sieht, macht es das Gleiche.
Ja, das ist irgendeine Kitty-Geschichte.
Aber müsst ihr schon zugeben, das ist eine coole Sache, oder?
So.
Das ist der SSH-Champ.
Gut.
Hab ich jetzt eigentlich alles geupdatet?
Hab ich schon rebooted?
Wie geht's mir? Nicht gut.
Ich hab heute Nacht nicht gut gepennt.
Und nachdem ich
Probleme hat einzuschlafen, habe ich mir übelste
Gedanken gemacht und habe dann die restliche Nacht
Ich habe schon gepennt, aber
so immer nur eine Stunde, da bin ich kurz
aufgemacht, habe wieder eine Stunde gepennt
Das merke ich noch
Das hat immer so ein, zwei Tage Nachwirkung
dann. Nicht wegen dem schlecht
Geschlafen, das ist gar nicht so wild, sondern weil ich mir so viel
Gedanken gemacht habe, beziehungsweise
Ich mache mir ja mittlerweile gar keine Gedanken
mehr. Das triggert mich
an sich schon und das hat
meistens, meistens hat das dann so ein, zwei
Tage noch so ein bisschen nachwehen.
Weil ich hab dann halt immer das Problem,
ich denk dann halt so nach dem Motto, oh, das war
jetzt einmal ganz schlimm, das wird jetzt für mein restliches
Leben so schlimm bleiben und bla bla bla bla bla.
Du hast extra um Mitternacht wegen Stream geschrieben, um dich
abzulenken.
Warum bist du denn um
Mitternacht noch auf?
Und, oh nein!
Meinst du, ich lese so mitternacht Twitch-Chat?
Was geht's?
Wir sind gerade mit einem Thema fertig.
Wisst ihr was geil ist? Heute ist mein letzter Tag
Schlimme Rufbereitschaft. Dann mach ich da wohl die nächste Jahre
Achso. Was heißt Schlimme Rufbereitschaft?
Die gehen dir laufen auf den Sack
Und du kriegst kaum Geld dafür oder wie ist das?
Übrigens Leute, ich hab
Six Head Move auf der Arbeit gemacht
Max hast du gesehen
Wie Five Head 1&1 ist?
Ne, hab ich nicht
Leute, ich muss euch aber noch was erzählen
Ich hab Six Head
Geistesblitz auf der Arbeit gehabt
Und zwar bei uns auf der Arbeit wird gerade etwas umstrukturiert.
Und die haben jetzt quasi geguckt, wer wie wo in welches Team geht.
Wenn Westterm das schon implementiert hat, warum kannst du das nicht verwenden?
Weil ich auf der Arbeit kein Westterm verwende.
Dafür verwende ich Terminator.
Und außerdem kann Westterm nicht alles.
Was ich gerne hätte
Ja beispielsweise direkt ins Clipboard kann Westtermlich
Und sowas
Moment aber was wollte ich jetzt
Genau ich wollte euch was erzählen und zwar
Also bei uns
Ja das geht aber Sally J mag ich nicht
Sally J hat im Endeffekt
Ups
das gleiche nervige Zeug wie T-Mox,
dass es nicht terminal, zumindest nicht so
richtig terminal aware ist.
Und das ist ein bisschen besser als T-Mox,
was Copy-Paste angeht, aber immer noch eklig.
Ich hab das mal ausprobiert,
das hat mir nicht gefallen.
Genau, also, Sixth Head
Move auf der Arbeit, und zwar
bei uns wird gerade ein bisschen umstrukturiert,
also irgendwann nächstes Jahr geht das dann los.
Und jetzt haben sie gerade so ein bisschen
in Gespräche geführt und geguckt, wer denn wo in welches
Team geht. Und es gibt jetzt ein neues
Container
Infrastruktur
Team oder irgendwie so
heißt das. Ich weiß nicht genau, wie es heißen wird.
So. Und
da ist mein Chef zu mir gekommen.
Mein jetziger Chef. Hat gesagt, Max,
wir würden uns
alle sehr freuen, wenn du in das
Container Team gehst, weil wir haben bei der
Bank viel zu wenig Leute,
die sich so gut wie du mit Containern auskennen.
So sinngemäß hat er das gesagt.
Habe ich gesagt, oh ja, das speichelt mir ja.
Macht mir ja auch Spaß.
Aber ehrlich gesagt, würde ich lieber bei dir und Linux bleiben.
Ja, aber Container ist doch nice.
Und wir haben doch nicht so viele Leute, die das können.
Und du kennst dich damit doch richtig gut aus.
Dann habe ich zu ihm gesagt, also, wenn das so ist,
dann könntet ihr mich ja eigentlich eine Stufe hochstufen.
in meiner Laufbahn,
weil dann bin ich ja quasi Experte.
Also kann ich eigentlich auch Experte
im Titel haben.
Und da hat er
erstmal gesagt, ja,
ja, aber, aber, aber, Experte,
da gehört ja noch mehr dazu.
Und letztens,
letztens nochmal Rücksprache gehabt,
hab ich nochmal gesagt, ja, also ich hätte
ich hätte es jetzt schon gerne, dass wir das
fürs nächste Jahr in die
Zielvereinbarung reinschreiben,
dass ich Experte
oder ich bin ja nicht mehr Experte,
Fachexperte oder wie es
dann genau heißt, werde.
Und da reden wir
nächste Woche nochmal drüber und dann schreiben wir das
rein. Und wisst ihr, was
das Gute ist? Wenn das
also ich bin auch der Meinung, dass das
bei mir angebracht ist, ja, mein Chef
denkt das übrigens auch, also insofern, das passt
schon. Zumal ich jetzt ja schon
vier Jahre dabei bin oder nächstes
Jahr April oder so bricht das
fünf Jahre an.
passt jetzt ja an der Stelle halt auch gut.
Bekommst du dann mehr Geld?
Ja,
aber
das haben die taktisch eigentlich
ganz geschickt gemacht.
Und zwar
Und es gibt bei uns, ich versuche das mal so grob abstrakt zu erzählen, es gibt bei uns mehrere Stufen.
Also, du kannst, doch, ich habe 2023 im April angefangen, nächstes Jahr im April.
Ich war 2023 da, 2024 da, 2025 da, 2026 da.
Also ab April nächstes Jahr bricht das fünfte Jahr an.
Also bei uns ist das so mit Gehaltsstufen folgendermaßen.
Also es gibt einmal die Tarifvertrag-Leute.
Da gibt es dann auch verschiedene Erfahrungsstufen und Gedöns und alles.
Aber das ist alles tarifvertragsmäßig geregelt.
Dann gibt es noch mehrere Stufen.
Außertarifliche Verträge.
Das Gute bei uns ist, wenn man in einem außertariflichen Vertrag ist,
kriegt man trotzdem in der Regel die Erhöhungen, die der Tarifvertrag bekommt, auch mit.
Das ist ziemlich pfeifert eigentlich, weil, überlegt euch mal, stellt euch mal vor,
die Tarifvertragsleute würden immer Erhöhungen bekommen.
Die außertariflichen Leute würden keine Erhöhungen bekommen, automatisch.
Das heißt, nach ein paar Jahren haben die Tarifvertragsleute die außertariflichen Leute überholt. Das will man natürlich nicht, weil man sieht ja diese außertariflichen Stufen als quasi Karrierestufen an. Deswegen kriegst du auch, wenn du außertariflich eingestuft bist, immer mehr oder weniger die Erhöhung aus dem Tarifvertrag auch automatisch drauf.
Das ist sehr angenehm. Das heißt, ich muss sie nicht alle paar Jahre nerven oder einmal, ein, zweimal, alle ein, zwei Jahre nerven, sondern es gibt automatisch mehr Geld. Das ist schon mal ganz gut. Aber wir haben verschiedene Stufen, was außertarifliche Verträge angeht.
Ja, es gibt bei uns so eine, ich sage jetzt nicht, wie viel es genau gibt, aber sagen wir mal so, sagen wir mal, es gibt drei, okay, nur mal so exemplarisch, es gibt drei Tarif-, also außertarifliche Stufen.
Das eine ist die erste, in der bin ich aktuell gerade, das ist so die Senior XYZ Stufe.
So. Als nächstes
gibt's dann die
ich glaub
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es
Fachexperte oder Fachspezialist
oder irgendwie so heißt. Keiner. Ich glaub Fachexperte
oder so. Das nächste
nennt sich dann Fachexperte
und das nächste ist dann Seniorexperte.
Seniorexperte ist dann quasi das höchste, was es
gibt. So.
Und
ich werde dann, oder
wenn das denn dann
alles so klappt, werde ich dann
Fachexperte. Also ich werde dann quasi
die zweite Stufe von drei.
Und das haben die dann aber
insofern ganz clever gemacht. Du kriegst nicht
automatisch monatlich
einfach mehr Geld überwiesen.
Das wäre ja zu einfach.
Du hast eine höhere Gehaltsspanne
dadurch, wenn du in der
höheren Gruppe bist.
Das heißt,
du kannst zwar im Monat mehr Geld kriegen.
Ich werde wahrscheinlich auch ein paar Euro im Monat
mehr kriegen. Das wird aber nicht so viel sein.
Aber der Bonus wird viel mehr. Also umso höher du steigst in dieser Karriereleiter, umso mehr steigt dein Bonusanteil im Vergleich zu deinem normalen Gehaltsanteil.
Ja, also wenn du tarifvertragsmäßig beschäftigt bist, hast du glaube ich gar keinen Bonus. Dann hast du einfach das, was im Tarifvertrag steht. Bist du außer tariflich beschäftigt, kriegst du das normale Gehalt plus einen Bonus und umso höher du da bist in dieser Leiter, sagen wir mal, dein Gehalt steigt nicht mehr wirklich viel, aber der Bonus steigt.
Weil, und ich finde das ist irgendwie auch in gewisser Weise relativ schlau gedacht, je höher du bist, umso mehr direkten Einfluss hast du ja auf die Gesamt-
Soll man sagen, auf die Gesamt-Performance der Versicherung.
Und dementsprechend bist du da natürlich auch sehr motiviert, dich weiterhin anzustrengen, weil du ja mehr Bonus haben willst.
Das heißt, wenn schlecht für die Versicherung läuft, kriege ich, obwohl ich eine Stufe höher bin, auch nicht mehr Geld.
Also wenn die sagen, es gibt einfach nur den minimalen Bonusfaktor mal irgendwas, dann kriege ich nicht wirklich mehr Geld.
Wenn es allerdings gut läuft, und das setzt sich bei uns aus mehreren Faktoren zusammen und die letzten Jahre lief es auch immer gut.
wenn es gut läuft, kann ich
bis zu dem wahrscheinlich
doppelten Bonus kriegen.
Also.
Je nachdem, wie das dann genau ist.
So genau habe ich mir das alles auch noch nicht angeguckt.
Also das heißt,
ich kriege nicht automatisch mehr Geld.
Nur wenn es gut läuft und
es ordentlich Bonus gibt, dann kriege ich halt noch ein bisschen
mehr Bonus.
Aber es ist ja nicht so,
als ist das andere
jetzt irgendwie
sonderlich wenig Geld.
Es ist schon mal schlecht gelaufen, also seit ich da bin,
noch nicht. Da gab es immer
ordentlich Bonus und auch ordentlichen Faktor
auf den Bonus erhöht.
Ein paar Euro
im Monat mehr werde ich dann schon bekommen,
aber so viel wird es nicht sein.
Genau, vielleicht,
vielleicht, wer weiß ja, vielleicht ist es ja nur
wegen mir gut gelaufen, ja, wer weiß,
wer weiß.
Also meine Versicherung,
für die ich arbeite,
bezahlt mir jeden Monat freiwillig
Geld.
Und wisst ihr, was witzig ist?
Ich arbeite bei einer Versicherung,
ich habe aber selbst keinen einzigen
Vertrag dort.
Aber gut,
das liegt daran, weil ich meine Sachen schon vorher hatte.
Ist Geld für dich noch wichtig?
Ähm, naja.
Es ist nicht wirklich so relevant.
Mehr, ja.
Weil wenn man erstmal so viel hat, dass man gut über die Runden kommt.
Und ich bin ja super sparsam.
Ich würde nicht sagen, dass ich geizig bin, aber so materielle Sachen geben mir relativ wenig.
Ich kaufe mir alle paar Jahre mal einen 5000 Euro neuen Rechner oder so oder ein viertes NAS oder was auch immer.
Aber ansonsten gebe ich nicht viel Geld aus.
Das meiste landet in meinem ETF.
Aber trotzdem, es ist auf der anderen Seite auch blöd, solche Chancen verstreichen zu lassen.
Also warum, wenn man die Chance hat und dementsprechend auch die passende Leistung für bringt, wo es dann mehr für gibt, warum sollte man das nicht auch in Anspruch nehmen?
Macht ja auch wiederum keinen Sinn.
Ja, warum sollte ich sagen, ey, ich mach zwar die Arbeit
Vom Anspruch her und von der Performance her
Von irgendeinem
Five-Hat-Experte, aber ich will nicht
Five-Hat-Bonuszahlung haben
Macht ja keinen Sinn
Ja gut, das stimmt
Also, ganz ehrlich, glücklicher bin ich dadurch nicht
Vielleicht, wenn ich mal in Rente bin
Weil ich dann noch ein bisschen mehr in mein ETF einbezahlt hab
Und easy life machen kann, keine Ahnung
Hab ich euch übrigens schon gezeigt, Chat, gell
Twitter
Achso, oh, Nitta gibt's ja nicht mehr, gell
Fuck
Gibt es irgendeine Alternative
Dazu, die, die, die, ähm
kennt jemand kennt jemand eine alternative die nicht getakt wurde von twitter
Twitter?
Kann man das aufmachen?
Ist das okay?
Chat, ich trau mich mal. Ich hoffe, jetzt kommt kein Pornzeug.
Service ist kontinuiert.
Fuck!
Okay.
Man hat anscheinend
Keine? So, gibt's anscheinend nichts mehr.
Mastadon, Alter, was soll ich da?
Da ist keine Sau.
So, was soll ich eigentlich zeigen?
Das wollte ich euch...
Okay, immerhin.
Das wollte ich euch eigentlich zeigen.
Guckt mal, Leute.
Was ich gestern gerannt bin.
Niemand ist auf Mastadon.
Ich gucke da manchmal bei Leuten auf Mastadon, ja?
die haben dann irgendwie
ein Like oder so pro Post
und 50 Views und sowas.
Das kannst du komplett knicken.
Guck mal Leute,
gestern bin ich 22 Kilometer gerannt.
Erster Halbmarathon, den ich je gerannt bin
gestern.
Und ich muss sagen, es war
tatsächlich, genauso wie ich es hier schon geschrieben habe,
es war einfacher als gedacht.
Kreislaufmäßig war
das überhaupt kein Problem.
Kreislaufmäßig hätte ich auch noch weiter rennen können.
Aber was mir echt gereicht hat, ist Muskel und so.
Muskelgelenke-mäßig.
Ich merke das heute übelst in der Hüfte noch.
Also an den Muskeln in der Hüfte und so.
Das merke ich richtig.
Also Beine, Muskeln und so.
Das ist richtig brutal.
Kreislaufmäßig war gar kein großes Problem.
Gut, ich meine, man muss auch sagen,
Ich bin auch langsam gelaufen, ja.
Gibt's ein Max-Subreddit? Ne.
Bin dran.
Also, ich bin auch recht langsam gelaufen, ja.
6,15er Pace, 141 Heartbeat ist jetzt nicht viel.
Also, ich denke mal, wenn ich, also wenn ich drauf anliegen würde, ja, wenn ich drauf anliegen würde,
Könnte ich da schon
Knapp unter einem 6er Pace
Laufen und würde nicht sterben danach
Aber muss ja nicht sein
Wozu auch
Aber das ist schon nice
Das war nämlich eines meiner
Kurz bis mittelfristigen Ziele
Einen Halbmarathon zu packen
Das nächste Ziel ist
Erstmal den Halbmarathon in einer noch besseren Zeit zu packen
Aber das nächste Ziel was jetzt kommt
Ist 5 Kilometer
Unter 25 Minuten
Das packe ich eigentlich auch schon. Ich bin nämlich mal 36 Minuten gerannt. Oder 38? 36? Ne, 38. 2x19. 38 Minuten. Ich bin schon mal 38 Minuten 5, at 5, 10 oder so gerannt.
oder 5,5, irgendwie sowas in dem Dreh.
Bisschen unter 5,10.
Ja, und
bei 5 Kilometer
unter 25 Minuten, ja gut,
bist halt 11 Minuten kürzer
als das, was ich da gerade bin unterwegs.
Oder 3,
äh, 13.
Also das
packe ich. Laut meiner Garmin-Uhr
packe ich das eh locker, aber die Garmin-Predictions
sind halt sehr optimistisch.
So, das ist mein nächstes Ziel.
5 Kilometer unter 25 Minuten.
Und dann mal gucken, wie es aussieht.
Eine Sache, die mich ein bisschen nervt ist, meine Garmin-Uhr ist der Meinung, seit einem Monat tut sich an meinem Fitnessstand nichts mehr.
Warum auch immer.
Mein VO2 Max steigt nicht mehr.
Aber ganz ehrlich, das sind eh alles nur irgendwelche random Schätzungen.
Ich merke ja, dass ich insgesamt immer fitter werde.
Außerdem war ich noch nie so fit.
Jetzt steigt das eh langsamer.
Ja, das Niveau, was man mal hatte,
erreicht man immer relativ schnell.
Aber besser werden ist halt immer anstrengend.
Was hast du denn für Schuhe?
Irgendwann ging mir laufen so oft die...
Okay, ich hab zwei Sachen, die ich dir empfehlen kann.
Wenn du ein bisschen schwerer bist
und einfach was willst, was bequem ist,
dann nehmt den hier gibt es auch in verschiedenen haben und breiten und so
übrigens eines der wenigen schuhe die es gibt die es in teilweise sogar jetzt
aktuell kann ich in extra breit gibt kann ich empfehlen habe ich auch mit
angefangen, also nicht mit dem 28er,
keine Ahnung, mit welcher Nummer ich angefangen habe.
Die sind super.
Die sind super zum Einstieg, gerade
wenn deine Muskelgelenke
das noch nicht so gewöhnt sind,
wenn du vielleicht auch ein bisschen schwerer bist,
was eh schon Muskelgelenke und so
ein bisschen mehr belastet, wenn du es
noch nicht so gewöhnt bist.
Ich habe jetzt
natürlich nicht 5000, ich habe kein Zugeschäft,
ausprobiert. Aber den habe ich mir zum Einstieg
gekauft, der ist super zum Einstieg.
Der ist aber wirklich nur zum Laufen,
so zum täglichen Fuß gehen und so, ist das nichts,
weil du hast, also wenn du damit langsam läufst,
also gehst, hast du schon ein bisschen das Gefühl,
du läufst auf Marshmallows,
aber der ist halt sehr nice, weich gedämmt.
Also wenn du Probleme hast mit Gelenke und allem,
dann hol dir den da, kann ich wirklich nur empfehlen.
Und was auch wichtig ist,
wenn du anfängst steigern das mal langsam über drei vier wochen ja also
geh mal zwei drei kilometer laufen machen tagpause zwei drei kilometer
laufen ein zwei tage pause machen die nächste woche läuft sie dann vielleicht
vier kilometer macht ein zwei tage pause dann läuft immer drei kilometer
hintereinander zwei tage machten tagpause so ein steiger das war über
drei, vier Wochen, weil
dein ganzer Körper muss sich ja
dran gewöhnen,
dass du das jetzt machst.
Und Augen zu und durch
ist meistens schlecht,
weil wenn es erstmal anfängt,
täglich weh zu tun beim Rennen, dann bist du erst
weniger motiviert und
wird dann auch nicht besser.
Ja.
Dann tut dir irgendwann das Schienbein
weh und du
selbst wenn du dran greifst, tut es schon weh
und das ist nichts.
Ja, so und was ich jetzt, also den habe ich immer noch, den verwende ich tatsächlich auch ab und zu noch.
Also aktuell verwende ich den nur, wenn mein Trainingsplan sagt, heute Rest oder Recovery Run.
Also super lahm und nicht lange.
Und ich mich entscheide, Recovery Run anstelle von Rest zu machen.
So, dann nehme ich den.
Früher, also jetzt für zwei bis drei Jahre, habe ich den ausschließlich verwendet.
So, mittlerweile habe ich einen, mit dem man auch ein bisschen schneller rennen kann.
Mittlerweile habe ich den da.
Superplast 3.
Der ist auch sehr nice gedämpft.
Ist aber ein bisschen, wie soll man das nennen, so reaktionsfreudiger.
Also der gibt ein bisschen mehr Energie ab.
Da trittst du drauf, es dämpft.
Aber es gibt auch wieder ein bisschen Energie nach oben ab.
Nach vorne ab.
was bei dem gel nimbus überhaupt nicht so ist bei dem gel nimbus trittst du rein
und es ist wie wenn du in marshmallows trittst dafür hast du halt keine gelenke
oder muskelprobleme wenn du mit dem gel nimbus läufst also die zwei schuhe habe ich
ich habe letztens ein video gesehen wie viel laufschuhe braucht man und der hat
irgendwie gesagt einen laufschuh für jede trainingseinheit also für jede
unterschiedliche Trainingseinheit
seinen eigenen Laufschuh.
Finde ich total rausgeschmissenes Geld.
Also der Typ hat halt,
es hat schon Sinn gemacht, was der erzählt hat,
ja, aber das würde ich nicht machen,
das macht auch überhaupt, gerade zum Einschauen, überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Der hat halt gesagt, okay, er hat einmal
so einen super gedämpften Schuh,
für so langsame Sachen,
dann hat er so ein Mittelding, dann hat er einen
mit Carbonsohle, wenn er hier
High-Performance-Dinger machen will,
dann hat er noch einen ohne Carbonsohle,
der aber auch für ein bisschen sportlichere Sachen ist,
dann hat er noch irgendwie so einen barfußschuh, dann hat er noch hier und da und sonst, der hat irgendwie sieben, der macht irgendwie sieben verschiedene Trainingseinheiten, sieben verschiedene Schuhen, ganz ehrlich, das braucht man nicht, ich finde, wenn man mit einem Dämpfungs, so einem Gelnimbus bei Isaacs einsteigt, ist wunderbar, da kannst du ohne Probleme ein, ein, ein Jahr, ein, zwei Jahre mit rennen, zum Einstieg und brauchst nichts anderes und ich habe halt gemerkt, okay, das war mir doch ein bisschen zu viel Marshmallow, wenn ich ein bisschen schneller rennen will, jetzt habe ich beide, jetzt habe ich für Sachen, wo ich ein bisschen schneller renne, habe ich den und den Gelnimbus,
für alles, was langsam ist.
So.
So sieht's aus. Und ja, man ist
eine ganze Ecke größer damit. Man hat, glaube ich, bestimmt
5 cm oder sowas an Schaumstoff
drunter.
Gibt es dann jeden Tag Rentner-Stream?
Ey, das dauert noch, bis ich in Rente gehe, ne?
ich bin jetzt 42, Leute.
Das heißt,
ich muss noch mindestens
mindestens
23 Jahre
arbeiten.
Eher mehr.
Aber deswegen
stecke ich ja mein ganzes Geld, was ich nicht brauche,
in ein ETF.
Und dann habe ich
massive Stonks gemacht.
In 20 Jahre.
Und dann scheiße ich einfach drauf, was das offizielle Renteneintrittsalter ist.
Und gibt schon wieder neue Updates.
WL Clipboard.
Moment, WL Clipboard
GitHub, was gibt es da Neues, braucht man das?
Was ich ja mal
mega nice finden würde, wenn
7 Monate
geil, nice, vor 3 Wochen, excellent
hält sich wohl
sehr in Grenzen
ja, also was ich
ja persönlich sehr nice finden würde
ist, wenn
Deskflow
Copy-Paste ordentlich unterstützt.
Also was aktuell geht ist,
ich kann
von meinem Windows Desktop hier, guckt mal,
von meinem Windows Desktop
kann ich auf den Linux Desktop
Copy-Pasten. Das geht. Aber von
meinem Linux Desktop
kann ich nicht auf den Windows Desktop Copy-Pasten.
Und das liegt an
Deskflow.
So.
Wir können mal kurz bei
Deskflow gucken. Bist du auf Art?
Ich bin auf CacheOS. Aber das ist ja ein Arsch, Linux.
früher war ich auf einem nacktischen archlinux und irgendwann habe ich mal ein video zur cache
us gesehen hat mir gedacht all da probierst du einfach mal eines der gehypten os aus weil ich
hatte mir gerade ich hatte hier gerade linux mini pc am start haben überlegt was installierten drauf
der kommt probierst du einfach mal eines der aktuell gehypten os aus cash us drauf installiert
festgestellt gut vor konfiguriert das kde sinnvolle default einstellung alle möglichen
arzt sachen die man unter arzt ebenso hat warum soll ich was anderes drauf wieder drauf machen
Guck mal, gibt es denn bei
Deskflow, gibt es da jetzt Clipboard?
Gibt es da jetzt eigentlich Clipboard?
Weil mittlerweile
soweit ich weiß,
habe ich da irgendwie mal Options gesehen.
Ich darf jetzt nichts machen, sonst geht meine Maus nicht mehr.
Advanced.
Hier, enable.
Enable VL Clip.
When using, there is...
Okay, also das ist jetzt halt die Frage.
Clipboard sharing issue.
Server.
Ubuntu Mac.
Ja, geht das mittlerweile vielleicht sogar?
Okay, Wayland macht mal wieder irgendwelche Dinger, die Wayland macht.
Und es dauert ewig.
Import Capture Support.
By the way, Flatpak?
Was zum...
Was hat das jetzt mit Flatpak zu tun, dass das funktioniert?
Ich blick da nicht mehr durch bei dem ganzen Scheiß, Alter.
Soll ich es mal aktualisieren und gucken, ob es dann einfach funktioniert?
Wo habe ich denn Deskflow überhaupt liegen hier?
Deskflow?
Kann man hier updaten drüber?
Nee, natürlich nicht, ne?
habe ich hier da ist das hier mein deskflor oder ich weiß gar nicht wo ich das kann man
irgendwie nachgucken wo man den krempel ins open file location habe ich das denn
überhaupt installiert ok deskflor ok jetzt hab wir probieren es einfach aus ob das funktioniert
der anderen seite ist es glaube ich gar nicht so gut wenn ich das jetzt ausprobieren das geht nicht
weil dann kann ich auch nicht auf mein
die lux mini pc so aber hier nach
clipboard ok ok
das probiere ich leute das probiere ich
auf stream aus sonst ist das mache ich
mir das irgendwie kaputt und es und es
Funsten hier richtig.
Ja, das glaube ich sinnvoller.
Ich kann jetzt auch mal kurz ohne Copy-Paste
leben, glaube ich.
Alright.
Was trendet denn auf GitHub so?
Wie gesagt, Leute, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher,
wie lange ich
heute da bin. Ich habe heute Nacht nicht gut gepennt
und habe mich wieder voll reingesteigert
in die ganze Geschichte.
jetzt geht es mir ein bisschen schlecht
sad hier
und ich kenne das schon, ich weiß, das hat dann
das hat dann, jetzt hat es 1-2 Tage
so Nachwirkungen, dann geht es wieder
ja, wer so Probleme auch schon mal hatte, kennt das vielleicht
ja, wenn man einmal was hatte, was schlecht war
und man sich da reingesteigert hat, denkt man
obwohl man schon oft das Gegenbeispiel
gesehen hat, denkt man, oh das war jetzt
einmal so, das wird bestimmt immer so sein
und alles ist ganz schlimm
und das ist halt keine...
Ich weiß ja, dass
es Blödsinn ist, weil ich hatte so
oft schon irgendwelche Katastrophengedanken
und
es ist immer wieder weggegangen.
Also ich kenn's ja eigentlich schon.
Aber man weiß ja nie, ob's diesmal nicht auch
so ist. Ob's wirklich so ist.
Aber realistisch betrachtet
ist es diesmal auch so.
Das ganze Kram bleibt nicht da.
Ich kann euch sagen, Leute,
so psychische Probleme sind echt nicht so geil.
Ich konnte das früher nicht verstehen.
Früher habe ich immer gedacht,
also auch über Leute, die damit Probleme hatten,
sich so viele Gedanken über alles gemacht haben,
habe ich immer gedacht, ey, da muss man einfach mal Augen zu und durch.
Aber Augen zu und durch ist genau der falsche Ansatz.
Augen zu und durch ist wie Traktor-Pulling,
habe ich euch ja schon erzählt.
Das staut sich da nur auf.
Deswegen, jetzt muss ich ein paar Tage warten, dann ist es auch wieder besser.
Haben wir schon gesehen, dass das sich immer wieder verflüchtigt.
Zumal es insgesamt mir jetzt auch schon viel besser geht, wie vor einem Jahr.
Also ich habe ganz selten noch irgendwas, wenn ich es habe, dann nicht so schlimm und meistens auch nicht so lang.
So, was haben wir denn hier Schönes noch?
Was trendet denn?
Paperclip Agent AI
Nice
AI
Achso, ich soll Golem gucken
Stimmt, ja, ja, ja, hab ich vergessen
Ja, das dauert, ne?
Software-Bugs zu fixen dauert immer
Das hab ich auch gemerkt
Aber es ist wirklich schon viel besser
im Vergleich zu vor einem Jahr
oder eineinhalb Jahren oder so.
Ich habe ja kaum noch irgendwas.
Ich penne ganz normal
mittlerweile wieder zum größten Teil
zu 99%.
Außer mal Ausnahme halt, wie heute Nacht.
Nicht reinsteigen lassen,
das stimmt. Aber das ist gar nicht so einfach.
Das passiert schon
fast automatisch.
Aber mittlerweile kann man es ja auch besser einschätzen, weil man weiß, man hatte das schon 500 Mal und das legt sich immer wieder.
Also, 1 und 1 streicht Homeoffice.
Nur mit dem Unterschied, dass das schwarze Loch relativ schnell zerstrahlt, wenn man das ein bisschen geübt hat.
das legt sich dann nach 1-2 Tagen wieder.
Also es legt sich meistens schon relativ schnell,
aber es braucht halt 1-2 Tage, bis wieder alles komplett weg ist.
Aber das braucht ein bisschen Übung.
Und Erfahrung, dass das halt
nicht so schlimm ist, wie man denkt erstmal.
So, also was macht denn 1&1?
1&1 streicht Homeoffice
nur für Bereich mit Betriebsrat.
Was? Wie jetzt?
Wollen die die Leute abfangen, oder was?
Was ist denn mit denen los, Alter?
Offensichtlich, ja, gängeln kann man die Leute nicht, oder?
Ich sehe das schon so richtig vor mir, ja?
Die Führungsriege dort hat gesagt,
nein, wir wollen keinen Betriebsrat.
Und die Leute haben gesagt, doch, wir machen das aber.
Nein, wir wollen das nicht.
Doch, wir machen das aber.
Und jetzt überlegen sie sich, was sie rechtlich gesehen eben machen können, um die Leute abzufacken.
Ohne, dass du was dagegen sagen kannst.
Aber es ist ganz einfach. Wisst ihr, was hier passieren wird?
Es wird das passieren, was bei allen da passiert.
Die besten Leute, die am meisten Ahnung haben und am einfachsten was anderes finden, verpissen sich.
Das ist immer so.
Das ist genauso bei diesen ganzen Aktionen.
die größere Konzerne
mal ganz gerne machen.
So dieses, oh,
XYZ ist zu teuer, wir müssen Stellen abbauen.
Ja, ähm,
das ist aber schwierig, die Leute
loszuwerden. Ja,
lass uns mal so eine Mischung machen aus
äh, Leute abfacken und
Abfindungen und dann gehen
die Leute schon freiwillig. Ja, das stimmt.
Die Leute, die freiwillig gehen, sind entweder
die kurz vor der Rente, ja,
oder aber halt auch ein Großteil
der in einem fähigsten Leute.
Das heißt, was dann übrig bleibt,
ist ein Haufen Ahnungsloser.
Das ist immer
nicht so geschickt.
Das macht so auf den ersten Blick
zwar einen guten Eindruck, weil Kosten sind niedriger.
Am Ende funktioniert der Laden aber nicht mehr.
Weiß nicht, ob das in dem Fall auch so ist, aber
könnte durchaus sein.
Genau, ein Haufen Ahnungsloser und AI.
Montabaur.
Ich kann...
Also, bei meinem Ex-Arbeitgeber
hatte ich mal einen, der
kam zu uns von 1&1
aus Montabaur.
Ich glaube, der hieß...
Stefan?
Ich weiß es gar nicht mehr genau.
Oder Dominik oder so?
weiß ich gar nicht, ewig her.
Und er hat damals schon gesagt,
Kackladen.
Sonst wäre er nicht gewechselt.
Ja, also.
Kannte er
Also der wusste, dass es den Typ wohl wirklich gibt.
Ja.
Also.
Die Personalchefung erklärte...
Lass mich raten, bevor ich das lese, was sie erklärt hat.
Die erzählt bestimmt den üblichen Blödsinn von...
Wir müssen die Zusammenarbeit und das Zusammengehörigkeitsgefühl vor Ort stärken und die Teams arbeiten vor Ort besser zusammen als Remote oder dieses Standard dumme Gelaber, was es da immer gibt.
Aufgrund der unterschiedlichen Vorstellungen zur Ausstellung der Arbeitszeiten im Coverday, was auch immer, sehen wir uns in der Slider dazu veranlasst, den mitbestimmten Betrieb in Montemont in Geltung der UL-Richtlinie zu Coverdays.
Was von was spricht die überhaupt?
denkt die irgendwelche irgendwelche 1&1 interne begriffe ist was für die allgemeine los
also wirklich mitbestimmt scheint das ja nicht so sein
IT System Administrator. Wir klicken jetzt einfach random drauf.
Cyber Security Senior Professional, Alter!
Eine mittlere zweistellige Zahl an Beschäftigten hat 100% mobiles Arbeiten per Arbeitsvertrag zugesichert.
Ja, das kommt bestimmt aus den Zeiten, wo sie halt händeringend Leute gesucht haben und da Zugeständnisse gemacht haben oder Leute, die abwandern wollten und dann Zugeständnisse gemacht haben.
Also kann man nur sagen, High IQ gewesen von den Leuten, die gesagt haben, ich verlasse mich nicht alleine auf das, was ihr sagt, sondern will, dass das bei mir im Arbeitsvertrag drin steht.
Komm mal hier, was für ein Zeug sich zusammen lügen wieder, Alter.
Meiner Vermutung nach zumindest.
Die Rücknahme der bisherigen Homeoffice-Regelung steht im Zusammenhang mit der gesetzlichen Verpflichtung zur Einführung der Arbeitszeiterfassung.
Ja, komisch, dass es an anderen Standorten ja wohl funktioniert.
Und komisch, diese Arbeitszeiterfassungsregelung, die gibt es schon deutlich länger als da, wo sie den Betriebsrat gewählt haben.
Hm, könnte das vielleicht sein, dass das nicht stimmt?
Ja, ja.
Bla, bla, bla.
Was ein Geschwätz, ey.
Golem.
Golem-Kommentare sind auch nicht viel besser als heiße Kommentare.
Was wollen die hier?
Ich weiß nicht, warum ich das angeklickt habe.
einfach so randem war okay ist ganz normal nach 15 stellen anzeige ja 1 1
aber ich hatte nie vor zu 1 1 zu gehen also wie gesagt ich habe von dem
ehemaligen kollege der bei 1 1 war erfahren dass das ein zimmer kackladen
ist aus seiner sicht ja ich habe das jetzt einfach mal so übernommen meine
ansicht dazu würde hingehen generell würde ich aktuell also es
müsste schon wirklich viel passieren aktuell dass ich meinen arbeitgeber wechseln weil geld gibt es
genug arbeit ist nice chef ist nice beziehungsweise chefs in nice leute sind nice home office regelung
ist nice kantine ist nice selbst selbst büro ist nice ich habe eine linux vm mit grafikkarte drin
und einem Remote Desktop,
wo ich mich kaum noch mit Windows rumschlagen muss.
Das ist auch nice.
Also insofern,
warum sollte ich wechseln?
Also ohne Scheiß,
ich bin ja käuflich, was sowas angeht.
Der einzige Grund wahrscheinlich,
das kann ich noch nicht mal sagen,
aber ohne Mist,
also sie müssten mir schon verdammt viel mehr Geld bieten,
dass ich da wechseln würde.
in irgendwas Ungewisses.
Also, sie müssten mir schon so viel bezahlen,
dass ich nach ein paar Jahren
definitiv ausgesorgt hätte für immer.
So, dann würde ich es machen.
Aber ansonsten...
Warum?
Bist du eigentlich auf LinkedIn?
Ja.
Da bin ich.
Nee, bin ich nicht.
Bin ich nicht.
Weil
ich hab den Zugang
zu dem Account gar nicht mehr.
Ansonsten hab ich kein LinkedIn-Profil.
Ich sorge manchmal
auf LinkedIn. Ein paar ehemalige Kollegen.
Was die so treiben.
und der eine ist jetzt irgendwo was weiß ich chief cloud architekt sonst was und
der postet immer diese typischen linkedin post wie wir xyz nutzen um
unseren was weiß ich products lifecycle die low hanging fruits zu optimieren und
sowas.
So komisches Zeug postet
er dann immer und andere komische Leute
liken das dann und sowas.
Also keine Ahnung, was da abgeht.
Aber LinkedIn ist eh
extrem cringe, ja.
Und was bei den LinkedIn
Posts ja immer so ist,
so, was ich selbst aus
XYZ gelernt habe.
So übelst
abgedrehte Dinger stehen dann
da.
So, letztens hatte ich mit dem Fahrrad, letztens wurde ich beim Fahrradfahren von einem Auto überfahren.
Was ich daraus gelernt habe, um den Shareholder Value zu raisen.
Oder keine Ahnung, so dummes Zeug, aller LinkedIn.
By the way, mein Fahrrad ist immer noch kaputt.
Aber das liegt nicht daran, dass ich vom Auto überfahren wurde.
Ich wurde noch nie glücklicherweise vom Auto überfahren.
Ich wurde nur einmal auf dem Fahrrad vom Auto angefahren.
Aber das ist auch schon eine Weile her, das ist gar nicht mehr das Fahrrad.
Ähm, meine Schaltung ist immer noch kaputt, beziehungsweise wahrscheinlich nur mein Schaltauge, aber ich war bisher zu faul, das zu reparieren.
Seit drei Monaten oder so.
Dü-dü-dü-dü-dü-dü-dü.
Wie viele deiner Kollegen sind noch bei der alten Arbeit? Also du meinst die, die ich noch persönlich kenne?
Eins
Zwei
Drei
Vier
Ich glaube nur noch vier Stück
Und wirklich gut kennen
Tue ich da eigentlich nur zwei davon
Der Rest ist glaube ich weg
Von
Ich weiß nicht wie viele
die wir da ursprünglich waren, aber
aber bestimmt 20 oder so.
Wenn ich öfters zusammengearbeitet habe.
Ich glaube,
es sind nur noch von denen,
mit denen ich wirklich viel was zusammen gemacht habe,
sind glaube ich nur noch zwei Stück da, beim alten Arbeitgeber.
Der Rest hat sich innerhalb Deutschland
verteilt mittlerweile.
Ups.
Also was trennt er denn hier noch? Lass mal gucken.
Voice Studio, das hatten wir schon.
AI.
Flutter.
Warum trennt er denn Flutter?
Hat Flutter wieder ein neues Release rausgehauen, oder?
Flutter.
Macht Flutter überhaupt keine Releases?
Gibt es da keine Releases mehr, oder was ist da los?
Keine Flutter-Releases?
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Was auch immer die da treiben.
Gibt es da keine?
Releases?
Hä?
Moment.
Müsste es da nicht eigentlich einen Button für geben?
Bin ich jetzt zu dumm dafür?
Wo ist der Releases Button?
Mal ganz davon abgesehen,
irgendwie releasen sie auch nichts mehr.
Aber taggen tun sie noch.
aber habt ihr das auch gehabt github war gestern und vorgestern wieder massive
kaputt ohne scheiß github ist der wirklich der räumlichste schlechteste
high available service den ich kenne
ich weiß nicht was sie da machen hier
ihr guckt euch das immer an
Moment, das ist übrigens noch nicht mal die richtige.
Das ist noch nicht mal die richtige, warte mal.
Da gab es doch bessere.
Oder ist es das?
Es gab doch...
Es gab doch so eine andere Ansicht.
Wo man das besser gesehen hat.
Lobster-Ass.
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Ne, es gab eine bessere...
Es gab eine bessere...
Ne, das hier nicht.
Es gab so eine bessere Übersicht, wo die auch die ganzen anderen Services mit einbetracht haben.
Also nach dem Motto, okay, ging nur die Webseite, ging auch die einzelnen Files anzuzeigen und sowas.
Missing GitHub Status Page.
Ist es das?
Ja, das meine ich.
Das meine ich.
Die meine ich, genau.
Kleiner Buckmann.
Die Mega-News mitbekommen, ne?
Doch, das habe ich gelesen irgendwo.
How is it possible?
Ja, nice.
Können wir vielleicht mal wieder ein gescheites Modern Warfare spielen.
Aber das Ding ist halt, so Dinger werden halt relativ schnell wieder von Activision direkt
weggestrikt.
How is it possible?
Da wusste ich, aber...
Why isn't it possible?
Meme.
Ja, genau, Mario.
Mario Kart, gab's doch was.
Das fand ich eigentlich ganz...
Jeder, der damals Mario Kart 64 gespielt hat, wird das nachfühlen können.
Das war Marios Rennpiste oder sowas.
Wo man zum Schloss fahren konnte und dann konnte man nicht rein.
Ja, aber die GitHub-Status-Page habe ich gemeint.
Genau, da sieht man auch hier, gerade die letzten Tage ging es anscheinend echt ein bisschen bergab.
Wobei, sieht man gar nicht.
Zumindest war GitHub im Arsch.
Gestern hatte ich Probleme und richtig massive stundenlang am Freitag.
Warum Flutter trendet, wissen wir immer noch nicht genau.
Das ist wieder so eine Projektbeschreibung, wo ich absolut keinen blassen Schimmer habe, was es eigentlich bedeuten soll.
Domain-Specific Language, damit kann ich ja noch halbwegs sagen, Design to Streamline the Development of High-Performance GPU CPU Accelerator Kernels.
Was?
gpu ist soweit ich weiß dass ui unter z
gpu das was was z verwendet na ja genau für ihr für irgendwie was ich eigentlich ganz cool finde
dass es das gibt.
Entkoppelt vom Editor.
Als Package.
Finde ich
sehr nice.
Also wenn man mal Cross-Plattform
UI
basteln möchte,
in Rust, ist das hier glaube ich
gar nicht so verkehrt.
Cross-Plattform High Performance.
Mich würde tatsächlich noch interessieren,
worauf das basiert.
Ich glaube ja nicht, dass es irgendein Webview ist.
Dafür ist Ted zu schnell.
Also die müssen die Controls ja höchstwahrscheinlich selber malen.
Gehe ich jetzt mal einfach von aus.
Das ist schick animiert.
Also wenn ich mal ein Cross-Plattform-GUI baue, überlege ich ernsthaft, das dann damit zu machen.
Aber ich brauche so gut wie nie Cross-Plattform-GUIs.
Gibt es eigentlich
Da müssen wir gerade mal was gucken
EPUI für Go?
Ne
Nur Rust
Omega Rust
Wobei das eigentlich gar kein großes Ding ist
man könnte ja ein statisches Rust Binary
kompilieren, was man aus einer statischen
Go-Anwendung aufrufen kann.
Sofern das keine Bindings zu irgendwelchen
C-Libraries braucht. Weil sobald wieder
C-Go ins Spiel kommt, ist wieder abfuck.
Wie dem auch sei.
Das finde ich ein nice Projekt.
PyTorch kennen wir schon. Money Printer Turbo.
Jawoll.
Joinks.
Joinks any video from your terminal.
No shady ads.
Das heißt, das ist sowas wie YouTube.dl
oder was?
Okay.
Wollen wir mal probieren,
ob das funktioniert?
Ich installiere mir nicht...
Achso, Moment, Moment.
Powered by YouTube.dl.
Ja, Moment, warum brauche ich das dann noch?
Jetzt mal eine ganz doofe Frage.
Wozu brauche ich das denn, wenn ich YouTube.dl habe?
Nee, Kurzwort kenne ich nicht.
Und wenn, würde ich es wahrscheinlich nicht sagen.
Ink.
Was zum Teufel ist denn?
React for Interactive Command Line Apps.
Üh.
Will ich das wirklich haben?
In was ist das?
Das ist bestimmt TypeScript, oder?
Ja, ja, TypeScript.
Warum brauche ich das denn, wenn ich einfach YouTube-DLP verwenden könnte?
Verstehe ich nicht.
Check ich nicht. Bin ich zu dumm für.
Oh.
Arch User Repo Timeout.
Wenn die wieder gedodst.
Keckweight.
Auer DDoS
Oh
Leute
Archinox DDoS wieder am Laufen
F
Na gut, dass ich vorhin die Packages
nicht aktualisiert habe
Wer weiß, was da wieder für Supply Chain
Sachen am Start werden
Ja, ähm, aber...
DDoS Arch, by the way.
Ja.
Ich mein, ich wollte grad sagen,
wir könnten jetzt einfach irgendwie
einen Watch drauf machen, aber wir sollten jetzt nicht
zum DDoSen indirekt mit beitragen,
indem wir das jetzt 30.000 Mal ausführen.
Schreibst da grad ein Paper drüber.
Wenn du da ein Paper drüber
schreibst, was empfiehlst du denn,
um nicht so anfällig zu sein gegen Supply Chain Attacks.
Also ich habe ja da so meinen Weg dafür.
Was würdest du empfehlen, um nicht so anfällig zu sein?
Für Consumer, für Entwickler halt.
Für Entwickler, die Zeug programmieren.
Ja, Hobby-mäßig, privat oder auch professionellen Umfeld.
Keine Ahnung. Was würdest du sagen?
Also Entwickler.
Ja, Entwickler.
Bin ich mal gespannt, was da der Experte
zu sagt.
Versus das, was ich mache.
So, schauen wir nochmal kurz, was trendet.
Dann gucken wir in den Chat, was er sagt.
Tool for Automatic PS5
Executable Porting to Linux und Windows.
Moment, was? Was? Was?
Bitteschön!
Moment.
Ja, das ist irgendein
Proof of Concept, oder?
Liste of verified games.
Ja, okay.
Das ist mehr oder weniger Proof of Concept.
Aber coole Sache.
Leider ist es C++.
Das heißt, es ist nicht lesbar.
Oder wieder.
Der C++-Erfinder, der, der, der, wie heißt er?
Bjarne Strusup oder so.
Der spricht C++ immer so geil aus.
Der sagt nicht C++ oder C++, der sagt C++, sagt er. C, C++.
Aber C++ hat eh verkackt. Die hätten die Chance gehabt, C++, genau so.
Die haben eh verkackt, die hätten die Chance gehabt, einen Rust-like Borrow-Checker einzubauen für diesen Standard.
haben sich aber, wer hätte das gedacht, für irgendwas overengineertes, wahnsinnig kompliziertes, nicht fertiges entschieden.
Wer hätte nur das erwarten können vom C++-Gremium, Leute?
Das ist ja ganz unbekannt, dass die irgendwelche overengineerten, undurchdachten, nicht fertige Dinger beschließen.
Im Prinzip so, wie sich die gesamte C++-Standard-Library liest.
Wo wir gerade dabei sind
Kann C++ mittlerweile eigentlich
Strings splitten?
Ich glaube immer noch nicht, oder?
Ich glaube
Nein, geht immer noch nicht
Aber es gibt jetzt
Es gibt jetzt immerhin, ich glaube, es gibt jetzt diese neuen Dinger.
Wie heißt das in C++?
Standard?
View?
Nee, Moment.
Wie heißt dann diese komische neue hässliche Syntax?
Die denken, sie erlaufen irgendeinen anderen Shit aus.
Pipe Filter Syntax.
Wie heißt das?
Ranges.
Ranges Split String.
Das gibt es auch bestimmt mittlerweile.
Okay, hier, okay, pass mal auf
Super lesbar, Standard
Ranges, Split, View
Standard Ranges, View, Split
Okay, so
Ähm
Das, ich bin immer wieder begeistert
Von C++, ja
Das hier ist ein Beispiel, und sogar das Beispiel
Ist scheiße zu lesen
Ey, könnt ihr vergessen, könnt ihr vergessen.
Aber immerhin,
ESP32, das SDK
von Espressif,
das ist mittlerweile
auch auf C++26
immerhin angekommen. Das ist nice.
Also immerhin C++26, das ist übelst neu.
Also die sind da
mittlerweile ziemlich auf Zack.
Ghost Track.
Useful Tool to track location or mobile number.
Moment, warum kriegt das...
Warum hat das 1600 Sterne die Woche?
Wurde aber zuletzt vor drei Jahren aktualisiert?
By the way, wie soll das funktionieren, irgendwelche Telefonnummern zu tracken?
Keine Ahnung.
Copy-paste ich mir mal raus, das hört sich recht interesting an tatsächlich.
Okay, copy-paste geht wieder nicht.
Ah ne, es geht nur in die andere Richtung.
Okay, was trendet?
Das waren jetzt die Overall-Trends.
Die waren jetzt wieder mal nicht so spannend.
Was trendet denn?
Komm, wir gucken mal, was in Go trendet.
Ich baue aktuell gerade eine Go-Anwendung.
By the way, Chat, jetzt wo so viele da sind, soll ich euch mal meine neueste...
Moment, war das hier mal zu?
Zack, nee, das wollte ich eigentlich gar nicht.
Soll ich euch mal meine neueste Anwendungsschöpfung zeigen?
Den SSH-Champ.
Jetzt sind 100 Leute mehr da als vorher.
Ich kann es ja nochmal kurz zeigen.
Wer war vorhin noch nicht dabei und will den SSH-Champ sehen?
Für alle Admins unter uns ist das FyFet-Anwendung.
Den SSH-Champ gibt es, by the way, auch auf GitHub,
aber das ist ernst gemeint, was hier steht.
Experiment do not use yet.
Okay?
Das ist nur Experimental.
Und es ist nicht Vibe-Coded.
Es ist nur manche Sachen Korrektur gelesen von KI.
Aber es ist nichts Vibe-Coded.
Es ist supported by KI manche Sachen.
Ja, wo ich keinen Bock habe, mir das selbst zusammenzusuchen,
wie man beispielsweise Notifications schickt.
Also, eine Sache ist
halt KI,
hab ich copy-pasted aus KI,
wie man unter Linux Notifications schickt.
So Desktop-Notifications,
dass es hier oben aufploppt. Ganz ehrlich,
das hätte ich mir von Hand raussuchen können.
Ist im Endeffekt ja auch nur hier
ein Aufruf, ja,
passenden Aufruf, passenden Parametern,
aber bis ich mir den Scheiß von Hand rausgesucht hätte,
hätte ich zwei Stunden gebraucht.
Da hab ich mir mal KI gefragt. Für sowas ist das wunderbar.
Aber der Rest ist nicht wipecoded.
Also gar nichts dran, Vibe-Code.
Es ist nur supported an manchen Stellen.
Also im Prinzip so, wie ich der Meinung bin,
KI sinnvoll auch, wo es sinnvoll ist, zu benutzen.
Was macht denn der Hard-P-Champ?
Noch nichts weiter gemacht.
Okay, also ich zeige euch schnell mal den SSH-Champ, Leute.
Ganz kurz, weil 100 Leute ungefähr haben es schon gesehen,
die anderen 100 noch nicht.
Deswegen zeige ich es jetzt mal.
Leute, ihr kennt doch bestimmt das Problem.
Ihr geht per SSH auf einen Server.
Ja, zum Beispiel hier auf diesem Raspberry Pi.
Und dann...
Und da liegt eine Datei, ja?
var log...
Da liegt eine Datei auf dem Server, hier var log...
Keine Ahnung, von config log, so, whatever, ja?
So, die guckt ihr euch an und stellt fest...
Ah!
Also geht mal davon aus, das Log ist jetzt ein bisschen länger, okay?
Weil so kann man das einfach copy-pasten.
Jetzt seht ihr die Datei und denkt, oh Mist, die Datei brauche ich ja bei mir lokal.
Die muss ich per Teams schicken, per E-Mail schicken, lokal irgendwie nochmal ein bisschen was dran analysieren oder sonst was.
Also ich brauche die Datei irgendwie vom Server runter.
Normalerweise geht man jetzt hin und sagt, SCP, bla bla bla bla, Datei kopieren nach lokal.
Du brauchst aber immer ein zweites Terminal, du musst immer das SCP eintippen und sowas.
Das ist eklig.
Noch problematischer wird es, wenn du über irgendwelche Zwischenproxys hoppst oder gar von SSH zu SSH interaktiv springst und dann auf irgendeinem Server bist, drei hops weiter und brauchst eine Datei lokal.
Solange die Dateien kurz sind und Text-only, kann man die Copy-Pasten.
Wenn die nicht Text-only sind, kann man so Base64 encoden und Copy-Pasten, das geht.
Ist die Datei allerdings ein bisschen länger, so sowas hier zum Beispiel, ja, dann ist das in der Tat relativ schwierig.
Und deswegen habe ich für mich, es ist aus eigener, aus eigenem Use Case entstanden, habe ich mir gedacht, wir bauen einen kleinen, der ist mittlerweile gar nicht mehr so klein, der ist schon ein paar hundert Zeilen go, einen SSH Rapper.
Und es ist auch wirklich ein...
Es ist auch wirklich nur ein SSH-Wrapper, weil wenn ihr beispielsweise SSH...
Also das ist eigentlich gedacht, dass man sagt alias SSH gleich App, dann später, ja?
Also wenn ihr den SSH-Champ ausführt...
Warum nicht SSH-Champ? Weil ich die Sachen immer mit großem S, beziehungsweise großem Buchstaben anfange.
So, wenn ich App-V mache, dann kriegt man auch, also das rappt 1 zu 1 SSH.
Ja, also auch alles hier kriegt ihr SSH und es geht auch alles, was ihr hier, Port Forwarding, Proxys erstellen, also geht alles.
So, aber wir machen das jetzt mal.
Ich verbinde mich jetzt mal hier auf meinen Raspberry Pi.
So, und jetzt sagen wir, aha, ah, guck mal hier, da gibt es jetzt ja einen Fehler.
Ja, das hätte ich gerne, dieses Log hier, hätte ich gerne bei mir lokal.
Wie würde man das normalerweise jetzt machen, ja?
Wie würdet, jetzt Chat, jetzt mal, wie würdet ihr das jetzt machen?
Ja, du könntest das beispielsweise nach slash tmp schreiben, hier plupp.log.
Dann könntest du sagen, scp max add, tem plupp.log, kopieren nach Downloads und so, ne?
Und so weiter und so fort.
Das könnte man jetzt machen.
Mit dem SSH Champ ist das Ganze viel einfacher.
Guckt mal, was ihr da machen könnt.
Ihr könnt die Maske nehmen.
Pipen.
Nach zum Beispiel Champ.
Clip.
Zack.
Und seht ihr da.
Ihr habt es im Clipboard drin.
Oder ihr könnt auch sagen.
Champ.
Push.
Kriegt ihr eine Abfrage.
Standard.
In.
wollt ihr eine neue Datei akzeptieren von
Standard-In vom PXE-Champ?
Sagt ihr Yes. Wird die Datei
kopiert, sogar mit Notification.
Und jetzt geht ihr mal lokal bei euch
in den Download-Ordner
und siehe da,
da gibt es einen Ordner, PXE-Champ
und da drin gibt es eine Standard-In.
Wenn man da jetzt reinguckt,
zack, ja guck mal da,
ist das Log.
Das geht auch noch anders, das geht
jetzt nicht nur reinpipen, das geht
auch mit Dateien. Ja, ihr könnt auch
zum Beispiel sagen, hier, das da,
die Datei hier, die
die Datei, die will ich jetzt kopieren.
Jawohl. New File
from PXHM, accept. Yes.
Blubb. Kopiert nach lokal.
Und jetzt ist die im Download-Ordner
drin. Ist das nicht nice?
Das Ganze funktioniert mit Trick 17
mit Terminal Escape Sequenzen
und dementsprechend auch über
beliebig viele SSH-Hops
drüber.
in Zukunft ist geplant, dass es auch
über einige T-Mark Sessions hinweg
funktioniert. Da muss ich aber noch ein bisschen mehr
escapen für.
Ist schon praktisch, ne?
Und, äh, um es euch mal
zu zeigen, ja,
das Ganze geht auch.
Äh, das war jetzt sehr schlau,
die Datei hier einfach so random zu ketten.
Herzlich zu ketten.
Das geht auch
mit Binary Files, das ist kein Problem.
es checkt allerdings und das finde ich habe ich auch ganz clever gemacht der
weiß selbstlob und so aber das muss muss man guck wenn ich wenn ich jetzt hier
sage ich will das hier pushen nach ins clipboard auf ok er sagt immerhin
binary data im input ist mal break your clipboard ok also er hat jetzt er hat
jetzt das nicht ins clipboard kopiert
Er hat es nicht ins Clipboard kopiert.
Terminal wird natürlich weiterhin versaut, ja, aber er hat es nicht ins Clipboard kopiert.
Ich habe da ein paar Checks drin.
Sind Binary Daten drin, dann vielleicht besser nicht ins Clipboard kopieren.
Und ist es über 10 MB groß, dann vielleicht auch besser nicht ins Clipboard kopieren.
Aber das ist sehr praktisch, ne?
Und wie das Ganze funktioniert, ich will das noch ganz kurz nochmal zeigen,
die entscheidende Stelle, das geht über Terminal Escape Sequenzen.
also die gesamte datei läuft im endeffekt über standard über standard wird vom ssh champ
abgefangen und in der datei umgeleitet das habe ich mir nicht selbst ausgedacht dass es ist das
sind escape sequenzen die western übrigens teilweise auch unterstützt die hat item 2
erfunden das ist ein terminal für mac os da bin ich grad bin ich gerade dran am
basteln und ich habe das aus purem eigennutz erstellt weil ich habe es auf
der arbeit öfters war dass ich per ssh auf den server muss von dort per ssh auf
einen anderen server und davon ssh noch mal auf landen selber
Ja.
So schaut's aus.
Du-du-du.
Du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du.
Excellent.
So, das hab ich nochmal gezeigt.
Ihr könnt mir gerne, wenn es euch gefällt,
prinzipiell, vom Ansatz her,
könnt ihr mir gerne einen Stand da lassen auf GitHub.
Wie gerade auch schon werdet ihr gemacht haben.
Aber, wie gesagt, Leute,
ich sag's nochmal, das ist noch nicht
dafür gedacht.
Ich hab das auch nicht wirklich getestet.
Es könnte sein,
es kommt zwar eine Abfrage,
es kommt zwar eine Abfrage, ob man
die Datei akzeptieren will vom Server.
Aber wie secure das ist, weiß ich nicht.
Also falls jetzt irgendjemand euch was
auf Standard-Out schicken kann,
auf dem Server, dann könnt ihr euch
irgendeine Datei schicken. Vielleicht, weil ich
nicht weiß, wie sicher das ist.
Aber das ist doch recht unwahrscheinlich, gerade in Trusted-Umgebung.
Nee, nee, noch nicht.
Trends wäre jetzt ziemlich sinnlos.
Erst wenn das ordentlich
freigegeben ist von mir zum Einsatz.
So, excellent.
Ich wollte ja noch gucken, was hier trendet bei Go.
Was trendet Go technisch?
KI, oder? Nee, keine KI.
Auch keine KI.
Ah, das kenne ich.
Das ist so ein Credentials-Dings.
Security-Scanner.
Da steht ja, hier liegt Credentials und sowas.
ja das kenne ich das ding ein ebpf das ist so kölner level netzwerk rahmen callbacks
transfer in proxy solution okay wie darf ich mir das vorstellen was soll das sein ebpf based
high linux high performance transfer in proxy solution a ja exzellent
How does it work?
Okay
Das ist was für die China-Chinesen auf jeden Fall schon mal
Mon KS
Was?
Das ist was um China-Chinesen-Fireball zu umgehen
Aber wer weiß
Die EU ist auf dem besten Weg dahin
das braucht man bei uns wahrscheinlich demnächst auch.
Übrigens, das finde ich auch richtig
sad, dass
GitHub die
Star-Army abgeschafft hat.
Also du kannst jetzt zwar Repos noch
starren, aber
du siehst nicht mehr,
wer die Repos gestarrt hat, was ich ziemlich sad
finde.
Was auch
sagt für
Analyse-Tools und sowas.
Wobei ich...
Quickstart, okay.
What the fuck?
Das erscheint mir ein bisschen kompliziert,
ehrlich gesagt.
ja und wie benutzt man das jetzt
gibt es da irgendwo eine how to usage?
nö gibt es nicht
bei how it works gibt es aber so usage example vielleicht
user guide
ok keine ahnung
Doch bei eigenen Repos geht das.
Ja, das mag sein, aber es ist doch trotzdem doof, dass es nicht mehr geht bei anderen Repos.
Gerade irgendwelche Analyse-Tools, die GitHub-Repos gecrawled haben und besser suchbar und bessere Trends und so, kannst du voll vergessen jetzt.
So, was trennen wir denn hier?
Das hatten wir, das hatten wir, das hatten wir.
Net Data, brauchen wir net.
Das gibt's doch schon ewig
und hatte noch nie was mit AI zu tun.
Warum hat das auf einmal was
mit AI zu tun?
Und warum haben die gar keine Screenshots mehr in ihrem Repo?
Es gibt schon 50 Jahre
Netdata
Warum das jetzt
Auf einmal KI ist, weiß ich nicht
Übrigens, ich hab auch nie den
Den richtig, den Anwendungszweck
Für Netdata hab ich auch nie kapiert
Weil das ist ja ohne Persistence
Yep, CockroachDB
Prometheus
Open Bao
Hm
Sollte ich
meine Secrets wirklich bei einer
China-Chinesen Software storen?
Also das klingt zumindest China-Chinesen mäßig
aber ist es glaube ich gar nicht klingt klingt einfach nur china chinesen mäßig
das kenne ich da kannst du web server benchmarken oder laut laut
generate kubo nidus gott rennt ja gott rennt weil gott hatte 127 release vor
noch nicht allzu langer zeit
Ja.
1, 2, 7. Guck hier, da.
Naja, gut.
Ist schon einen halben Monat, nur noch länger.
Okay, ich nehm das zurück.
Ist schon eine ganze Weile her.
ok nichts spannendes dabei ein projekt noch was trennt denn in rast blazing die laser speed fast
leute gpu kit das würde ich das würde ich echt gerne mal ausprobieren ich habe noch mal rein
hier du ich habe doch irgendwo stream themen wie ist das ding
ok als nächstes china chinesen datenbank stellt omni ssh open source ssh klein
ein server manager von mac os windows native live matrix das was warum brauche
ich in ssh klein mit live matrix dashboard aller
Achso.
Okay.
Naja.
Gut.
Wer es braucht.
Nicht, dass die das gleiche machen wie der SSH-Champ, ne?
Das geht ja nicht.
Ne, aber anscheinend nicht.
Wir suchen da. Wir suchen da mal nach 1337.
Oh.
Kann das nicht.
SSH Champ ist safe.
Hydra DB.
Hyperswitch.
Topcode.
Das wollte ich einmal ausprobieren.
Das haben wir glaube ich schon hier in unserer...
Wir müssen das mal ausprobieren.
Stehen.
Ja.
Das Ding hat einen Streamer-Mode.
Was ist das?
SSH-Ding?
Ja.
Mal gucken.
Nicht, dass es das gleiche macht, wie der SSH-Champion.
Aber das glaube ich nicht.
Ne, macht es nicht.
Ups, vielleicht soll ich nicht.
Topcode wollte ich mir auch mal angucken.
Wobei ich damit wahrscheinlich nichts großartig machen werde.
Also ganz ehrlich, da kriege ich Anfälle hier.
Bei dieser Syntax.
und für meine Zwecke, ja, ich mache ja keine Public Web Anwendungen,
die irgendwie besonders gut in Google ranken sollen,
kann ich einfach ganz normales Weltkit Client-Site Anwendungen machen und gut ist.
Aber für alles andere, ja, die schnelle First-Page-Views haben wollen
und gutes Suchmaschinen-Ranking ist sowas nicht verkehrt.
Man kann natürlich auch das ganze Full-Stack mit Weltkit oder mit Node.js und anderen Sachen machen.
Open Observe.
Das habe ich mir doch mal angeguckt, oder?
Im Stream.
Haben wir uns das nicht mal angeguckt?
Das kommt mir bekannt vor.
Hm.
Ich glaube, das haben wir uns im Stream schon mal angeguckt.
Damals war das aber überhaupt noch nicht wirklich ready.
Es hat mir vom Ansatz her ganz gut gefallen damals.
Ja, guck mal, das ist schon drei Jahre oder so her, da haben wir uns das angeguckt.
Da fand ich es vom Ansatz her gar nicht so doof, aber das war noch nicht ready damals.
Und ansonsten ist halt die Frage, ob du wirklich so eine integrierte Plattform und vor allem, ob du diesen ganzen Krempel brauchst, ja.
weil ich mein,
zentrales Logging,
kannst du ja, ich mein, es gibt, es gibt,
es gibt auch noch sowas wie Syslog, ja,
für zentrales Logging, ich sag's nur,
so die Oldschool-Sache,
ach so, aggregieren von Logs,
Analyse, hauptsächlich Alerting über Fehler,
ach so, okay, es geht ja nicht nur ums Logs sammeln,
tja,
Da kann ich dir gar nichts zu raten, ehrlich gesagt.
Ich habe lokal nichts Großartiges laufen für dauerhafte Log-Auswertung.
Auf der Arbeit haben wir notgedrungenes Splunk, weil das die Firma irgendwann mal einführen wollte.
Das ist auch ganz brauchbar, aber ich glaube, das ist für dich wahrscheinlich auch übelstes Overkill.
Was natürlich geht, ist im kleinen Stil, ja.
es gibt Prometheus-Exporter,
die
Log-Dateien
ingesten können und daraus
Metriken generieren.
Wenn du nur so Dinger brauchst wie
steht Error im Log,
dann
Metrik soll Fehler melden
und sowas.
Da gibt es fertige
Prometheus-Exporter für, die so einfache Dinge
machen. Wenn du natürlich die Logs
indizieren willst, durchsuchbar haben willst
und sowas, da ist das nix.
Da kann ich dir gar nichts
Großartiges zu raten, aber ich bilde mir ein
Ich hab mal ein Setup Video für Loki mir angeguckt
Und
Loki war
Relativ easy zu installieren
Du brauchst nur, wie hieß das
Locktail oder so
Wie ist das so
Promptail.
Ja, das Ding brauchst du auf deinen Server.
Also das war,
soweit ich mir das angeguckt habe,
vom Setup her, nicht
sonderlich kompliziert.
Was trennt er denn sonst noch?
Hyperswitch, das hatten wir gerade schon.
Topcode hatten wir auch schon.
Open Shell.
Leute, ihr wisst es noch.
Tokens gleich Profit.
und wenn ihr einen Engineer für 150k
im Jahr einstellt, wenn der nicht mindestens
nochmal 150k Tokens ausgibt,
taugt da nix,
sagt der Nvidia-Chef.
Der muss es wissen.
Und für den stimmt das ja auch.
Für den sind ja auch
Tokens gleich Profit.
Für Nvidia stimmt das.
PPM.
Okay, Leute.
Auto-Shorts.
Aus Auto-Shorts könnte ich quasi aus meinen
Streams einen Clip erstellen.
Taugt das was?
Ich glaube ja eher nicht, oder?
Wir können das mal ausprobieren.
Aber das muss wahrscheinlich, weil das mit lokaler AI und sowas ist,
muss das wahrscheinlich auf Windows laufen, hä?
Dass das ordentlich performt.
Ah ja, geil.
Windows ist Linux-Installation.
Okay, gibt's immerhin, gibt's das schon mal?
Olamar plus Whisper, ja.
Dino!
Ach ja.
Gut.
Haben wir uns mal angeguckt, was so trendet.
Hält sich dieses Mal wieder in Grenzen die Spannung.
So, was haben wir denn hier auf YouTube?
Was können wir uns denn schönes mal angucken?
Wie gesagt, Leute, ich bin mir nicht sicher,
wie wie lange ich heute monka ist einer wie lange ob ihr welcher mitarbeiter
laut darf ein video sein ich bin mir nicht sicher wie lange ich online bin
als mir geht es nicht ganz so ganz ganz gut
die frist die cloud warum hätte erster anfang ist aha das kann man gucken gucke
ich immer gerne wie das von denen der aua wer von euch ist schon auf linux
umgestiegen
muss es muss ja auch es muss mal gucken was der bauer zu die rucksack ich bin
ich war der test hat hauptsächlich grafikkarten hardware kram performance
und so ich glaube da ist der hauptmarkt immer noch windows ja privat nicht so
experimentiert freudig was das betrifft ich habe einfach nicht die zeit nicht
damit auseinanderzusetzen, wenn ich irgendwas machen will,
dann muss es einfach gut sein. Ganz ehrlich, ich verstehe das auch voll und ganz.
Warum? Ja, wenn man,
die meisten Leute, die auf Linux umsteigen,
die sind einfach nur super krass
abgefuckt von Windows und wollen was anderes.
Das Problem ist, wenn du
Windows, äh, wenn du Linux quasi als
Windows-Ersatz siehst, der für dich
wie Windows funktionieren soll,
ohne die nervigen Punkte von Windows
wird das nicht funktionieren.
Du musst Linux schon als was Neues sehen
Vor allem wo du nicht unbedingt
Mit deinen alten Skills
Bei allem weiter kommst
Ja
Jetzt nur
Ja, gucken wir mal.
Das
Hetzen hat übrigens ihre Preise wieder
angehoben, habe ich gelesen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das
jetzt schon so ist oder ob sie es nur angekündigt haben.
Das haben wir schon geschaut.
Vor drei Monaten WTF.
Ja, ja, das haben wir schon geschaut.
Ah, die haben aber ihre Preise
wieder erhöht.
Aber die können ja letztendlich auch nicht wirklich was machen.
Ja, was sollen die machen? Für den wird der Kram halt auch teurer.
Lass mal kurz was gucken hier
Cloud Pricing
Ne, nicht irgendwie
Ich
Ich hatte noch so eine ganz normale Übersicht
Hatten die nicht mal
Okay, die hatten ja nicht mal so eine bessere
Hatten die nicht mal eine schönere Übersicht
Und was ich schade finde, meine Lieblings-VM gibt es schon so weile nicht mehr.
Meine Lieblings-VM war immer die 3-Kerne-Kiste.
Weil die war kaum teurer als die 2-Kerne-Kiste, hatte aber einen Kern mehr.
Ähm, Chat, wie sieht das von den Preisen her aus?
Was ist denn von den Preisen her aktuell attraktiver als Hetzner?
Was haben wir denn noch so zu bieten an der Reise?
Einen NetCup haben wir noch.
Einen OVH haben wir noch.
Wobei, zu OVH kann ich nicht.
OVH will einen Ausweisscan sehen.
Den kriegen die von mir nicht.
Ich sehe das nicht ein, dass ich den Ausweis an irgendwelche random Leute schicke.
IONOS habe ich.
Einen Server.
Einen 1-Euro-Server habe ich bei IONOS.
Mit einer festen IPv4-Adresse.
Die werde ich auch für immer behalten.
Hier, Servers.
akzeptieren abblick laut dedicated vps digital auch nicht los ist glaube ich auch ein bisschen
teurer kann man gucken strato was sind so die beliebten was sind so die beliebten hosting
anbieter in deutschland über hetzner ihr vps 2007 natürlich 2027 ist ja wie bei antivirus software
Erinnert sich noch einer an die Tage von irgendwelchen Internet Security Suite 2027?
Wann kam das Ganze raus? Januar 2026.
Die haben sich immer weiter überboten mit den Jahreszahlen.
Gibt es diesen Scheiß eigentlich noch?
Internet Security Suite?
Symantec war das?
Norton? Norton?
Norton Internet Security Suite?
Norton 360?
Fuck, den Scheiß gibt's immer noch.
Den Kram gibt's immer noch.
Was ist denn überhaupt die Daseinsberechtigung davon jetzt?
Cloud-Safe-
Oh, ganze 10 Gig Clouds Deutsch.
Ui.
Passwort-Manager, warum soll ich irgendeine random Pass-
Safe-Cam.
What?
Alter, was zum-
Hör mal bloß auf.
Okay, Products.
Compute. Compute nennt man das jetzt, by the way.
Das heißt nicht mehr irgendwie
VPS, VM, sondern Compute.
Compute, ja.
App-Plattform.
Droplet heißt der Kram schon immer bei denen.
Gibt das nicht einfach auch stinknormale
VPS-Server?
Eigentlich sind GPU-Droplets
Ich will einfach
stinknormale Leute.
Stinknormale
4Ms.
Wo gibt's die hier?
Droplets.
Das sind sie.
Getting started.
Ich will gucken, was es kostet.
Ja, basic.
Ach, naja.
Puh.
Das geht schon deutlich mehr ins Geld, wie
Hetzner und die anderen.
Ah, hier kriegst du, also
bei OVH kriegst du, lass mal
kurz vergleichen, Server.
Getting started.
22 pro Monat. Okay.
Okay, okay.
V-Server Lite.
Was soll
V-Server Lite bedeuten.
Soll das bedeuten, du hast eine
gesharete IP und alles
mögliche? Oder was, wie, wo, was ist
was ist, was ist Lite?
Cost optimized
V-Server Plans, fast secure hardware
jetzt interessiert mich nicht, nicht wirklich.
Was hat es denn so für
VPS Pico?
Ein Core, ein Gig RAM,
30 Gig SSD.
Naja, Leute,
sollte ich euch mal was sagen?
für so kleinkram für beispielsweise mal zum beispiel ja leute die eine
heimautomatisierung laufen haben bei sich daheim und sie brauchen ein paar
services der aus dem internet erreichbar sind ja zum beispiel presence presence
tracker so wo bist du also eines was die handys track wo man gerade ist und so
was da braucht man ja auch mal so ein public public endpoint das läuft locker
auf so einem Ding. Locker.
Die Sache ist nur die, krieg ich
eine IP dabei? Oder wie ist das?
Optionally included.
Okay. Und was?
Was kostet?
Was kostet? Ah, hier.
Wie? 0 Euro?
Aber man bezahlt ein bisschen weniger,
wenn man nur IPv6 nimmt.
Ja, für eine statische Webseite,
für Kleinkram, ganz ehrlich,
für Kleinkram reicht das auch.
Das ist okay.
Und ansonsten,
wenn ich mir hier so die anderen Sachen angucke,
ganz im Ernst,
mit 4 Kern und 8 Gig
kommst du schon sehr weit.
Auch mit 2-Kern und 4-Kick kommst du auch schon weit.
Was ist jetzt der Unterschied zwischen V-Server Lite?
Wahrscheinlich sind die Dinger maßlos überbucht, die V-Server Lite.
Price Optimized.
Okay, was ist denn der Unterschied zwischen...
Außer, dass sie kostoptimized sind.
Okay, da gibt es ein bisschen mehr
Jetzt schon
Ja, nimmt sich jetzt mit Hetzerpreisen
wirklich was, ne?
Vielleicht
Letztendlich, die kochen ja alle nur mit Wasser
Was willst du machen, ne?
Was willst du machen?
Guck das
Wobei ich sagen muss, 4 Kerne, 8 Gig
Das ist sehr günstig
Das ist in der Tat
Gar nicht so ohne
8 Euro
Hier 453
2 Core 4 Gig
Das ist gar nicht übel
Bei OVH
Das geht klar
Preislich finde ich
Ja
Oder hier 12
Guck mal
Das ist echt nicht übel
6 Kerne
12 Gig RAM?
Ja, haben die zu viel RAM gekauft
oder was?
Ah, dafür ist nicht so viel.
Ah, ne, 2 Gig.
Anbindung ist das jetzt nur.
Unbegrenzte.
Das ist,
also wenn das das auch hält,
was die Zahlen versprechen,
ist das preislich
gar nicht so schlecht.
Ich hoffe nur,
OVH will nicht wieder, dass man eine Ausweiskopie
hinschickt. Weil das mache ich nicht. Ich schicke
keine random Ausweiskopie irgendwo hin,
was dann auf einem umgeschützten Nas-Share
oder so rumliegt. Ja, guckt euch
den letzten Leak bei Revolut an.
Wo
Ausweisdaten, hier, guck.
Wo Ausweisdaten
und sonst was bei Revolut.
Und ich meine, da würde man vermuten, Revolut
als Bank aus Litauen,
glaube ich, hätte da
ein bisschen höhere Anforderungen an
Datensicherheit. Nö.
Also das kann jederzeit passieren.
Deswegen schicke ich keine Ausweiskopien mehr in der Welt rum.
Okay, das wird ein bisschen...
Das wird ein bisschen teurer jetzt.
High-Grade-Server.
Okay.
Ist ein bisschen teurer.
Sind aber auch schon fette Kisten dann.
Sind Ausweiskopien nicht sogar illegal?
Keine Ahnung. Sind es?
Sind sie es? Fragezeichen.
Ach, das sind die Preise,
wenn man zwölf Monate
mietet. Ach so.
Ach so.
Ach so. Ich dachte...
Ah ja, gut, da ist es natürlich ein bisschen teurer schon.
Das heißt, da wird aus der...
Naja, ein paar Cent teurer.
Leute, ich muss mich jetzt mal als Noob outen.
Was zum Teufel ist Cloud Linux?
Ist es das von Amazon?
Okay, keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Was ist das?
Habe ich ja nie gehört.
Ich habe keinen Plan, was das sein soll.
Du schmeißt mal ein paar kleinere Anbieter.
Okay, okay.
Disclaimer, arbeitest du bei einem dieser Anbieter?
Ich habe da nichts dagegen.
Wir können uns die trotzdem angucken.
Aber nur so Disclaimer, falls du dabei arbeitest.
Nee, machst du nicht?
Okay.
So was wie Talos?
Nee, glaube ich nicht.
Deinserverhost.de
Okay, das klingt schon...
KI-Linux-Bild.
Das geht schon gut los.
Komm, wir gucken uns aber ein paar kleinere
Hosting-Anbieter an. Zeig's
mal her. Okay. Erstmal
KI.
Live-Chat? Was?
Ich will kein Live-Chat.
Erstmal ein schönes KI-Bild. Nice.
So.
Das könnte auch sein,
dass die Webseite
zum nicht unerheblichen Teil KI generiert ist.
Wir machen mal hier Dark Reader aus.
Vielleicht sieht die Webseite dann nicht so
nicht so dark aus.
Okay, die Seite ist zumindest
schon mal schön schnell. Das finde ich ganz gut.
Also, lass mal kurz gucken. V-Server.
Cloud-Speicher. KVM-Server.
Ryzen neu. KVM-Server. Okay.
Und die neuen,
die sind besser. Was interessiert mich eigentlich?
Was da drunter ist großartig.
Ab 1 Euro im Monat.
Okay. Okay.
Wo ist der Haken?
Ab 2,70 Euro im Monat.
Okay, ein Kern und 2 Gig.
Game, was hat das mit Game zu tun?
Zwei Kerne, 6 Gig.
Das ist preislich auch nicht verkehrt.
So, und das sind hier...
Das sind die normalen...
Guck mal hier, ein Kern, ein Gig, 10 Gig SSD für 1 Euro im Monat.
Okay, 100 Mbit Shared, naja gut, ich mein, ey, was willst du für einen Euro im Monat erwarten, ja?
So, und 250 Gig Traffic.
Naja, sagen wir mal so, wenn du einfach nur eine statische Webseite hosten willst oder sowas,
mit statischem Content,
wo jetzt nicht viele Leute draufgehen,
was wahrscheinlich bei irgendeiner privaten
statischen Webseite für irgendwie,
was weiß ich, du bewirbst dich irgendwo und willst was
verlinken, dein, dein, äh,
deine Vita oder wie man das so nennt,
verlinken, ey, warum nicht?
Da reicht das dicke für, ja,
das ist vollkommen in Ordnung.
Alternativ haben wir noch
Das ist aber sehr günstig
Das glaube ich nicht
Das glaube ich ja nicht
Dass du für 3 Euro sowas kriegst
Das ist bestimmt
Ja bis zu
Okay
Okay, okay, okay, ja, ja, weißt du schon.
Zip, CPU-Kurs.
Okay, nehmen wir mal drei.
Okay, drei mit, sagen wir mal, okay, 4 Giga-Gramm.
Ja, da wird es schon ein bisschen, okay.
Aber das ist ja auch klar.
Ohne IPv4-Adresse.
By the way, die Webseite...
äh, suckt.
Manchmal, ich bin ja ein Fan von Native HTML Elementen, ja.
Aber manchmal sind nicht Native HTML Elemente von der Usability her schon besser.
Mehr gibt es nicht als eine.
Sie ist auf 2.
Ach so.
Okay, das ist wirklich Fail Usability.
Aber gut
Das lässt sich ja easy fixen
Das sind ja uralte Betriebssysteme
Das ist ja
Das ist ja uralt
Alter Leute
Debian 11, Ubuntu 22
Und Ubuntu 20
Wir sind bei Ubuntu 26
Und 4 LTS mittlerweile
und bei dem ja ein 13.
Also das ist vielleicht ein bisschen
zu Budget.
Wobei das insofern
natürlich nicht weiter tragisch ist.
Man kann den Kram ja selbst upgraden,
wenn es sein muss.
So.
Aber die Ryzen-Dinge,
muss ich mal sagen,
Die Ryzen-Dinger machen gar keinen allzu schlechten preislichen Eindruck
Ja, machen wir mal zwei Kerne
25 Gig ist auch mehr als ausreichend
Okay, maximal 2 Gig
Ja, na gut, dann machen wir mal so
Ey, ich mein, 2 Gig, 2 Kerne, 4 Euro, das ist schon in Ordnung
Nein, da haben... Ah, guck mal, hier gibt's jetzt auch...
Hier gibt's jetzt... Ah, Windows, okay
Hier gibt es zumindest Debian 13, damit bist du ja voll und ganz top.
Und wie kann man den mittleren konfigurieren?
Okay, da kann man sich drei...
Wie gesagt, mein persönlicher Geschmack sagt, der Sweetspot für Preis-Leistung bei VMs war früher immer drei CPU-Kerne.
Das war die Zeit, wo ich mir noch viele Server bei Hetzner gekauft habe.
Habe ich immer den 3-Core, die 3-Core-Kiste genommen.
Das ist eigentlich echt in Ordnung, Leute.
3 Kerne, 6 GIG RAM, 7 Euro im Monat?
Äh.
Ich check jetzt gerade nicht.
5,69 Euro pro Monat?
Warum?
Achso, das ist die Base-Konfiguration quasi
Okay, okay
Gut, ich würde es aber tatsächlich pro Monat machen
Pro Monat ist auch schon doof
Aber gut
Da musst du dich halt einen Monat festlegen
Ich bin ein Fan von
wenn die Anbieter halbminütlich
abrechnen.
Bei Deals.
Wo steht hier Deals?
Wie gesagt, von dem Anbieter habe ich noch nie was gehört.
Hier, das da.
Winterdeal.
Was hat man da?
Vier Kerne zählen.
Alter!
Das ist günstig.
Standort Frankfurt?
Also das ist wirklich günstig.
Vier Kerne, 10 Ggramm.
Also damit kannst du schon wirklich eine serious Web-Anwendung betreiben.
Damit kriegst du viele User abgespeist.
Achso, null erhältlich.
Keck weh.
Okay, war zu schön, um wahr zu sein.
Leider nicht verfügbar.
Das war zu schön, um wahr zu sein.
Dann hätte ich den... Ohne Scheiß,
ohne Scheiß, Leute,
hätte es den Server noch gegeben,
den hätte ich mir tatsächlich
einfach zum Testen mal bestellt.
Einfach mal gucken. Man muss ja ab und zu
immer kleineren Anbietern eine Chance geben, ja?
Warum nicht? Warum nicht?
KVM-Flex.
Weird-Flex.
Okay, sieht aber preislich auch ganz okay aus.
letztendlich nimmt sich das jetzt ja alles nicht so viel.
Das kostet alles
plus minus ein paar Euro.
Was mir persönlich bei Hetzner halt
gut gefallen hat, ist
also das Webinterface hat eine
super Usability und es geht saumäßig
schnell alles. Die haben eine ordentliche
CLI. Die haben einen ordentlichen
Terraform Provider.
Da könnte ich wetten, das haben die kleineren
Anbieter nicht. Beides nicht.
Hetzner
wollte nicht so einen Kack wie Ausweis einscannen
und ihnen schicken.
Das wollen die, glaube ich, nur für Domains.
Und ansonsten
war ich da eigentlich immer zufrieden mit.
Aber kann man trotzdem mal gucken. So, was haben wir sonst noch für Anbieter?
Der Bero-Haus. Okay.
Die Webseite ist vibecoded, Leute.
Sagt mir, was ihr wollt, aber die
ist vibecoded.
Auch die Animation. Das ist, Leute,
die Webseite, 100%.
Die ist so heftig vibecoded.
Was?
Alter, warum ist das so teuer?
Warum ist...
Ja, von wegen von
95.
90.
Achso, für ein Jahr.
Ey, ne.
Die Webseite kriegt Anfälle.
Alter, die Webseite.
Ne.
Da hab ich schon keinen Bock drauf.
Okay, die Webseite
könnte auch direkt Vibe Code sein.
KVM-Server.
Storage KVM-Server.
Okay, lass mal gucken, was haben die hier.
Configure Server.
Mini Storage.
2-Core, 2-Gig-Rahmen, 25.
Okay, das ist preislich in Ordnung.
1-Core, 2-Gig.
Ja, das ist wieder so für so
Kleingraben, ist auch okay.
Wie gesagt, es bewegt sich alles so ungefähr
im gleichen Rahmen.
1-Core.
Aber der andere, den fand ich,
den anderen, also das hier,
fand ich gar nicht so schlecht, wenn es
noch Winterdeals gegeben hätte.
Hätte es noch Winterdeals
Winterdeals gegeben, dann hätte ich
mich tatsächlich mal dazu durchringen
können,
das auszuprobieren.
Also das ist wirklich,
das wäre wirklich,
das wäre wirklich ein gutes Angebot.
Vier Kerne und 10 GIG RAM.
Scheiß drauf,
das DDR4 ist wie ein Juck, das hatte eh keiner
irgendwie Bandbreitenprobleme beim RAM.
Speicher auch mehr als genug.
Ein Gig Anbindung
shared, ja, okay.
Letztendlich, realistisch
betrachtet, ne,
die kleinen Anbieter,
alle haben letztendlich eine shared
Anbindung. Und zwar
in eigener Ablenk im Endeffekt.
Übrigens, was ich damals
beim Provider gelernt habe,
ich dachte ja immer, Peering
ist so was voll magisches
und so, ja, weil da wird
immer drüber gesprochen, so, ah, hier das
Peering von der Telekom und Cloudflare
und hier das Peering da und hier Peering
so und hier und da und sonst was.
Also ich hab Peering, damals
als ich beim Provider gearbeitet hab, mal live gesehen.
Unser Peering damals zu
Freenet, wisst ihr was das war?
Das war ein Kabel
gesteckt von uns
zu einem Rack nebendran.
Das war das Peering zu Freenet.
So.
Also da ist viel weniger Magic dabei,
als man eigentlich so denkt.
Damals gab es Freenet noch.
Ich glaube, Freenet gibt es gar nicht mehr.
Ich habe auch noch einen alten Vertrag
bei IONOS.
Ich habe einen 1-Euro-Server
mit einer Public-IP-4-4-Adresse
und ich glaube,
1 GB RAM und eine CPU oder sowas.
Aber ich behalte den auch,
weil Public-IP-4-4-Adresse
Allein schon für eine Public-IP
von 4 Adresse bezahlst du ja woanders mehr.
So, zack.
Machen wir hier mal dicht.
Also, ich glaube, man kann so zusammenfassend
sagen, Hetzner ist
nicht mehr ganz extrem
vorne im günstigen Server-Game,
ist aber immer noch,
hat er immer noch gute Preise.
Und ich glaube, das Ökosystem, was sich Hetzner mittlerweile aufgebaut hat, ist echt nicht ohne.
Das war im DZX.
Davon habe ich keine Ahnung. Das war aber im DZX. Auf der Hanauer Landstraße war das.
Es könnte auch wirklich sein, dass es so konfiguriert war.
Dass es nicht wirklich ins andere Rack ging, sondern irgendwie, keine Ahnung mehr.
ich würde gerne mal wieder in D6,
aber nachdem ich nicht mehr beim Provider arbeite,
kommt man da schlecht rein,
beziehungsweise kam man damals auch schon schlecht rein.
Das war damals ein Riesenakt,
dass du da überhaupt rein durftest.
Du musstest irgendwie um drei Ecken angemeldet werden,
musst dich ausweisen,
du wurdest gewogen beim Reingehen.
Du kamst in so eine Schleuse rein,
wurdest du gewogen
und beim Rausgehen wurdest du wieder gewogen,
dass du da nicht irgendwie Sprengstoff oder so drin abgelassen hast.
50 Kilo oder so.
Sonst ging das nicht.
Was ich mich immer damals gefragt habe ist,
was ist, wenn du mal aufs Klo musstest und ordentlich gekackt hast?
Aber ich habe innen drin auch gar kein Klo gesehen.
Ich glaube, die haben innen drin noch nicht mal ein Klo.
Na, du musstest auch genau anmelden, was du vorhast und dann musstest du, wo das ist und, ja, ja, also das war tatsächlich ein größerer Akt.
Damals, dass man da rein durfte.
Interaction
Interaction ist der Betreiber vom D6
Achso, meinst du das?
Jetzt hab ich's verstanden
Offiziell wird das D-Kicks ausgesprochen
Echt?
Ich habe damals von Leuten, von denen ich dachte, dass sie wissen, wovon sie sprechen, D-Zix gehört und seitdem sage ich D-Zix.
Vielleicht hat der D-Zix sich auch damals noch D-Zix ausgesprochen, weil es gab ja auch Zeiten, da hat sich Amazon Amazon ausgesprochen.
Ja, man spricht es ja auch noch was anderes.
man spricht man spricht ja auch man spricht ja auch nicht knippex aus
jeder den ich kenne sagt knippex aber die spricht man knie packs aus habe ich
ganz selten gehört nur
Es gibt viele Sachen, die man ganz anders ausspricht.
Und bei Kubernetes habe ich noch keine Aussprache gehört, auf das sich alle einigen konnten.
Am einen ist es Kubernetes, am anderen ist es Kubernetes, am anderen ist es Kubernetes und sonst was.
BTFS ist auch so ein Ding.
BTFS, BetaFS, ButterFS, alles mögliche schon gehört.
Du hast Kneipex dazu gesagt.
Ja, das habe ich noch nicht gehört.
Genauso Leute, Sisko.
Kisko, Sisko, Schisko.
Schisko habe ich tatsächlich auch schon gehört.
Schisko.
Wobei ich ja Zytrix immer...
Schytrix ausspreche.
Ich weiß, dass es nicht so heißt, aber...
Zytrix ist halt ziemlich Schytrix.
schluss ja ich hab schon heute gesagt schluss und die müssen es wissen wir hatten wir hatten
bei uns auf der arbeit im storage für die die für storage leute bei den storage leuten zuständen
erst für storage zuständig waren dann müsste es eigentlich wissen der hat der hat cisco immer
schitzko ausgesprochen
schittrix heißt eine reihe an cv ja gut gute namensbezeichnung
er sind ein bisschen seit seit trackt gewesen ja leute ich habe keine ahnung
monka ist alle ich weiß nicht irgendwie gibt es keine spannenden videos was hat
denn was hat denn gut informatik heute zu uns zu sagen okay was hat denn gut
informatik zu uns zu sagen bei zehn wurde edward snowden zum staatsfeind weil
er enthüllt hat ja der hat auch nicht damit gerechnet wie vergesslich die
leute sind bzw wie planlos die leute sind und wie dumm die leute sind
der hat halt gedacht er tut der menschheit noch einen gefallen und die
menschheit hat gesagt ja scheiß drauf
Heute juckt das kein mehr. Heute können die alle sonst was machen mit den Daten. Die können Sachen leaken und verlieren. Verlieren ist das falsche Wort. Das juckt heute kaum noch jemand. In zwei Tagen ist das vergessen.
Wie gesagt, vor zwei Wochen hat Revolut, das ist eine litauische Bank, hat Revolut umfänglichste Kundendaten verloren, inklusive Ausweiskopien und sowas.
... dass die NSA massenhaft Daten von Millionen Menschen sammelt, ohne Wissen, ohne ein...
... Berlin-Kasse knicken.
... Willigung und ohne Grundlage.
Die Welt war empört mit Parlamentsdebatten, Titelseiten und Sonderausschüssen.
Und dann haben wir kollektiv die Schultern gezuckt und weitergemacht.
Heute, mehr als zehn Jahre später, läuft exakt dasselbe Spiel, nur ohne den Skandal.
Palantir, gegründet mit CIA-Kapital, analysiert Massendaten für Geheimdienste, Militär- und Strafverfolgungsbehörden in dutzenden Ländern.
Ihr Geschäftsmodell ist buchstäblich Muster in Menschen finden, bevor die Menschen selbst wissen, dass sie ein Muster sind.
Und das ist kein Einzelfall.
Nehmen wir zum Beispiel Haushaltsroboter, die du kaufst, damit sie dein Zuhause saugen, die aber gleichzeitig deine Wohnung kartografieren.
Und Fitness-Tracker, die deine Gesundheitsdaten an Versicherungen verkaufen.
Oder Meta, die seit Jahren Profile von ihren Nutzern erstellen, die präziser sind als das, was deine engsten Freunde über dich wissen.
Und den Zugang dazu an jeden Verkaufen, der zahlt.
Das ist das Geschäftsmodell.
Und das Gefährlichste daran ist nicht die Technologie selbst.
Das Gefährlichste ist...
Es juckt keine Sau.
Dass wir verlernt haben, die einfachste aller Fragen zu stellen.
Aber das Ding ist halt auch, viele Leute, die damit aufgewachsen sind, für die ist das komplett selbstverständlich.
Deswegen bin ich ja auch der Meinung, muss ich an der Stelle nochmal sagen, dass diese ganze Diskussion um Social Media Beschränkungen, Verbote und so, komplett der Schwachsinn ist.
Also ich verstehe, wo die herkommen, ja, also warum das angestrebt wird, das kann ich schon nachvollziehen.
Da geht es ja keinem irgendwie in der Politik darum, die Kinder vor Social Media oder sowas zu schützen.
Wenn es darum gehen würde, die Kinder zu schützen, sollen die sich um irgendwelche Pedos auf Ruckblocks kümmern.
Null. Das ist einfach nur vorgeschoben, weil es ein Thema ist, wo du quasi jegliche Kritik ersticken kannst,
weil du immer fragen kannst, ja bist du denn nicht für den Schutz der Kinder?
Und da wird natürlich jeder, der noch halbwegs bei Verstand ist, sagen, ja doch, natürlich bin ich das.
Ja, so. Aber das geht dir null um den Schutz der Kinder, wenn es irgendwie um Social Media Verbot oder andere Geschichten geht. Da geht es letztendlich darum, ums... Ich muss das in zwei Punkte splitten. Einmal um massenhafte Überwachung und um Kontrolle der Informationen.
Ja, also sprich, wer kann sich denn noch unliebsam über irgendwelche Politiker äußern, wer kann denn noch unliebsame Sachen im Internet rausposaunen, muss der denn vielleicht Angst haben, dass demnächst die Polizei bei ihm vor der Tür steht, weil er ein Schwarzkopfbild gepostet hat oder sowas in der Richtung.
Also gerade was das jetzt hier eingeführt wird, von wegen Chatkontrolle und demnächst Social Media Verbot, da geht es darum, dass man erstmal eine Plattform schafft, eine Plattform unter anderem zur Altersverifikation und sobald du eine Plattform, also wegen Social Media musst du, sobald du aber eine Plattform hast für Altersverifikation, hast du ja schon mal eine Plattform geschaffen, die du für ganz viele andere Sachen auch benutzen kannst und die wird dafür benutzt.
Sobald Daten da sind, werden die benutzt. Das hat man an ganz vielen Stellen gesehen. Ich sage nochmal zu Zeiten, nur mal ein praktisches Beispiel. Zu Zeiten, wo es darum ging, während Corona, wo es darum ging, dass Restaurants so Listen hatten, wer wie wo wann gegessen hat, dass man Infektionsketten besser nachvollziehen kann.
eigentlich eine sinnvolle Geschichte,
ja, konnte man ja so
bei der direkten Sache sagen, es klingt doch sinnvoll.
Ja, im Nachhinein hat natürlich die Polizei
gesagt, ah, auf diese Daten wollen wir auch
für Verfolgung von XY Zugriff
haben. Also, sobald es das gibt,
wird das gemacht und es werden gerade an allen
Stellen Infrastruktur und
Stellen geschaffen, um mehr
Überwachung zu ermöglichen
und um mehr Kontrolle
auszuüben.
Das fängt an mit solche
Sachen wie Altersverifikation geht dann
weiter mit, ja, du brauchst das
jetzt natürlich, die offizielle App, dass du dich irgendwo
anders noch anmelden kannst, weil sobald es
ein Alterslimit gibt, braucht es
eine Stelle zur Altersverifikation. Wenn es eine Stelle
zur Altersverifikation gibt, musst
du da auch irgendwelche Daten eintragen,
weil du die offizielle App benutzen musst.
Dann geht es weiter mit
Verschlüsselung aufbrechen,
VPNs aufbrechen,
mit On-Client
scannen nach Daten.
Das fängt wieder an, dann alles mit
Oh, wir wollen die Kinder schützen, als nächstes kommt
Oh, wir wollen euch vor Terroristen schützen
Oh, wir wollen euch vor Kriminellen schützen
Vor Schwerstkriminellen schützen, oh, wir wollen Morde aufklären
Oh, wir wollen das, das, das
Und am Ende kommt dann
Oh, du hast eine Urheberrechtsverletzung begangen
Oh, wir haben es gemerkt, weil wir dein Handy gescannt haben
So, also das wird immer weiter Salami-Taktik
Mäßig aufgeweicht
Ja, und am Ende
Am Ende
Ich sag's ja oft, ja
Aber das glaube ich in vielen Bereichen, dass wir gar nicht so weit von China weg sind, wie wir uns das immer selbst einreden. Wir sind vielleicht jetzt noch weg, aber die Gleise sind eindeutig in diese Richtung gestellt.
Und es wird definitiv, das sage ich euch jetzt schon, so sicher wie das Arme in der Kirche, es wird großöffentlichkeitswirksame False Positives geben, vielleicht auch weniger öffentlich wirksame False Positives, aber es wird definitiv False Positives geben.
Wenn das so weit kommt, dass Geräte gescannt werden, dann kann es durchaus sein, dass bei der Oma, die ihre Enkel am Meer gefilmt hat mit dem Handy, die Polizei wegen Kinderpornos vor der Tür steht.
Das wird früher oder später, die Frage ist nicht, ob das passieren wird, die Frage ist, wann das passieren wird, weil das Ganze wird natürlich auch zunehmend automatisiert ausgewertet von Stellen, die total überlastet sind, die das einfach nur noch durchwinken.
hat man ja gesehen mit Hausdurchsuchungen,
die es teilweise schon gab, wegen
banalsten
Sachen auf Twitter,
Hausdurchsuchungen, die einfach von irgendwelchen
Richtern durchgewunken werden,
die das teilweise auch noch gut gefunden haben,
dass das eine quasi Bestrafung ist
und das sind halt so Dinge,
also die Entwicklung ist für mich
klar zu erkennen in die Richtung, die es geht.
So,
kleiner Rant so im Großen und Ganzen.
...zustellen, nämlich, wem nützt das wirklich?
Weil wir so begeistert vom Was-Kann-Das-Sind,
dass wir das Wozu-wird-das-genutzt gar nicht mehr denken.
Ich bin der Letzte, den man einen Technikfeind nennen würde.
Ich liebe das, was Technologie ermöglicht hat.
Aber zwischen blindem Enthusiasmus und Paranoia
liegt ein Raum, den wir dringend wieder besetzen müssen.
Der Raum des kritischen Hinterfragens.
Das nächste Mal, wenn eine App zu gut klingt, um wahr zu sein,
frag dich nicht nur, wie...
Severance hab ich auch geguckt.
Muss ich ehrlich sagen, ich spoiler nicht.
Muss ich sagen, ich werd mir die dritte Staffel nicht mehr angucken.
Letztendlich, die erste Staffel war noch cool
Ist da kaum schon was passiert
In der zweiten Staffel ist auch kaum was passiert
Dann hab ich mir so, okay
Ich glaub, denen sind nach der ersten Staffel die Ideen ausgegangen
Werde ich nicht mehr weiter gucken
Keine Ahnung, ob es da mittlerweile eine dritte Staffel gibt
Werde ich mir nicht mehr angucken
Die Band war geil
Du meinst die Musik nochmal in dem Finale der zweiten Staffel?
Naja.
Ich weiß nicht.
Es war irgendwie ein bisschen over the top so.
Aber hatte schon was.
Gebrauchte CPU gekauft.
Plötzlich ist der PC gesperrt.
Das habe ich gelesen, ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es um diesen Fall hier geht.
Das habe ich gelesen auf Reddit.
Da hat sich einer eine gebrauchte CPU gekauft und hat Valorant gestartet.
Und auf einmal war er gebannt in Valorant.
Und hat dann an den Support geschrieben.
Und das Support hat gesagt, wir können Ihnen nicht helfen, die CPU ist gebannt.
Aber, jetzt kommt der Witz, aber weil wir schon mal dabei sind,
dadurch, dass du mit einer gebannten
CPU dich eingeloggt hast,
haben wir alle deine anderen
Hardware auch gebannt.
Das heißt,
wenn er sich jetzt einen neuen Rechner kauft
und seine SSD einbaut,
wird er wieder gebannt.
Wisst ihr, was ich mir an der Stelle gedacht habe?
Man könnte doch mal einen Versuch starten.
Man lässt sich bannen
in Valorant
auf dem Rechner und dann
verkauft man die SSD, also günstig,
besonders günstig ja dann verkauft man die ssd weiter dann verkauft man die ziel
dann verkauft alle teile günstig weiter das müsste ich ja wie den virus
verbreiten auf einmal ist auf einmal so halb deutschland gebannt weil jeder
jeder der das einbaut band ja wieder seine hardware
Das ist das.
Jung studiert Arbeitslos.
So schwer ist der Job-Einstieg für junge Menschen mit KI.
Generell ist der Job-Einstieg aktuell schwierig.
Also gerade auch im IT-Sektor.
Ich bin da mal gespannt drauf.
Wenn das immer weiter zunimmt.
Man sieht das ja auch schon.
Es gibt ja mittlerweile ganze Services und Anwendungen,
wo sich irgendeiner hingesetzt hat,
der keine Ahnung von der Technik hat,
aber halt irgendeine Vision,
irgendein Manager-Dude sich hingesetzt hat
und was mit Cloud Code erstellt hat.
Das ist ja immer wunderbar,
so als Proof of Concept, als Demo-Anwendung.
Aber ich bin mal gespannt,
wie gut diese Anwendungen erwartbar und erweiterbar bleiben
über die Jahre hinweg.
Weil wir reden ja hier nicht von, wurde ein Entwickler, erstellt das und benutzt KI zur Unterstützung dabei und setzt der KI passenden Richtlinien und alles drumherum, hat sich über die Architektur im Vorfeld Gedanken gemacht, guckt sich das an, was da kommt.
Wir reden ja hier von Leuten, die keine Ahnung haben, aber eine Idee haben. So eine First Demo auszukotzen in ein, zwei Tagen mit Cloud Code ist kein Ding. Aber das dann als ordentlicher Service zu verkaufen, dass das auch wirklich alles durchdacht ist, sicher ist, dass das wartbar ist, erweiterbar ist, patchbar ist. Ich glaube, da wird sich noch viel, ein Riesenhaufen an Legacy rausstellen, der nicht gut handelbar ist.
wo man natürlich sagen kann, KI könnte einem ja wieder helfen, diese Legacy besser zu handeln, aber warten wir mal ab.
Also ich sehe noch ganz lange Zeit hin, bis KI wirklich selbstständig Softwareprojekte inklusive Architektur und allem aufzieht,
ohne große technische, menschliche Guidance.
Da sehe ich da wirklich noch viel Verbesserungspotenzial.
potenzial und wir das mit lms überhaupt sehen werden keine ahnung und was auch witzig wird
was auch noch witzig wird trainiert ja viel aus viel aus daten die da sind ich bin mal gespannt
wann es so diminishing returns oder wie man das nennt gibt also sprich wenn ki zum größten teil
mit KI-Daten trainiert wird.
Ich meine, viele Prompts werden ja heutzutage
mit einer KI benutzt,
um Prompts zu erstellen.
Und dementsprechend frage ich mich,
wie ist es denn bei den Trainingsdaten?
Also sprich,
wie viele Daten,
also wie viele Trainingsdaten
sind schon KI-Daten?
Weil muss ich das mal angucken.
Stack Overflow ist gestorben durch KI.
Nicht nur durch KI.
Hatten lange Zeit auch Probleme.
Aber Stack Overflow ist mitgestorben durch KI.
Stack Overflow ist bei 2% oder so ihres sonstigen Volumens. Also Stack Overflow ist dead. Aber wie ist das denn jetzt, wenn KI nur noch von KI lernt?
und
ich finde, ein bisschen sieht man es auch schon daran,
dass ganz viele KI-Läden
Bücher aufkaufen.
Die kaufen antike, oder aus Antiquarien,
ich muss nicht antike Bücher, aus Antiquarianen
und anderen Quellen,
kaufen die Bücher,
um sie dann einzuscannen,
um ihre KI zu trainieren,
danach werden die Bücher übrigens entsorgt,
weggeschmissen, oder ob es ein Schade ist,
damit sie weiterhin menschlichen
Content reinbekommen.
Du bist ein guter Mann.
So, dann gucken wir mal.
Mal gucken, ob er über diesen Fall von Valorant erzählt.
Stellt euch vor, ihr kauft einen gebrauchten Prozessor.
Technisch ist er völlig in Ordnung.
Keine Defekte, der PC läuft einwandfrei.
Und trotzdem hat diese CPU ein Problem,
das man ihr nicht ansehen kann.
Sie steht auf einer schwarzen Liste.
Genau das ist einem Käufer eines gebrauchten AMD-Prozessors.
Ja, sag ich doch.
Okay, ich habe es euch im Endeffekt schon erzählt.
Der Vorbesitzer hatte offenbar in einem Computerspiel gecheatet.
Und deshalb war nicht nur dessen Account gesperrt worden, sondern seine Hardware.
Und seine gesamte Hardware wohlgemerkt.
Nicht nur die CPU, alles was er zusätzlich drin hat, auch noch.
Der Vorbesitzer wusste davon nichts.
Und als er die gebrauchte CPU in seinen eigenen Rechner einbaute,
sollen sogar weitere Komponenten seines PCs auf der Blacklist gelandet sein.
Nee, nee, nee, chat, chat, chat, chat, chat, chat, chat.
Moin, sag ich, ist lange nicht gesehen.
Chat, KI und AI ist ja prinzipiell out. Wir sind jetzt ja mittlerweile bei Agentic Engineering. Ja, es gibt eine Hardware-ID bei CPUs. Das gibt's, ja.
wie genau man die auslässt, weiß ich nicht, aber wahrscheinlich mit irgendeinem
Assemblerbefehl, da gibt es wahrscheinlich irgendeinen Opcode für,
der das aus, das dann irgendein Register schreibt oder so, keine Ahnung,
da gibt es auch garantiert irgendwelche C-Libraries für, um das, also
CPU-Info oder so kann das bestimmt auch, ja, ja, es gibt eine Serie,
CPU auslesen, das geht, und viele Hardware hat das, ja, also
NVMe-SSDs haben
eine Seriennummer.
Bei einer Grafikkarte,
ehrlich gesagt, weiß ich das nicht.
Ich würde
aber darauf tippen, dass Grafikkarten
sowas auch haben.
So Peripherie und sowas
eventuell
auch.
Mäuse, Tastaturen und sowas.
Seriennummern, USB-Geräte
wahrscheinlich auch, oder ziemlich sicher auch.
Ich glaube RAM nicht.
RAM würde ich mal vermuten
hat sowas nicht. Aber nicht sicher,
ehrlich gesagt. Vielleicht hat RAM sowas auch.
Frunummer!
Beste, Alter!
Kennt das noch jemand von euch?
Die Frunummer.
Ja, das war bei IBM früher.
Die Nummer für Hardware-Teile.
Und wenn du bei IBM früher angerufen hast,
haben die dich immer gefragt, welche Frunummer
hat denn diese Komponente?
Und damals muss ich sagen, Leute, ich kann es euch nicht sagen, das Netzteil ist eingebaut, ich kann da nicht drauf gucken, dann geht der Server aus.
Aber letztendlich waren wir zu dumm damals.
Also, es gibt doch dieses Meme.
Dieses Jedi-Meme.
Mit dem Graf drin.
Das da.
Also ich meine jetzt nicht, dass was drauf ist, ich meine nur dieses Bild.
Nur dieses Bild, ja?
So.
Also früher war das bei mir so
Also mir geht es jetzt nicht um den Text
Um den Text der da drauf steht
Sondern einfach nur um dieses Bild an sich
Also früher war ich so
Alter IBM
Wie soll ich euch die Frunummer sagen
Ich kann ja den Server nicht aufmachen
Ihr seid ja so dumm
So
Dann kam als nächstes
Dann habe ich über IBM rumgeraged
IBM warum seid ihr so dumm
Warum muss ich meinen Server ausschalten
Mittlerweile bin ich auf dem Stand hier und sage, wir waren dran schuld, dass wir denen die Nummer nicht sagen könnten.
Wir wären eigentlich dafür verantwortlich gewesen, eine Liste zu pflegen mit Hardware-Nummern, die wir in unseren Servern haben.
Man kann das Ding noch, bevor man es einbaut, aufschreiben, was man da besitzt.
Ja, also so wäre es eigentlich richtig gewesen. IBM hat recht gehabt.
uns nach der Frunummer zu fragen.
Aber wie gesagt, das war noch in Zeiten...
Also, ich sage ja immer,
ich habe bei einem Internetprovider gearbeitet.
Ich habe nicht bei einem großen Internetprovider gearbeitet.
Das hört sich immer so wichtiger an, als es eigentlich ist.
Also ich habe weder bei Vodafone noch bei der Telekom
noch bei 1&1 oder irgendwie so gearbeitet.
Das war ein relativ kleiner Internetprovider,
aber es war ein Internetprovider.
Er war aber auch nicht groß.
Das war aber eine ziemliche Frickelbude.
Dementsprechend sowas wie Inventarisierung und so.
Kannste knicken.
Nur mal, dass ihr euch das vorstellen konntet, was das für ein Laden war.
Der Laden hatte 200 Mitarbeiter.
Und ratet mal, ich glaube ihr wisst es, weil ich es schon 500 Mal erzählt habe.
Ratet mal, wie viele Azubis von den 200 Leuten.
200 Mitarbeiter, wie viele davon Azubis?
Ungefähr.
50.
Korrekt.
Ihr wisst das, ich habe das schon, Recycle Story, ich habe das schon 500 Mal erzählt. 50 Azubis von 200 Mitarbeitern. Also ein Viertel. Viertel war Azubis. Und so eine Frickelbude war das auch. Und letztendlich hatten die viele Azubis, weil es billiger war.
Du konntest einen Azubi ins Auto setzen, dem einen Server in den Kofferraum legen, der ist dann von Frankfurt nach München gefahren, hat dort den Server ausgepackt, eingebaut, angeschlossen, gecheckt, dass alles läuft. Das war einfach viel billiger.
Gibt's die Bude noch? Ne, die wurden mittlerweile aufgekauft, die gibt's nicht mehr.
Ich glaube sogar, dass die mittlerweile zur Telekom gehören.
Ich glaube, die haben mal eine Weile Virtual-Machine-Plattforms-Zeug für die Telekom betrieben, nachdem sie aufgekauft wurden. Ich glaube, von der Telekom sogar. Ich glaube sogar, dass die mittlerweile zur Telekom gehören.
naja und dementsprechend gab es da auch keine ausbildung in dem sinn du konntest entweder
wahnsinnig viel lernen weil du alles mitmachen konntest oder du konntest drei jahre zweieinhalb
jahre chillen und hast nichts gelernt das hat genauso wenig weiner hat es interessiert keine
Ich habe mitgemacht und habe quasi so alle meine Linux Basics
In der Ausbildung erworben
Damals, weil du konntest einfach mitmachen
Wenn du wolltest, ja
Du hattest als Azubi Hutrechte auf allem
Du konntest als Azubi alles machen
Was jeder normale
Mitarbeiter auch machen kann
Und du konntest mitmachen, du konntest aber auch abchillen
Es gab keine Ausbildung in dem Sinn
Für mich hat es sich insofern gelohnt, ich konnte mir halt wirklich Linux, also ich nenne es jetzt mal From Scratch, ich meine nicht Linux From Scratch, aber so von Grund auf lernen.
Und was wir da für Frickelsachen gemacht haben, meine Güte ey, da würdest du heute eine Abmahnung für kriegen wahrscheinlich, damals war das normal.
Wir hatten damals, ich kann mich noch dran erinnern, wir hatten damals das Problem, wir hatten einen Standort in Frankfurt und einen Standort, ich sage mal in, keine Ahnung, Stuttgart.
und wir mussten Dateien kopieren
von einem Standort zum anderen.
So, und die Firewall-Regeln
dazwischen waren irgendwie
verbuggt oder so. Es ging nicht.
Es ging nicht. So, und was wir dann gemacht haben,
ist mit unseren Admin-Rechten,
wir haben SSH-Tunnel gebaut.
SSH-Tunnel von unserem PC
auf eine Kiste im Rechenzentrum.
Von der Kiste im Rechenzentrum auf eine Firewall.
Wir durften uns auf eine Firewall einloggen,
als Azubi.
Von der Firewall
einen Tunnel
über die zwei Tunnels.
Von diesem Tunnel auf die nächste Firewall.
Wir sind über irgendwie, keine Ahnung,
elf Zwischenhops mit SSH-Tunnel gegangen,
um Sachen zu übertragen,
was eigentlich nicht erlaubt war,
aber wo irgendeiner gesagt hat,
oh ja, das müssen wir jetzt machen,
denkt euch mal aus, wie das geht.
Heute, bei meinem jetzigen Arbeitgeber,
würde ich sagen, hallo Leute,
das hat schon seinen Sinn,
dass das nicht erlaubt ist.
Wenn ihr das wollt,
offiziell per Ticket beantragen.
Hat uns damals
nicht interessiert. Wir haben damals einen halben Tag
gefrickelt mit 15 SSH-Tunneln,
bis es funktioniert hat.
Ich meine, man sieht schon daran.
Guck mal.
Wie gesagt, das will ich euch jetzt nicht erzählen,
aber das brauche ich als Einstieg.
Als ich meine Abschlussprüfung hatte,
da hat mich morgens die IHK
angerufen und hat gesagt,
Herr Max, Sie sind durchgefallen.
Da habe ich übrigens mal sogar
ein eigenes Video zugemacht.
Also, wen die eigentliche Story interessiert,
kann sich das Video angucken.
Ja, habe ich ein Video zugemacht.
Zumindest hat die IHK bei mir angerufen
und gesagt, sie sind durchgefallen.
Und ich habe gesagt, wie jetzt?
Das kann doch überhaupt nicht sein, dass ich durchgefallen bin.
Ich hatte doch meine Abschlussprüfung noch gar nicht.
So, und das Problem war,
dass ich meine Abschlussdokumentation
hochgeladen hatte und das Server
von der IHK ist abgekackt.
Irgendwie eine halbe Minute,
nachdem ich meine Abschlussdokumentation
hochgeladen habe, meine Projektdokumentation
hochgeladen habe.
Und die hatten das nicht mehr und die haben mich durchfallen lassen,
weil ich nicht rechtzeitig meine Dokumentation eingereicht habe.
So, und dann habe ich zu der
Frau von der IHK gesagt, doch, ich habe doch
sogar noch die Bestätigungs-E-Mail für euch.
So, und jetzt kommt das Abenteuerliche, was ich
euch erzählen wollte. Ich war an dem Tag daheim,
weil ich mittags Prüfung hatte, bin ich auf die Arbeit gegangen.
So, und
Da habe ich einen Kollegen auf der Arbeit angerufen.
Und was wir dann gemacht haben ist...
Also das ist wirklich voll durch die Brust ins Auge.
Der hat sich verbunden...
Von seiner Workstation...
Auf eine Kiste im Rechenzentrum im Keller.
Von der Kiste...
Rechenzentrumskiste im Keller...
Hat er sich per SSH verbunden...
Auf eine Kiste mit einer Public IP.
Dann hat er mir einen Public Port aufgemacht auf dieser Kiste über einen weiteren SSH-Tunnel,
sodass wenn ich per SSH an diesen Port gegangen bin, eigentlich bei ihm im Firmennetz auf seiner Workstation rausgekommen bin.
Natürlich musste ich das SSH-Passwort wissen, sonst hätte das nicht funktioniert.
So, und darüber habe ich dann noch einen weiteren SSH-Tunnel aufgebaut, auf meine Workstation, die glücklicherweise an war.
Und darüber habe ich Lotus Notes forwarded mit X-Forwarding.
Damit ich die E-Mail auf... ihr könnt euch vorstellen, wie schnell das gewesen ist, ja.
Darüber konnte ich dann die E-Mail raussuchen für die IHK und an die Frau von der IHK schicken.
Alter, Leute.
Was für abadische Aktionen, Mann.
Aber immerhin, Lotus Notes
ging per X-Forwarding.
Ja.
Sowas Geiles wie X-Forwarding gibt es ja
unter Wayland nicht mehr.
Wayland hat dieses
Zeug vollkommen aus dem Blick verloren.
Die fangen jetzt erst an
RDP und so Sachen
zu implementieren für KDE
und Gnome und so. Und das hat immer noch nicht alle Features.
Und für alle Leute,
die es nicht kennen
und die es hoffentlich auch nie
kennenlernen werden, weil
neu eingeführt wird das nirgendswo nicht.
Ich zeige euch mal ein Bild.
Ja.
Ja, so.
So ungefähr sah das aus.
So, hier, das ist es.
Das ist es.
Lotus Notes, Leute.
Ja, das war schon die bisschen neuere Version.
Das war schon die bisschen neuere Version.
E-Mail-Ansicht.
Es gibt Waypipe.
Waypipe geht aber nicht unter Gnome und KDE.
Und die RDP-Implementierung von KDE kannst du vergessen.
Die ist nicht Headless.
Und die Gnome-Implementierung kann vieles nicht.
Wie zum Beispiel Laufwerke.
Jaja
Also hier, wer
Chat, Frage an euch
Wer von euch hatte mal die Ehre
Lotus Notes live zu sehen
Es muss doch nicht mal benutzt worden sein
Wer hat es mal live noch im Einsatz gesehen
Einer
Okay, tatsächlich
Tatsächlich
Ey, mehr als ich gedacht hab
Sag mal ihr, dann seid ihr auch alles so alte Säcke wie ich, oder
Wenn ihr das noch gesehen habt
ich bin jetzt 42
ja Outlook ist auch
also ganz ehrlich Outlook ist auch mega
Crap
also die die es gibt es gibt ja zwei
Möglichkeiten Outlook zu verwenden es gibt diese hässliche
Desktop Anwendung die laggy
as fuck ist ich glaube ich habe noch
nie eine so unperformante Anwendung
gesehen wie Outlook auf dem Desktop
und dann gibt es Outlook
im Browser das ist viel viel schneller
und für E-Mail lesen ziemlich gut
Aber das kann halt vieles nicht, was Outlook auf dem Desktop kann, wenn man es braucht.
Ja, wenn irgendwelche Firmen Custom-Plugins haben und sowas.
Ich bin 42 mittlerweile, ja.
Naja, klar. Ich habe auf YouTube mit ein paar 20 angefangen.
Das ist jetzt auch schon 15 Jahre oder so, ja.
Wann habe ich denn auf YouTube angefangen? 2010? 16 Jahre?
Das neue Outlook habe ich noch nie gesehen.
Aber ich glaube, viele Firmen werden nie auf das neue Outlook umsteigen können,
weil die halt irgendwelche komischen Plugins und Gedöns haben.
ja lotus nots aus meine güte das war ein ding sagt solch monka w solange ich verwende diese
linux vm so oft da kann ich jetzt gar nicht mehr hier meine meine emotes einspielen
machen wir das mal zu gibt es eigentlich noch wo wir gerade dabei sind gibt es eigentlich
noch tracks tool.de excellent die seite sieht aus wie aus 2000 enter history outlook outlook
ist auf dem ersten Platz. Das hat's auch verdient.
Aber gut, die Seite wird
halt krass gebottet, ne?
Outlook ist auf dem ersten
Platz, Teams auf dem zweiten Platz. Okay.
Zutrix Resiver.
Ja, nur vom Feinsten.
Was ist Siemens Expedition?
Das kenne ich nicht. Das ist bestimmt
auch grausames
Zeug, oder?
Ah, das ist für PCBs
und sowas.
Ich war dein erstes Abo auf
YouTube. Excellent.
So muss das sein.
Das finde ich sehr nice.
Wir müssen unbedingt
ein neues Video aufnehmen im Stream, Leute, weil
ansonsten drücke ich mich immer davor.
Und wenn ich das nicht
im Stream mache, dann drücke ich mich immer davor.
Ich drücke mich ja im Stream auch davor.
Richtig.
Business Enterprise Software ist das Schlimmste.
Ja, wenn man nicht in diesem Bereich arbeitet, denkt man sich immer nur so,
Alter, ist Windows kacke, Alter, ist das kacke.
Ja gut, bei so richtig teurer Business Enterprise Software ist das bestimmt besser.
Aber nee, nee, ohne Scheiß, Leute.
Je teurer und nischiger die Software ist, umso beschissener ist die in der Regel.
Ich habe ein Beispiel. Beim alten Arbeitgeber waren irgendwelche Sales-Leute da.
Und die haben uns damals, als wir auf der Suche nach einem Knowledge-Base-Wiki-System waren, was verkauft.
Wir haben damals favorisiert, Leute, wie wäre es denn, wenn wir einfach mal anfangen würden?
Und wie wäre es denn, wenn wir einfach mit einem Doku-Wiki starten?
Wie gesagt, wir reden hier von 2015 oder so.
Wie wäre es denn, wenn wir einfach mal anfangen würden?
Lass es, ein Doku-Wiki ist easy, das ist alles Plaintext.
Da kamen andere und haben gesagt, nein, wir wollen aber Confluence.
Weil Confluence und das Atlassian-Ökosystem,
habe ich damals auch gemeint, ist okay, dann meinetwegen Confluence, ist doch egal.
Aber irgendwas, mein Doku-Wiki ist kostenlos, kann jeder bedienen.
Dann haben wir schon was, wo wir ordentlich anfangen können.
So, und dann hatten sie irgendwelche Sales-Leute da,
die ihnen die geilste Knowledge-Base aller Zeiten angepriesen haben.
Leute, das war eines der beschissensten Softwareprodukte, die ich je benutzen musste.
Das Ganze nannte sich Sabio.
Kennt das jemand?
Sabio Knowledge-Base-Management oder so.
Okay, du erkennst schon mal, dass es so eine typische Business-Enterprise-Webseite ist.
du siehst hier Produkte,
ja, aber du findest nix.
Diese Webseiten sind eindeutig
nicht für Technikleute gemacht.
Also du sagst hier Plattform,
du findest halt nix.
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Ich guck mal, ob ich...
Ja. Ja, so ungefähr
sah das aus. Wobei das schon
das neue Interface ist.
So ungefähr sah das aus.
Dieses Sabio-Knowledge-Space.
Man muss dazu sagen, die Knowledge Base war damals so advanced, in Anführungszeichen.
Die hatte kein Webinterface.
Um auf das Wiki zugreifen zu können, das war kein Witz, um auf das Wiki zugreifen zu können, hast du...
Ne, das verwechsel ich gerade.
Wartet mal, das verwechsel ich. Sorry Leute, das verwechsel ich.
Das verwechsel ich, das verwechsel ich.
Das war eine andere scheiß Software, die kann ich euch auch gleich zeigen.
Das hat ein Webinterface gehabt.
Das war aber so ein scheiß Wiki-System, Alter.
Es war ganz...
Man sieht ja auch schon kaum Screenshots,
weil das war halt nicht verbreitet.
Das haben uns irgendwelche
Sales-Leute von denen, unseren
Leuten verkauft, wo halt nicht
ein Techniker dabei war. Das war wirklich absolut
Crap. So, und ich hab noch
ein weiteres Softwareprodukt,
was auch richtiger Crap ist.
Helpline-Ticketsystem. Kennt das jemand?
Wirklich,
Das ist ohne Scheiß, ich weiß nicht, wie es jetzt ist.
Keine Ahnung, wie das jetzt ist.
Aber damals sah das so aus.
Das war ein geiles Bild, Alter.
Das war ohne Scheiß, das war ein Ticketsystem.
Hier ist das Screenshot.
Nee, nee, das ist...
Das war ein Ticketsystem.
Oh, das geht schon im Browser da, Leute.
Das ging, so sah das aus.
Das ging nur in einer WPF, WPF oder Windows Forms, keine Ahnung, aber ich glaube es war eine WPF.
Das war nur benutzbar mit einer WPF Windows Desktop Anwendung.
WTF, warum führt man sowas ein?
Wir reden hier von, keine Ahnung, 2014 oder so, da war ein Webbrowser schon verbreitet, ja.
Das war das beschissenste Ticketsystem, was ich jemals in meinem Leben benutzt habe.
So beschissen, Alter. Das war so schlecht.
Ich musste mich da immer auf Windows-RDPen.
Das war so schlecht.
Und witzigerweise, wenn du was angeklickt hattest, konnte es kein anderer mehr bearbeiten.
Wir hatten da das Problem, Leute haben ein Ticket angeklickt, waren dann im Urlaub und keiner konnte das Ticket sich nehmen und bearbeiten.
Guck mal, das ist Peter Boss.
Der Infotisch.
Wenn ich das schon sehe, Alter.
Das ist halt auch wieder so ein Ding.
Das hat irgendein deutsches Unternehmen wahrscheinlich entwickelt.
Hat irgendwelche Sales-Leute rumgeschickt.
Alle Bekanntschaften abzugrasen.
So aus anderem Business Enterprise Umfeld.
Um es denen dann aufzuschwätzen.
Das war wirklich...
Also diese zwei Sachen.
Sabio und Helpline.
So.
Also damals, ich weiß, ich kann ja nicht für jetzt sprechen, aber damals war das wirklich zwei der beschissensten Softwareprodukte, die ich je verwendet habe.
Meiner Meinung nach.
Grausam.
So, ich muss mich mal kurz ein bisschen abregen.
So.
Exzellent, exzellent.
Danke für den Follow.
Gut, wieder abgeregt.
Sehr gut.
Ex-excellent
Ne, schon eine Weile nicht mehr
Lange nicht mehr gehört
Wobei, ihr wisst mich, wie das bei mir
Das lag sicherlich auch zum größten Teil an mir
Weil mit so zwischenmenschlichen Sachen
Ich hab mich dann einfach nicht mehr gemeldet und so
Hätte ich da mal ein bisschen Kontakt gehalten
Hätten wir wahrscheinlich heute noch ab und zu
Shina All You Can Eat essen oder so
Aber, ja
Max und soziale Interaktion, Alter
Damals gab es ASP.NET
ASP.NET gibt es immer noch
Beziehungsweise
ASP.NET Core
Gibt es ja immer noch
Und ASP.NET Core ist meiner Meinung nach
Also ich rede nicht von dem alten ASP. Das alte ASP war grausam, da hast du recht.
ASP.NET Core ist meiner Meinung nach eines der besten Webframeworks, die es überhaupt gibt.
Du meinst nicht zufällig das Weihnachtsgrill?
Mit den Torx-Schraubendrehern?
Ja.
Ja, da sieht man so, meine soziale Kompetenz ist es nicht so gut bestellen, was das angeht.
Frontpage, ja gut, Frontpage war noch früher, Frontpage ist noch länger her.
Ja, Leute.
Ich meine, das Video müssen wir nicht gucken.
Oh, da kommt...
Okay, ich habe nichts gesagt.
Das hat sogar noch ein bisschen mehr Inhalt.
Oh, danke schön für den Sub.
Ich muss mal gucken.
Ich glaube, es gab heute nicht so viele Subscribers.
aber exzellente subscription aber ich habe wahrscheinlich wieder welche
vergessen der mustang fahrer den habe ich vergessen
dankeschön an die fise bianen sub gesponsert an film der mustang fahrer
huge subs der f programmer auch angekriegt sehr schön danke für die
subs leute wir kommen uns das video doch an weil es hat wohl noch ein bisschen
mehr inhalt was bands und solche sachen angeht hören wir uns das noch mal also
wie gesagt ich habe euch ja das mit valerian schon mit den leuten die
barbara und gebahrt der eine der bäume land gebannt wird schon erzählt aber wir
Gucken wir mal, das andere Video geht dann nur sieben Minuten.
... zunächst nach einer ziemlich kuriosen Geschichte aus der Gaming-Welt.
Aber dahinter steckt ein viel größeres Thema.
Denn immer mehr Geräte besitzen eine digitale Identität.
Smartphones, PCs und sogar einzelne Komponenten können wiedererkannt als vertrauenswürdig eingestuft oder eben gesperrt werden.
Und damit stellt sich eine neue Frage beim Gebrauchtkauf.
Kaufen wir in Zukunft nicht nur die Hardware eines Vorbesitzers, sondern auch deren digitale Vergangenheit?
Der konkrete Fall tauchte endlich...
Ja, ist so. Das ist by the way wahrscheinlich nicht das erste Mal, dass sowas passiert.
Das ist das erste Mal, wo das jetzt so ein bisschen viral seine Kreise gezogen hat, aber das wird schon öfters passiert sein.
Ende September im deutschen Subreddit PC-Baumeister auf.
Ein Nutzer hatte sich einen gebrauchten AMD Ryzen 7 5800X 3D gekauft.
Eine ziemlich beliebte Gaming-CPU für AMDs AM4-Plattform.
Technisch war mit dem Prozessor offenbar alles in Ordnung, bis der Käufer Valorant starten wollte.
Mit seiner vorherigen CPU funktionierte das Spiel einwandfrei. Nach dem Wechsel auf den gebrauchten Ryzen wurde er dagegen direkt rausgeworfen.
Der Support des Entwicklers Riot Games teilte ihm nach seiner Darstellung schließlich den Grund mit. Die Hardware sei bereits im August gesperrt worden. Offenbar hatte der Vorbesitzer damit gecheatet.
Das war eine kurze Zusammenfassung von dem, was ich auch gerade erzählt habe.
Käufer hatte also nicht nur einen gebrauchten Prozessor gekauft, er hatte dessen Vergangenheit mitgekauft. Warum macht ein Spielehersteller so viel?
Aber es ist ja noch schlimmer. Wie gesagt, noch schlimmer.
Jetzt wurden auch alle anderen Hardware-Komponenten in seinem PC blacklisted.
Das heißt, selbst wenn er sich eine neue CPU kauft, kann er nicht spielen.
Und alles, was die alte Hardware verwendet, kann nicht mehr spielen.
Das Grundproblem ist einfach. Würde Riot nur den Account eines Cheaters sperren,
könnte der sich einen neuen Account anlegen und weitermachen.
Deshalb verwendet Riot sogenannte HWID-Bans, also Hardware-ID-Sperren.
Dabei wird nicht nur ein Benutzerkonto gesperrt.
Riot kann auch physische Komponenten des Computers wiedererkennen.
Eine Neuinstallation des Spiels hilft dann nicht.
By the way, das ist wahrscheinlich eines der Gründe, warum wir Kernel-Level-Anti-Cheat brauchen,
weil ich gehe mal davon aus, bei den meisten Komponenten kann man diese Sachen nicht auslesen,
wenn man nicht root ist.
Beziehungsweise vielleicht ohne Kernel-Treiber überhaupt nicht auslesen.
... neues Benutzerkonto auch nicht.
Und auch eine neue Installation von Windows muss eine solche Identität nicht unbedingt
beseitigen.
Der Rechner selbst hat gewissermaßen eine Reputation bekommen.
Und genau das ist der interessante Teil dieser Geschichte.
Denn moderne Computer besitzen immer mehr Mechanismen, mit denen sich nicht nur ein
Benutzer, sondern auch das verwendete Gerät auf seine Vertrauenswürdigkeit überprüfen
lässt.
Eine wichtige Rolle spielt dabei das TPM, das Trusted Platform Module.
Das ist ein besonders geschützter Bereich.
Das ist das Ding, ohne das man Windows 11 nicht mehr installieren kann.
Außer mit Trick 17.
Unter anderem kryptografische Schlüssel verwalten kann.
Aber war es bei War Dogs nicht so, dass welche unrechtmäßig gebannt, dass sehr viele unrechtmäßig gebannt wurden am Anfang?
Bei modernen PCs steckt die TPM-Funktion direkt an der Plattform bzw. wird als Firmware-TPM umgesetzt. Riot beschreibt selbst, dass sich der sogenannte Endorsement-Key eines TPM als Hardware-Identität verwenden lässt. Und Riot nennt sogar ein ziemlich drastisches Beispiel.
Wird ein Firmware-TPM entsprechend gesperrt, kann es für einen Cheater notwendig werden,
die CPU auszutauschen, um dieser Identifikation zu entgehen. Ob genau diese Methode beim anfangs
genannten gebrauchten Ryzen eingesetzt wurde, wissen wir nicht. Riot verrät verständlicherweise
nicht im Detail, wie der komplette Hardware-Fingerabdruck funktioniert,
aber dass Hardware eindeutig genug wiedererkannt werden kann, um sie zu sperren, das ist längst
Realität. Jetzt könnte man sagen, na gut, ich spiele keinen Valorant, ich bin sowieso kein
ein PC-Gamer, was interessiert mich das?
Aber genau hier wird die Geschichte viel größer.
Google hat beispielsweise vor einiger Zeit
eine neue Funktion namens Device Recall
für Android vorgestellt.
Damit können App-Entwickler bestimmte Informationen
mit einem Gerät verknüpfen.
Google nennt als Beispiel ein Smartphone,
das bereits für schweren Missbrauch verwendet wurde.
Oder ein Gerät, mit dem immer wieder
Naja, das Ding ist,
dass sie sehr viel
dran setzen, die Anti-Cheat-Software-Hersteller
zu erkennen, ob sie in einer
vor einem laufen und viele spiele viele viele spiele mit anti cheat starten gar
nicht in der virtualisierten umgebung
ich gehe davon aus es gibt sehr sehr viele tricks und nicht nur den die
plattform namen sehr sehr viele tricks um rauszubekommen ob man native läuft
oder nicht
der neue accounts angelegt werden um schutzmechanismen zu umgehen und das
bemerkenswerte daran, diese Information kann selbst dann wieder abgerufen werden, wenn die App gelöscht
und neu installiert wurde. Sogar ein Reset des Geräts kann sie überstehen. Das Smartphone kann also
gewissermaßen eine Information über seine Vergangenheit behalten. Und Google weist Entwickler
bei dieser Funktion ausdrücklich auf ein Problem hin. Geräte können ihren Besitzer wechseln. Sie
können gebraucht, verkauft oder general überholt werden. Deshalb empfiehlt Google, ältere Informationen
irgendwann nicht mehr zu berücksichtigen.
Denn sonst könnte genau das passieren,
was wir bei dem Gebrauchten in Ryzen sehen.
Das Verhalten von Besitzer A hat Konsequenzen für Besitzer B.
Und plötzlich bekommt die Frage,
wem eine digitale Reputation eigentlich gehört,
eine ganz praktische Bedeutung.
Bei Smartphones kennen wir etwas Ähnliches schon lange.
By the way, wo wir es gerade bei Device Tracking und so haben,
ich habe letztens einen Reddit-Post gelesen,
dass manche User auf Reddit jetzt Gesichtsidentifikation machen sollen.
WTF? Wollen die mich verarschen?
Ich scanne doch nicht mal ein Face für Reddit.
Können mich mal.
Jedes Mobiltelefon besitzt eine IMEI, eine eindeutige Gerätekennung.
Wird ein Smartphone als gestohlen gemeldet, können Mobilfunkanbieter diese Kennung auf eine Sperrliste setzen.
Damit kann das Gerät unabhängig von der eingelegten SIM-Karte vom Netz ausgeschlossen werden.
Auch Apples Aktivierungssperre funktioniert nach einem ähnlichen Grundprinzip.
Ein gestohlenes iPhone soll nicht einfach gelöscht und anschließend von jemand anderem verwendet werden können.
Deshalb warnt Apple beim Gebrauchtkauf ausdrücklich davor, ein Gerät zu übernehmen, das noch mit dem Account des Vorbesitzers verknüpft ist.
Der entscheidende Unterschied, dort gibt es einen vorgesehenen Eigentümerwechsel.
Der Verkäufer kann die Verbindung zu seinem Account entfernen.
Und damit kommen wir zum eigentlichen Problem.
Was passiert, wenn nicht der Eigentümer mit einem Gerät verknüpft ist, sondern die Bewertung?
By the way, da haben wir noch was, was die Hersteller wahrscheinlich gar nicht so schlecht finden.
Also mal aus Herstellersicht betrachtet.
Das ist ja quasi schon ein bisschen den Gebrauchmarkt eingeschränkt.
Und da haben die Hersteller nichts dagegen.
Die Hersteller mögen eh keinen Gebrauchmarkt.
So und wenn du jetzt immer Gefahr läufst, dass du mit deinem Android-Tablet, bei einem gebrauchten Android-Kauf, Tablet oder Smartphone, Probleme bekommst mit beliebigen Services, Apps, was auch immer, dann überlegen sich die Leute natürlich zweimal, kaufen die sich ein gebrauchtes Gerät.
Was wiederum was ist, was eigentlich der Hersteller ziemlich nice findet, weil der Hersteller
neues Gerät verkaufen will.
... seiner Vergangenheit.
Der Ryzen aus unserem Beispiel kann technisch völlig einwandfrei sein.
Benchmarks können funktionieren, Windows kann problemlos laufen, dem Prozessor ist
äußerlich nichts anzusehen.
Und trotzdem kann irgendwo in einer Datenbank stehen, diese Hardware wurde im Zusammenhang
mit Cheating erkannt.
Beim nächsten Besitzer stimmt diese Aussage über die Vergangenheit der Hardware weiterhin,
nur die Person dahinter ist eine völlig andere.
Bevor wir zur Frage kommen, ob man sich davor schützen kann, noch kurz ein Hinweis in eigener Sache.
Wenn euch solche Geschichten interessieren und ihr bei IT...
Also ich denke mal, man kann sich davor schützen, das dürfte aber so ein bisschen ein Wettrennen sein.
Also es gibt bestimmt Sachen, wo man das blocken kann oder spoofen kann, aber das wird dann nach einer Zeit selbst wiederum als Cheat erkannt.
Und ich glaube, dass man sich nicht wirklich sinnvoll davor schützen kann, wenn man dann diese Spiele spielen möchte oder diese Sachen konsumieren will.
T und Technik-Themen. Gerne noch etwas tiefer einsteigt. Schaut euch Heise Plus an. Dort findet ihr ausführliche Hintergrundberichte.
Hey, Heise Plus. Hört mal bloß auf Heise Plus. Ich habe einmal Heise Plus abgeschlossen, weil ich einen Artikel lesen wollte, der nur auf Plus verfügbar war.
dann stand in dem Artikel, der auf Plus verfügbar ist, nicht wirklich sinnvoll mehr Neues drin.
Und dann wollte ich kündigen und das haben sie irgendwie nicht auf die Reihe gekriegt.
Das hat dann ewig gedauert.
Also das war, ne, im Leben schließe ich keine Heise Plus mehr ab.
...Ratgeber und Analysen und außerdem digitalen Zugriff auf die Magazine aus dem Heise-Kosmos.
Und nicht zuletzt unterstützen Abonnenten natürlich auch, dass wir für euch diese Videos hier produzieren können.
Ich bin aber CT-Abonnent. Ich habe die CT schon seit 20 Jahren, länger. 25 Jahren, 26 Jahren, keine Ahnung. 25 Jahre, sage ich jetzt einfach mal, abonniert.
Ich bekomme die immer noch regelmäßig als Heft. Ich lege die dann aufs Klo und gucke ab und zu mal rein. Aber ich lese eigentlich so gut wie nichts mehr. Aber ich habe sie trotzdem noch weiter abonniert.
Der Heise Plus für 12 Wochen mit 50% Rabatt. Alle Infos findet ihr unter heiseplus.de.
Ja, Heise hat mein Factory gekauft.
Angebot.
Kommen wir zur Frage, wie prüft man beim Gebrauchtkauf, ob Hardware vorbelastet ist?
Bei einem gebrauchten Smartphone kann man zumindest einiges kontrollieren.
Man kann bei einem iPhone beispielsweise prüfen, ob Apples Aktivierungssperre entfernt wurde.
Bei einer gebrauchten PC-Komponente ist das erheblich schwieriger.
Riot bietet keine öffentliche Datenbank an, in der Käufer überprüfen könnten, ob ein Prozessor gesperrt ist.
Und einfach den eigenen Account zum Testen zu verwenden, ist ebenfalls keine besonders gute Idee, denn dann...
Übrigens, Riot könnte eine Public-Datenbank anbieten, ohne die CPU-IDs zu leaken.
Man könnte beispielsweise die gehashte CPU-ID da hinschicken.
Oder aber, vielleicht noch witziger, machen wie das die Have-I-Been-Pwned-Datenbank schickt, nur den Anfang des Hashes hinschicken und man bekommt dann alle anderen Hashes zurück und kann die selbst vergleichen. So ist es komplett anonym. Da musst du noch nicht mal einen Hash deiner CPU-ID da hinschicken. Also wenn die wollten, könnten die das ohne Probleme, aber die wollen natürlich nicht.
kann die Sperre sich ungewollt übertragen.
Deshalb warnt Riot auch selbst davor, einen eigenen Account auf einem Rechner zu verwenden,
bei dem man einen Hardware-Bann vermutet.
Damit entsteht eine ziemlich ungewöhnliche Situation.
Eine Eigenschaft der Hardware beeinflusst...
Wie soll ich denn bitte schön einen Hardware-Bann vermuten?
...Wert, aber der Käufer kann sie vor dem Kauf praktisch nicht überprüfen.
Und genau deshalb ist dieser kuriose Fall mit dem gebrauchten Ryzen viel interessanter
als nur eine Geschichte über Cheater und Computerspiele.
Unsere Hardware bekommt zunehmend eine digitale Identität.
Und damit kann sie auch eine digitale Vergangenheit bekommen.
Das kann sinnvoll sein.
Gestohrene Smartphones sollen nicht einfach weiterverkauft werden können.
Betrüger sollen nicht durch ein Werksreset alle Schutzmechanismen umgehen können.
Und Cheater sollen nicht fünf Minuten nach einer Sperre mit einem neuen Account weitermachen.
Alles soweit gut.
Aber sobald Hardware den Besitzer wechselt, entsteht ein neues Problem.
Identität des Geräts bleibt gleich.
der Mensch davor nicht.
Vielleicht müssen wir deshalb am Kauf gebrauchter
Elektronik künftig nicht so wirklich schützen,
hat er jetzt nichts gesagt, oder?
Das würde mich auch wundern, was willst du da
großartig dagegen machen?
Sondern auch, was hat dieses Gerät
eigentlich schon erlebt?
Was sagt ihr zu der ganzen Geschichte? Schreibt es gerne in die Kommentare.
Das wird wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen mehr Probleme
geben. Was habe ich da eben gerade oben
rechts gesehen?
Mein Umzug auf
einen neuen Passwortmanager.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich benutze weiterhin Keepers
Keepers beste
Alter, kann ich mal bitte gescheite Shorts angezeigt bekommen?
Ja, Hood Informatik
Der einzige gescheite, der Rest kannst du komplett knicken, Alter
Oh, mir fällt gerade was auf
Leute
Mein KDE, hups, geil
Wenn man nicht richtig
drückt.
Mein Hintergrund ändert sich ja gar nicht mehr
unter KDE.
Guck mal, ich hatte doch unter X
so ein Skript laufen,
was meinen Hintergrund regelmäßig changed.
Das gibt es ja gar nicht mehr.
Aber wir können jetzt mal gucken.
Ich weiß, ChatGPT suckt, aber
wir können das Skript mal kurz
umbauen.
Wie setzt man dann unter KDE Set Background CLI?
Wie geht denn das?
How to set KDE from command line?
Okay.
What the fuck?
Plasma apply wallpaper image.
Okay.
Also kann ich jetzt quasi sagen,
wir gehen jetzt zu Images und applyen da Axte.
Okay.
Nö.
Coffee, Stream.
Das ist debate.
Hast du Linux nur in der VM laufen?
Nee.
Das ist ein Mini-PC.
ein echter echte bär metal ist das aber warum geht das mit dem mach ich das
irgendwie verkehrt plasma apply wallpaper image
ich fand das
Doch, aber ich will ja das Bild zu gewissen Uhrzeiten ändern.
Ein absoluter Pfad braucht man da.
Also, dass man dann quasi sagt, Home, Home, Max, Repos, White People, Happy, Images.
Ah.
I understand.
So, das heißt, sowas brauchen wir.
Gut, dann würde ich sagen,
dann werden wir das jetzt einfach mal hier schnell austauschen.
Weil das geht ja nicht.
So, set background BG night.
Moment, habe ich doch hier schon.
Moment, Leute.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Ich habe das schon mal angepasst.
Ja, funzt ja auch.
Ja, wie, warum
hab ich das da nie gesetzt?
Ich brauch kein Cron.
Ich mach das über...
Es gibt doch bei KDE so Startup-Dinger.
Wie auch immer.
Autostart kann man auch machen.
Add new.
Application.
Restart.
Okay, schauen wir mal.
Ich reboot jetzt einfach.
Ja.
Mal gucken wir mal, ob das jetzt funktioniert.
also muss dann fahrer dass du musst kompletten fahrt angeben dann geht's
passwort high passwort kommt ihr nicht drauf was das passwort ist es ist nicht
123456.
Es ist 123456789.
9.
So, da sind wir.
Hat das jetzt funktioniert?
B, S, A, X,
Grep, Minus, I, Z, B, G.
Ja, Pons, It.
Sehr schön, da sind wir.
Siehst du, so einfach kann es sein.
Ich habe sogar die Vorbereitungsarbeit schon erledigt.
Aber irgendwie habe ich das nie als automatischen Startup eingetragen.
Naja, also in Berlin hatten die immer ein Passwort, sowas in der Richtung Amsterdam 123.
123 Amsterdam.
Läuft da CacheOS? Ja.
CashUS.
Der Grund ist folgender.
Ich habe jahrelang hier,
ihr kennt die Kiste ja vielleicht noch,
ich habe hier so eine Linux-VM benutzt.
Mit Arch Linux drauf.
Ja.
Und mit i3 und X11
war das damals noch und Xorg war das damals noch.
So sah das aus.
Und
irgendwann dachte ich mir mal so,
naja, Wayland ist
jetzt ja schon ganz gut
nutzbar und x wird immer weiter ausgefasst von allen distributionen guck doch mal wie das mit
wailand funktioniert da bin ich zu dem schluss gekommen dass wailand in der vm absolut unusable
ist guck also ihr seht ihr das ist bei mir hier in der vm also hier das ist jetzt die vm kiste
es ist nicht viel unterschied zu meinem kde ja so und ja dann war halt die nächste frau okay was
machen wir und ich hatte noch so ein linux bzw linux ja noch so ein mini pc hier zwar so eine
kiste mit das art schillungs ist vom scratch installieren ja sondern ist ein mini pc da habe
ich mir gedacht ey komm warum nicht mal eines der aktuellen hype us benutzen habe ich zum testen
mal CatchyOS draufgehauen.
Und ich muss sagen, CatchyOS,
ich meine, es ist ja letztendlich ein vollwertiges Archie-Lux
mit ordentlich vorkonfiguriertem KDE,
ordentlichen Default-Settings.
Ich habe nie einen Grund gesehen, warum ich es
runterschmeißen sollte.
Deswegen.
Deswegen KDE.
KDE, ihr kennt meine Meinung
zur Linux-Desktop-Umgebung. KDE ist die
einzig ernstzunehmende Desktop-Umgebung.
also für breite usage die jeder nutzen kann und ich kotzen muss dabei
kann es vergessen xfc ist zu minimalistisch und zu zu zu
zu...
Wie nennt man das?
Nicht
pollisch genug. Einfach auch...
Hat, glaube ich, auch
Mail-In-Probleme.
Omachi, ja, ey,
das checke ich beim besten Willen nicht.
Keine Ahnung.
Also da verstehe ich null
den...
Appeal von Omachi
irgendwie gar nicht.
Ich meine, die vermarkten sich jetzt ja auch irgendwie als
Adjantic OS oder sowas
Aber der DHH, der labert eh gerne irgendwelchen Hype-Krempel
Hier, Beautiful Fun und Adjantic Linux
Vor ein paar Monaten hieß das Ding noch
Beautiful Fun
Irgendwie anders
Ja, mittlerweile sind sie auf einmal Adjantic
Kein Schimmer, wahrscheinlich haben sie das Ding
Weil Adjantic drinne vorkommt
Kriegen sie jetzt Sponsoring
Warum das Sponsoring bekommt?
Letztendlich, Letztendlich, Omachi ist ein Arch-Skin.
Oder so, ein Arch, ein Customized Arch.
Ja, also, ich kann die Anziehungskraft von Omachi nicht verstehen.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich, also, kann ich nicht nachvollziehen.
Ja, das habe ich jetzt schon öfters gelesen, dass der Kerl wohl ein paar, dass der DHH wohl ein paar fragwürdige Aussagen getroffen hat, wobei ich da sagen muss, keine Ahnung, ob das stimmt.
Man sollte da auch, ich bin der Meinung, man sollte da generell vorsichtig sein, indem man die Sachen wieder kaut, nur weil das irgendjemand auf Reddit oder sonst wo gepostet hat, ja.
die Leute sind heute mittlerweile relativ schnell
andere Leute so vorzuverurteilen.
Also ich habe keine Ahnung,
was er gesagt hat, was so schlimm ist.
Also ich weiß nichts von dem,
was er erzählt hat. Keine Ahnung.
Deswegen kann ich das auch nicht
bestätigen, das Gegenteil davon.
Keine Ahnung. Ich habe da keine Meinung über den Kerl.
Ich weiß nur, dass es der Erfinder von Ruby on Rails ist.
Ruby on Rails, eines der
nicest Webframeworks überhaupt ist,
aber ziemlich aus der Mode gekommen.
gibt es da geiz und schon als wird für was du da gemacht hast moment mal etwas
meinst du jetzt meine vm mit mit xorg oder oder mein cash ios hier
beides ja also für die für die vm also ich habe auf github
eine nicht ganz aktuelle Version
von meinen Config-Dateien.
Hier.
Aber viel hat sich ja nicht geändert.
Und wir haben, du kannst
mal im Archiv gucken, wir haben ein paar Einrichtungs-Streams
damals gemacht. Aber das würde ich
jetzt gar nicht mehr so
empfehlen, sich ein Arch
vom Scratch in der VM mit X aufzusetzen.
Also X.org ist halt
auf dem absteigenden Ast und wird auch immer
weiter outgefaced.
github selber läuft auch noch auf ruby und wales zu nehmen nicht ohne unerheblichen teil also wenn
du wenn du anfangen möchtest mit linux auf dem desktop ich glaube das beste ist tatsächlich
sich einen günstigen mini pc zu kaufen und das darauf zu installieren das muss nichts
teures sein ja am besten mit amd grafikkarte intel oder amd nicht entweder
Und eh das Wichtigste zum Linux lernen ist, das kann übrigens auch ohne, natürlich ihr könnt auch ein Linux Mint oder so in der VM installieren, das ist kein Problem, das funktioniert schon.
Du willst mir was flüstern? Du kannst mir nichts flüstern, ich habe Private Messages ausgestellt.
Achso, du meinst, ich soll dir was schreiben
Okay
Weil du es bist
Ich schreib dir was
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt
Wahrscheinlich kommt jetzt ein Aski-Dick-Pick
Oder irgendwie sowas
So, Ekos, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt
Oh ja, das ist...
Äh, Ico ist das gar keine so schlechte Idee.
Aber ich bin da jetzt nicht der wahnsinnige...
Ich arbeite nicht bei HR oder so, ne?
Ich kann dir nur meine Meinung dazu sagen.
Aber anonymisier das ordentlich.
Finde ich nicht verkehrt, ja
Könnten wir mal ausprobieren
Ja gut, das ist jetzt ja wahrscheinlich
Ein bisschen Richtung Verschwörungstheorie
Aber wenn man das hier mal als seine persönliche Meinung sieht
Die Meinung kann man ja teilen oder nicht.
Ah.
Muss man nichts drauf geben und kann auch erzählen, was er will.
Es steht aber auch jedem frei zu sagen, ich will nichts von dem Typ benutzen.
Naja, also zumindest eine Sache, zumindest eine Sache, muss man ja mal sagen.
Also, wenn man mal sich London heute anguckt, London vor 20 Jahren, also optisch hat sich, wie hat der Merz gesagt, das Stadtbild schon geändert.
Ey, ganz ehrlich, mich interessiert das überhaupt nicht, was die Leute so von sich geben.
Es geht mir komplett am Arsch vorbei.
Deswegen kann ich mir auch Twitter und so Sachen
Oder viele Subreddits nicht mehr geben
Laufen bei jedem Scheiß
Will dir irgendwie
Einer seine Weltanschauung aufs Auge drücken
Das geht mir mega auf den Sack
Die sollen mir also nicht auf den Sack gehen
Das fuckt mich nur noch ab
Ja.
Überlegenheit dazu.
Ich kann mich für das
interessieren, was ich will und wenn mir das meiste, die meiste
Weltanschauung der Leute am Arsch vorbeigeht, dann ist
es so.
Es kann mich keiner zwingen, dass ich mich für irgendwas
interessieren muss. Und das meiste,
was die Leute so absondern, egal ob es auf Twitter
oder Reddit ist, geht mir am Arsch vorbei.
Und dass du jetzt definierst,
was für mich Probleme zu
sein haben, ist ja auch wieder sowas.
Also ich finde, so kommen uns doch echt
sehr krass überheblich und das kommt gerade
immer von Leuten, die
wie soll man sagen,
der Ansicht sind,
sie sind irgendwie den anderen
moralisch überlegen.
Die sollen alle mal den Ball flach haben, sich vor allem
alle mal hauptsächlich um ihren eigenen Scheiß kümmern.
Ja, ja.
Ich bin auch
NixOS-Fan, deswegen
moralisch belehren. Klar. Wobei
man eigentlich Arch Linux...
Ich hab kein Problem mit, dass sich das
nervt. Ich hab ein Problem damit, wie das geschrieben
ist. So, als hab ich mich da jetzt
gefälligst für zu interessieren, ja.
Ob dir das gefällt, dass mich
das interessiert oder...
Da hätt ich viel zu tun.
Also, die beste
Hardware für Linux ist
eine, die
nicht absolut bleeding edge
neu ist und die nicht unbedingt
eine Nvidia Grafikkarte hat.
Wobei ich da gelesen habe, dass sich auch viel getan
hat, was Nvidia Treiber Support angeht.
Ähm,
was hast du denn für
Wieso, das ist doch gut
Ist doch top
Ist doch wunderbar für eine Linux-Kiste
Ah, okay
Nvidia-Grafikkarten
sind nicht die geilsten, das stimmt
Wobei meine
persönliche, ich weiß es nicht, ja, ich weiß es nicht
Aber meine persönliche Vermutung ist
Die 1060
ist so alt
Da würde ich mal vermuten, dass sie zumindest
ganz brauchbar läuft unter Linux
mittlerweile.
Aber generell
sind die Treiber
von Nvidia halt ziemlich kacke.
Wie sich das...
Ich weiß ehrlich gesagt auch gar nicht, wie sich das jetzt eigentlich auswirkt.
Aber man liest überall nur, dass es Probleme mit Nvidia-Grafikanten gibt.
Gerade, wenn das halt welche der neueren Generationen sind.
Wayland macht Probleme.
Ja gut, das ist natürlich Kacke.
Ja.
Weil du willst ja aktuell schon, wenn du eine dedizierte Linux-Kiste hast,
dann willst du auch einen aktuellen Desktop mit Wayland benutzen.
Ich meine, man darf nicht vergessen, ich glaube, KDE hat den X-Support jetzt komplett rausgeschmissen, gell, aus ihrer neuesten Version oder werden in ihrer nächsten Version den X-Support komplett rausschmeißen.
Hab ich gelesen.
Ah, also.
Schon.
Das ist auf dem absteigenden Ast.
Ich muss ja sagen, es gibt so ein paar Dinger, wo ich mich so ein bisschen vielleicht als Linux-Boomer outen muss.
Das erste ist, ich bin bis heute kein riesengroßer SystemD-Fan.
Ich mag Warlock gucken, anstatt Journal-CTL.
Ich erkenne schon die Vorteile an, die SystemD gebracht hat.
Ja, ob System D allerdings alles machen muss von DNS bis DHCP und Gedöns? Nun ja, da kann man sich drüber streiten. Ich bin jetzt aber auch niemand, der sagt, ich muss jetzt eine Distro verwenden, die, wie heißt das, OpenRC oder so verwendet und am besten auch noch Xlibre oder sowas.
Also, das muss nicht sein
Ich bleib da schon lieber bei Standardsachen, die gut supported sind
Aber ich bin bis heute kein Riesensystem-D-Fan
Und ich bin der Meinung
Das ist das X
Beziehungsweise X.org
Oder X.11
Also, X.11 ist das Protokoll
X.org ist die Implementierung
Früher war es X.Free 86 oder wie das hieß
Ein paar richtig coole Sachen hatte
Die es halt unter Wayland nicht gibt
Gerade wenn es ums Thema Automatisierung geht, ist X halt, Xdo-Tool und solche Geschichten, tut sich Wayland immer noch schwer.
Und Remote Access. Remote Access mit Wayland ist deutlich eingeschränkter als mit X-basierten Sachen.
Auf X-Org basierende Sachen hast du X-Free-RDP installiert.
Nee, X-RDP, nicht X-Free.
X-RDP installiert, gut, es hat funktioniert.
Du hast die meisten Sachen supported gehabt, von Clipboard bis Drucker und Ordner, die gemountet werden sollen.
Bei Wayland ist es halt so, Wayland ist ja kein Server in dem Sinn.
Wayland ist ja nur die Spezifikation.
Der Standard im Endeffekt.
jeder desktop umgebung muss den ganzen kram selbst nachbauen beziehungsweise selbst implementieren es
gibt wl roots das ist so quasi die referenz implementierung ja und und viele setzen da
auch darauf auf aber beispielsweise knorr ist der komplett eigene implementierung der wale
and geschichte kde hat eine komplett eigene implementierung der wale and geschichte deswegen
gibt es auch viele sachen die auf desktop umgebung nicht oder anders funktionieren weil die
implementierung anders ist und dementsprechend kannst du auch kein x kein rdp server starten
der dann die alle alle wayland sessions handelt ja es gibt denn es gibt ein exo port für wl roots
basierte sachen es gibt in den x es gibt einen rdp server eingebaut in kde der nichts taugt es
gibt einen eingebauten rdp server in gnome der war semi was taugt das ist halt schon besser gewesen
unter x wie gesagt auf der arbeit warum nicht das sage ich gleich was zu ich wusste ich muss
muss zu beiden was sagen das ist aber unter x besser gewesen ich hoffe da tut sich einiges
die nächsten Jahre über. Ja, KDE
beispielsweise, dass das RDP Headless
funktioniert. Das hat ja keinen Sinn, wenn man eingeloggt sein muss und sowas.
Und dass die eben
Gnome supportet viele Sachen nicht. Ja,
der RDP und der Gnome funktioniert ganz okay,
aber die unterstützen beispielsweise
keine gemauten Ordner-Mounts
über RDP und sowas.
Das ist halt ziemlich mies.
So, ähm,
der Sinn, warum ich nicht
Sway verwende, ist folgendes.
Ich habe Sway mal ausprobiert und fand es einen guten i3-Ersatz.
Dann habe ich aber festgestellt, dass Wayland unter VMware halt überhaupt nicht richtig funktioniert.
Und dann bin ich irgendwann auf diesen Linux-Mini-PC gewechselt mit CacheOS.
Und ich habe mir damals schon gedacht, ey, warum probierst du nicht mal KDE aus?
KDE ist halt einfach der massenkompatibelste, beste, supportetste und vollumfänglichste Desktop unter Linux.
Und du kannst mit KDE mehr oder weniger auch eins zu eins das machen, was ich mit einem Tiling Window Manager mache.
Guck mal, was benutze ich bei meinem Tiling Window Manager?
Ich benutze Workspaces mit Anwendung im Fullscreen.
Das kann ich hier auch.
Also für mich ist in der Handhabung das KDE hier kaum ein Unterschied zu meinem i3.
das einzige was ist und das kann man mit karte auch fixen ist wenn ich neue anwendung aufmacht
dann floh zu die übrigens bei der wii windows ist auch ein faktor ich brauche unbedingt wap
die windows ohne wap die windows geht nix hier leute guckt es war wie geil es war bild und
deswegen kann ich bin jetzt dahin geblieben ich benutze es mehr oder weniger wie drei und ich habe
einen super desktop den ich nicht wie der letzte verrückte customizen muss damit er ordentlich
benutzbar ist ja i3 muss man schon echt viel machen du hast dir beispielsweise eine applikation
launcher mit dabei einen clipboard manager mit dabei und solche geschichten wobei ich ja meine
meinem profi setup immer noch ein bisschen hinterher trauere es ist es ist letztendlich
die usability sache und dass ich mich weniger um konflikt mehr um sachen kümmern will deswegen
hänge ich jetzt auf kenne ich hänge ich jetzt auf karte und bleibt da bleibt da wahrscheinlich auch
als fiese auch möglich einzelbe zu lernen natürlich gerade als fiese als was denn sonst oder wie meinst
du das also gerade als fiese solltest du ein so belehren weil infrastruktur professionierung
konfiguration wahrscheinlich eines der haupt dinger ist in im aufgabenbereich eines fies
Du solltest dir zwei Sachen angucken. Das erste ist Ansible, das zweite ist Terraform. Du kannst auch beide schön in Kombination verwenden, aber je nachdem, was der Schwerpunkt ist, ist das eine halt besser als das andere. Willst du Infrastruktur hauptsächlich professionieren, wo es nicht viel Setup braucht, gerade weil es halt Kisten sind, die man schnell wegschmeißen kann, wieder neu aufbauen kann, dann Terraform. Willst du nach dem Aufbau die Sachen noch halbwegs komplex konfigurieren, dann Ansible.
Zumal ja inzwischen auch EU-Steuergelder in KDE wandern.
Das habe ich letztens auch gelesen.
Aber der Witz ist, also generell muss man mal gucken,
die, also was für Gelder bei KDE oder Gnome oder so ankommen.
Ich glaube, Gnome hatte letzten Monat, glaube ich, oder letztes Jahr sogar, irgendein größeres Open Source Projekt, hatte ganze 8000 Euro Spenden.
Ich weiß nicht mehr, was es war.
Es war irgendein richtig großes Projekt, kaum Spenden und dann kriegt so eine Distro wie Omachi Millionen, Alter.
Die sollen das lieber mal an KDE spenden.
Puppet, das kenne ich auch noch.
Puppet habe ich lange Jahre auch gemacht. Ich habe auch viele Git-Repos damals betreut, so mit gucken, Merch-Requests rein und dann ausrollen und gedöhnen, so ein Puppet-Apply und erst das in Test, dann in Int, dann in Prot und ja, Puppet habe ich viel gemacht.
Ansible ist deutlich angenehmer als Puppet.
Eine Sache gibt es allerdings, die Puppet meiner Meinung nach besser kann als Ansible.
Und das sind No-Op-Runs.
Du kannst bei Ansible Try-Runs machen, aber das muss der Provider dann oder wie heißt das Ding?
Modul richtig unterstützen und sowas.
Also das war in Puppet besser.
Der Rest ist in Ansible alles tausendfach besser.
Kadir hat auch über eine Million bekommen. Ja, wunderbar.
Also, Ansible
ist ein bisschen, hat ein bisschen Einstiegskurve,
aber das hält sich in Grenzen. Ganz ehrlich,
Ansible ist
verhältnismäßig easy zu lernen.
Was gibt's heute zu futtern? Das weiß ich
noch gar nicht genau. Ich hab noch
Spaghetti von gestern übrig, aber die haben mir gestern nicht geschmeckt.
Also, esse ich heute wahrscheinlich nicht.
Irgendwas anderes. Weiß ich auch nicht.
Keine Ahnung.
So, also,
Also, Ansible hat halt eine super Doku.
Ja, das hier meinte Ansible.
Bild in sowas hier.
Copy, da kannst du gucken, alles was das kann.
Also, da haben die wirklich sehr viel Zeug drin.
Ja, und auch wirklich eine gute Doku, wie du das verwendest.
Sogar mit Examples und so drunter.
Also, mit Ansible kommst du schon weit.
Und wenn du so Basic-Sachen erstmal machen möchtest,
Du willst beispielsweise, dass alle Linux-Systeme Hardtop installiert haben.
Das ist easy in Ansible.
Man kann Ansible auch übertrieben komplex machen.
Irgendwann fangen die Leute dann an, mit Tower rumzuhantieren.
Wobei man da sagen muss, naja, das Projekt ist ziemlich am Abkacken.
Red Hat hat jetzt so die Bezahlversion mit AAP am Start.
Aktualisieren ihre ganzen Sachen nicht mehr.
So, Sekunde.
Ruby.
Ja, also Ansible solltest du auf jeden Fall lernen.
Das ist sinnvoll.
Oh, Leute, es gibt was zu essen.
Jetzt wird es ernst.
Ja, so, wir sind wieder am Start.
Also ich muss gleich was fordern.
Was wollte ich jetzt gerade noch sagen?
Ja, also man kann Ansible auch super komplex machen und kompliziert,
Aber wenn du so Sachen willst, jede Linux-Kiste soll Hardtop drauf haben und, was weiß ich, D-Stat und irgendwelche.
Dafür ist Ansible wunderbar.
Du kannst dann auch so checken wie SSH-Config-Options und sowas.
Kann ich dir nur empfehlen.
Wer hat denn das nochmal gefragt?
Der Grapefruit-Lover.
Dafür ist das super fürs Professionieren von Hardware.
Du kannst einiges mit Ansible auch machen, weil es für alles mögliche Module gibt.
zum professionieren von hart also damit ist gemeint zum erstellen zum anlegen
ja hardware wird ja heute kaum noch eingebaut in der sache ich muss kommen
zurück hatte mit eingebaut aber server nicht hardware server die du heutzutage
benutzt wir sind ja selten das einheitsrechenzentrum muss was ins
rack anstöpseln muss trommannschaft letztendlich anstöpseln wie lands
anlegen ist ja heute nicht mehr heute sind ja 99 prozent der fälle sind vor
oder irgendwelche anderen managed kisten container cloud sql datenbanken und das machst du mit
terraform also mit terraform kannst du infrastruktur anlegen hauptsächlich bei cloud anbietern aber je
nachdem was ihr verwendet wenn ihr beispielsweise vmware verwendet oder proxmox verwendet als
virtualisierung kannst das auch also mit terraform legst du deine server an mit ansible konfigurierst
du deine server wenn du es ein bisschen so im so daten ich damals der aktuelle zeit geist was
server angeht ist dass es wenig konfiguration auf dem server selbst gibt also spricht dass
du server möglichst einfach löschen und wieder hinstellen kannst das ist aufgekommen mit container
orchestrierung im kubernetes umfeld ja dass das möglichst wie spricht man das aus leute
wie auch immer ist alles hat natürlich den vorteil du kannst easy server erstellen und
wegschmeißen muss aber halt gucken wo deine konfiguration liegt ja die muss dann irgendwo
anders außerhalb des systems liegen wenn es welche braucht und deswegen würde ich dir empfehlen
einfach dir beides anzugucken weil beides sich auch sehr gut kombinieren lässt und sehr gut
miteinander harmoniert ja du kannst zum beispiel per terraform 15 vms erzeugen
und in terraform lässt du den in-it command laufen war also server
initialisierung skript was unter der haube einfach terraform aufruft schwachsinn
unter der haube einfach ansible aufruft sich aus dem repo seine config
auscheckt und den server konfiguriert da hast du quasi mit einem klick oder
klick stimmt nicht mit einem tastendruck oder zwei tasten drucken hast du 15
server stehen die sich automatisch hochziehen je nachdem wie du wie gut
ein deployment läuft sogar automatisch deployen also terraform und ansatz und
beides und beides da muss ich muss ich dem rom in die recht geben
beides ist nicht sonderlich kompliziert also du kommst ohne probleme da rein als
als fisi würde ich dir empfehlen fangen mit ansatz und wenn du dann in
richtung professionierung was cloud infrastruktur angeht und so ein bisschen
mehr gehst, dann auch Terraform, aber
gerade wenn du viel händisch auf
Servern aktuell machst, ist Ansible wirklich
gut, weil was Ansible auch kann ist,
Ansible kann auch auf 50
Servern, die einem speziellen Muster
entsprechen, einfach ein Kommando ausführen.
Wenn du sagst, oh, mich würde jetzt mal
interessieren, welcher Server wurde heute Nacht
restartet, dann sagst du einfach
hier Ansible, bla bla bla,
ad hoc
Command, uptime
auf allen Produktionsservern.
Bam.
oder sie abteilen
ja genau da gibt es noch geht runner ja moment das wieder das ist wieder was
an das ist ja das eine hat mit dem anderen gar nichts zu tun
geht lab bzw github actions runner die das sind vor allem meistens oder
container meistens die github oder github workflows bzw github actions
ausführen das ist was aus der richtung continuous integration continuous delivery schräg schräg
deployment das sind workflows die kannst du auch verwenden wenn du sachen automatisieren willst
das ist aber weder noch das eine noch das andere also zum beispiel wir machen mal ein beispiel was
was alle drei Sachen verwendet.
Also, stell dir mal vor,
ihr habt ein Entwicklerteam.
Das Entwicklerteam möchte ihre Anwendung testen.
Bisher ist es so,
der Entwickler ruft dich an,
du installierst ihm eine VM mit Ubuntu drauf
oder Debian drauf,
du installierst ihm ein Java drauf,
du richtest ihm einen User ein,
du gibst ihm den Userzugang,
userzugang für sein deployment verzeichnis er schiebt seine anwendung drauf erstattet die anwendung probiert was aus
das haben wir mal so das wäre so der der alte oldschool workflow ja da macht euch ein ticket auf oder ruft dich an
wir können das ist natürlich automatisieren könnte es sagen
wenn der entwickler
In seinem github repo
terraform config pusht
dann läuft eine automatische github action die das terraform applied und die
server aufbaut und nach dem server aufbau läuft automatisch ansammeln was
die server konfiguriert und der entwickler ist happy weil er per e mail
sein ssh zugang geschickt bekommt kannst du automatisiert waren also das greift
alles ein bisschen ineinander deswegen ist es nicht ist es nicht
verkehrt sich alles mal ein bisschen einzeln anzugucken
Und wenn man bei allem einen ganz guten Überblick hat, weiß man dann auch, wie man das ganz gut verzahnen kann.
Aber da geht auf jeden Fall der Trend hin, manuelles Server streicheln ist out.
Was auch gut ist, weil da wird so viele Sachen vergessen.
Ah, wir brauchen Application Server D.
Aktuell haben wir A, B, C.
Oh, was haben wir da jetzt noch alles gemacht?
Wir brauchen das drauf, das drauf.
Oh Mist, jetzt gibt es ja nur eine andere Java Version.
Oh, wie ist das? Das habe ich vergessen.
Ah, Lautbalanzereintrag vergessen, bla bla bla. Also der aktuelle Trend und der finde ich ist auch ein guter Trend ist, die Wahrheit liegt in irgendeinem Git-Repo drin und wird dann über irgendwelche Workflow-Tools, Professionierungstools applied und angewendet.
angewendet das ist so der aktuelle gedanke der sich da so durchgesetzt hat
ja und im ago cd habe ich noch nicht gemacht aber du kannst ago cd auch für
server management beziehungsweise für server professionierung verwenden das
geht in kombination mit cross playing glaube ich geht das ganz gut und
Vielleicht gibt es ja auch was für Terraform.
Habe ich aber selbst noch nicht gemacht.
Also mit Crossplane kannst du zum Beispiel Custom Resource Definitions für Kubernetes anlegen,
die dann unter der Haube beispielsweise eine Cloud SQL Datenbank erstellen, außerhalb vom Cluster.
Der Trend ist eher... Na gut, das ist der Trend beim Umsetzen. Mit Trend meine ich jetzt von der Methodik her.
Vom Umsetzen her, ja, gut.
So, aber Chatgeleute,
schön, dass ihr dabei wart. Ich muss jetzt
unbedingt was fressen. Ich hab mega Hunger.
Power
off. Bam.
Wir sehen uns
dann wieder
im nächsten Stream. Heute hab ich 4,5 Stunden
oder 4 Stunden 15 einfach nur gelabert.
Ich merk schon im Hals. Ich hab kaum Videos
geguckt, kaum Sachen. Ich hab einfach nur 4 Stunden
15 durchgeschwätzt.
Okay. Gut, Leute. Bis dann. Macht's gut. Wir sehen uns.
Moment, warte mal.
Und jetzt alles komplizierter zu machen, was?
Lohnt es sich noch Container? Klar.
Container sind eines der wichtigsten Skills, die du brauchst.
Guck dir an, wie du einen Docker-Container baust.
Und danach kommt das eins zum anderen.
Das ist alles, gerade für Feezy, ist das eines der wichtigsten Sachen.
Linux-Containerisierung, Automatisierung,
Infrastrukturprovisionierung, automatische
Workflows. Das ist wichtig
heutzutage. So, Leute, ich bin jetzt
auf. Bis dann, macht's gut. CU.